THE SENATE NOW TO RESEARCH THE
WATER COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING AS WE TAKE
SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVE IN NINETEEN
RISKS THE SENATE CONTINUES
TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC AND
HAS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON AND TELECONFERENCE
BURKE DISSIPATION FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS PUSHED ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE ALLEN
OUTSIDE NOW TODAY'S PURCHASE
BEEN NUMBERS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE
IN THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN
THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE
HOW MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
HEARING HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY
IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS NEEDED
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE -- STREET
BUILDING AND ASK ALL MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENT IN ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND WE'RE
GONNA START TODAY IS A SUB
COMMITTEE -- SO WE'RE NOT GONNA
DO A QUORUM CALL JUST YET BUT
I'M HOPING MEMBERS CAN MAKE IT
IT IS A VERY BUSY MORNING WITH
LOTS OF OVERLAPPING COMMITTEES
A WE DO HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY FOUR OF WHICH
ARE IN PROPOSED CONSENT --
THAT'S A FILE ITEMS SIX SEVEN
EIGHT AND NINE -- END
UP BEFORE WE GET STARTED
I SHOULD ALSO NOTE THAT --
WE MAY -- WOULD WILL BE LIMITING
TESTIMONY FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION -- TO THE TOTAL
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR EACH
SIDE ON BILLS COMING BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY AS WELL
AS EACH SIDE BEING PERMITTED
THREE MINUTES TOTAL FOR
THEIR TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
-- SO LET'S GET STARTED AND
I THINK FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
IS S. B. NINE FIFTY THREE SO
CENTER MAN IF YOU'RE UP FOR TO
PRESENT TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION
AND THANK YOU CHAIR STERN VERY
GOOD THANK HIGH AND I WANT TO
THANK COMMITTEE STAFF WHO'VE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH US
ON THIS BILL AS WELL AS --
THE VERY STAKEHOLDERS BOTH IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WE'VE
BEEN WORKING CLOSE WITH CLOSELY
WITH I ALSO WANT TO BEGIN BY
SAYING THAT WHEN I FIRST RAN
FOR THE OFFICE I NOW HOLD I
NEVER THOUGHT IT INTRODUCED
A BILL LIKE THIS I DO BELIEVE
CLIMATE CRISIS IS AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT PERSONALIZATION I WE HAVE
TO ACT BOLDLY AND DECISIVELY
TO MEET THIS CHALLENGE HEAD
ON AT THE SAME TIME I I
FOCUS MY EFFORTS ON ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS AND
I HAVE TO CONFESS DID NOT PAY
MUCH ATTENTION TO THE TWENTY
EIGHT PLATFORMS OFF THE COAST
OF CALIFORNIA I IS HE SAID
THAT'S ACTIVELY BEEN SUBJECT A
MORATORIUM ON NEW DRILLING SINCE
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES BUT THEN
THE EVENTS OF LAST FALL OCCURRED
AND AS YOU ALL KNOW IN OCTOBER
AND MAJOR OIL SPILL TOOK PLACE
OFF THE COAST OF ORANGE COUNTY
RIGHT OFF OF HUNTINGTON BEACH
ORIGINATING FROM AN UNDERWATER
PIPELINE CONNECTED TO PLATFORM
ELLIE APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND GALLONS OF OIL SPILLED
INTO COASTAL WATERS KILLING
BIRDS AND FISH FORCING BEACH
CLOSURES AND HURTING LOCAL
ECONOMIES IN HUNTINGTON BEACH
NEWPORT BEACH AND LAGUNA BEACH
WHICH IS THE CITIES I REPRESENT
IT TOOK NEARLY FIFTEEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE IN ALMOST THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO CLEAN UP THE SPILL
NOT INCLUDING FEDERAL COSTS
AND FRANKLY WE DODGED A BULLET
THE HUNTINGTON BEACH OIL SPILL
WAS ORIGINALLY PREDICTED TO
BE MUCH MUCH WORSE ON AN ORDER
OF MAGNITUDE SIMILAR TO THE
REFUGIO BEACH OIL SPILL IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN WHICH SHUT DOWN
SANTA BARBARA COASTLINE FOR SIX
MONTHS FORTUNATELY THE SMELL
THIS BILL IS MUCH SMALLER THAN
EXPECTED AND WE ALSO BENEFITED
FROM A TIMELY STORM THAT BLEW
IN THE NEXT NIGHT PUSHING MOST
OF THE OIL RESIDUE OUT TO SEA
AND WE FOR OUR COASTLINE BUT
NONE THE LESS THIS CLOSE OUR
BEACHES FOR A WEEK I HAD A
MASSIVE ECONOMIC IMPACT AND THEN
JUST AS WE'VE BEEN CUT BECAUSE
BEGUN RECOVERING FROM THIS EVENT
ONLY TWO MONTHS AFTER THE SPILL
A RUPTURE OIL PIPELINE FROM
PLATFORM EVA EXPERIENCE ANOTHER
LEAK NOW AS I SAID EARLIER
I BELIEVE CLIMATE CHANGE IS A
PRESSING ISSUE FOR US BUT EVEN
IF YOU DON'T AGREE WITH THAT I
THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT THE RISKS
POSED BY OFFSHORE DRILLING ARE
NOT JUSTIFIED BY THEIR BENEFITS
OFFSHORE OIL PRODUCTION IN BOTH
FEDERAL AND STATE WATERS IN
CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTS FOR LESS
THAN POINT THREE PERCENT OF
ANNUAL PRODUCTION UNITED STATES
THAT'S NOT EVEN A DROP IN THE
BUCKET AT THE SAME TIME THESE
OFFSHORE RIGS THREATEN A VIBRANT
CALIFORNIA COASTAL KANEMI THAT
GENERATES FORTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY AND EMPLOYS OVER A HALF
MILLION CALIFORNIANS FULL
COASTLINE AND PRECIOUS MARINE
ECOSYSTEMS ARE ALSO CORE PART OF
AYE OUR IDENTITY IS CALIFORNIANS
NOT ONLY IN COASTAL COMMUNITIES
LIKE THE ONES I REPRESENT BUT
ALSO ACROSS THE STATE PEOPLE
FROM ENGLAND FLOCKED OUR BEACHES
AND COASTLINES BECAUSE THIS IS
PART OF WHO WE ARE A CORE PART
OF WHO WE ARE CALIFORNIANS AND
LET'S BE CLEAR THE PLATFORMS
OFFER COSTAR KICKING TIME BOMBS
THE REMAINING LEASES ARE LARGELY
HELD BY THINLY CAPITALIZED FIRMS
THAT DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO REPAY TAXPAYERS IN THE EVENT
OF ANOTHER MAJOR OIL SPILL
AND DON'T HAVE THE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO INVEST IN AGING
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WAS PUT
IN PLACE IN NINETEEN SEVENTIES
AND NINETEEN EIGHTIES ANOTHER
MAJOR OIL SPILL IS INEVITABLE
UNLESS WE AND OFFSHORE DRILLING
IT'S TIME TO PUT AN END TO THE
USE OF THIS AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND AID THE STATE IS TRANSITION
TOWARDS MORE SUSTAINABLE
RESOURCE PROCUREMENT WE HAVE
AN APPROACH THAT WE BELIEVE IS
FAIR TRANSPARENT AND WELL WE'LL
AN OFFSHORE DRILLING IN STATE
WATERS WITHIN TWO YEARS HERE'S
WHAT OUR BILL WOULD DO FIRST
IT REQUIRES THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION TO COMPLETE WITHIN
ONE YEAR AN AMORTIZATION STUDY
ASSESSING THE FAIR MARKET VALUE
OF THESE LEASES INCLUDING BOTH
THE ANTICIPATED PROFITS AND ALSO
IMPORTANTLY THE COST OF CAPPING
AND DECOMMISSIONING THESE
REQS WE PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
DISCRETION LANDS COMMISSION
TO CONDUCT THE STUDY AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THEY WILL
COME TO EXPLORE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR DECOMMISSIONING
AS PART OF THEIR STUDY SECOND
OUR BILL WOULD DIRECT LANDS
COMMISSION TO TRY TO NEGOTIATE
A VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT WITH THE
LEASEHOLDERS OPERATING STATE
WATERS TO AN OIL PRODUCTION WITH
COMPENSATION PROVIDED BASED ON
THE FINDINGS OF THE AFFIRMATION
AMORTIZATION STUDY THIS IS THE
CORE PART OF OUR BILL WE ARE
HOPING THAT LANCE COMMISSION
AND THE OPERATORS CAN REACH
A VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT AND WE
GIVE THEM A TWO YEAR WINDOW
UNTIL DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR TO TRY
TO REACH THAT AGREEMENT THIRD
IF ANY GREEN IS NOT REACHED BY
THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
THIS BILL WOULD INSTRUCT LANDS
COMMISSION TO TERMINATE THE
LEASES FOR OIL PRODUCTION IN
STATE WATERS AND PROVIDE JUST
COMPENSATION TO THESE LEASE
HOLDERS BASED ON THE FAIR MARKET
VALUE AS DETERMINED BY THEIR
IMMUNIZATION STUDY WE ARE TRYING
TO PROVIDE LANDS COMMISSION
WITH THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO
COME TO A NEGOTIATED SETTLEMENT
AND THAT IS REALLY WHAT THE
OUTCOME THAT WE'RE HOPING FOR
NOW I ALSO WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT THE IMPACT OF JOBS HAS
TO BE A CORE PART OF THIS BILL
THE HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN
ON THESE RIGS DESERVE A FAIR
TRANSITION AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WANT TO BE PART OF THIS
PROCESS WERE OPEN TO WORKING
WITH DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS TO
TRY TO DEVELOP VARIOUS OPTIONS
FOR THESE WORKERS I ALSO WANT
TO THANK OPPOSITION WHICH HAS
BEEN VERY OPEN TO WORKING WITH
OUR OFFICE WE'VE HAD CLOSE
AND CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
OPPOSITION WE BELIEVE THE
BILL HAS MOVED INTERACTION HAS
ADDRESSED MANY OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY OPPOSITION AND SHOULD
THIS BILL MOVE OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY -- YOU HAVE MY WORD THAT
WILL CONTINUE -- HAVING THESE
DISCUSSIONS LOOKING TO TRY TO
COME TO A PLACE WHERE WE ADDRESS
THE REMAINING CONCERNS I ALSO
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THIS BILL
IMPACTS JUST THREE OFF SHORE
-- IN CRACK GAS PLATFORMS
PLATFORMS EVA ANNIE AND ESTHER
ALL OF WHICH CURRENTLY OPERATE
OFF THE COAST OF ORANGE COUNTY
THESE PLATFORMS WERE CONSTRUCTED
BETWEEN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
AND NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
I ALSO WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS BILL CREATES A FRAMEWORK
THAT IS FRANKLY A MUCH BETTER
DEAL FOR TAXPAYERS THAN THE
STATUS QUO TOO MANY OF THE
REMAINING LEASEHOLDERS HAVE
A HEADS I WIN TAILS YOU LOSE
SITUATION WHERE IF THERE'S A
MAJOR OIL SPILL THEY DECLARE
BANKRUPTCY THEY DON'T HAVE THE
FUNDS TO PAY OFF THE COST TO
TAXPAYERS IF THEY DRAINED THE
LEASES DRY AND WALK AWAY AS WE
SAW WITH PLATFORM HOLLY ARE THEY
WALK AWAY DECLARE BANKRUPTCY
AND LEAVE THE TAXPAYER HOLDING
THEY'LL IN THE CASE OF PLATFORM
HOLLY THAT BILL IS ESTIMATED TO
BE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
I SO WHAT ARE BILL WOULD DO
IS ACCOUNT FOR THE COSTS OF
DECOMMISSIONING UP FRONT MAKE
THAT PART OF THE FAIR MARKET
VALUE I IN IS AGAIN A A GOOD
DEAL FOR TAXPAYERS IT'S A
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE APPROACH
NO MORE TORRANCE ARE NOT ENOUGH
WE HAVE TO END THE DRILLING IF
WE WANT TO STOP THIS BILLING AND
WE WE SEE THIS IN STILL AFTER
SPILL OUT THE EFFECTS ON WHO
WE ARE CALIFORNIANS I WANT TO
TELL BREE STORY BEFORE TURNING
OVER MY WITNESSES I JUST ABOUT
TWO YEARS AFTER I WAS BORN MY
DAD WAS A DOCTOR IN MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING WAS DECIDING WHETHER
TO ACCEPT A POSITION AN ACADEMIC
POSITION IN THE MIDWEST OR TO
JOIN LOCKHEED MARTIN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA HE CAME OUT HERE
INTERVIEWED AND THEN DECIDE
TO DRIVE A FEW MINUTES THE
COASTLINE HE BY HIMSELF A FISH
SANDWICH TOOK OFF HIS SHOES AND
SOCKS WALKED ALONG THE WATER
ALONG THE SHORELINE WHILE EATING
HIS DINNER AND THOUGHT HIMSELF
THIS IS WHAT I WANT FOR MY LIFE
AND THAT'S HOW I ENDED UP IN
CALIFORNIA AS A YOUNG KID MY
BROTHER MY FAMILY GOING UP HERE
-- AND THAT'S REALLY THE STORY
OF COUNTLESS CALIFORNIANS OUR
COASTLINE IS WHO WE ARE AND IT'S
WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR COASTLINE
FROM THE CONSTANT SPECTER OF
OIL SPILLS ARE BILL WOULD DO
THAT IN RESPONSIBLE TRANSPARENT
AND FAIR WAY SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND I
WANT IT NOW INTRODUCED MY ONE
WITNESS FOR TODAY VICTORIA ROME
OF NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL TESTIFYING ABOUT THE
THANK YOU SO MUCH NO TURN LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES MISTER MS ROOM
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN SENATOR
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YEAH
WE GOT YOUR OKAY
GREAT THIS IS VICTORIA ROOM WITH
ENERGY THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL AND WE SUPPORT
SB NINE FIFTY THREE BECAUSE
IT PROVIDES A PATHWAY TO END
OFFSHORE OIL DRILLING IN STATE
WATERS AS STATED OFFSHORE
DRILLING THREATENS OUR ECONOMY
WILDLIFE OCEAN ECOSYSTEMS AND
COASTAL COMMUNITIES ARE COAST
AND BEACHES DRAW MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
VISITORS EACH YEAR HAS SELECTED
IN A MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
COASTAL ECONOMY THAT EMPLOYS
OVER HALF A MILLION CALIFORNIANS
THE ONLY WAY TO PREVENT MORE
OIL RELATED DISASTERS LIKE THE
ONE WE EXPERIENCE IN OCTOBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS TO
TURN TRANSITION OFF OF FOSSIL
FUELS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
SB NINE FIFTY THREE AND THE
RESPONSIBLE BILL THAT ALLOWS
FOR NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
INDUSTRY ON HOW TO VOLUNTARILY
RELINQUISH THEIR STATE LEASES
IF AN AGREEMENT CAN'T BE
REACHED SB NINE FIFTY THREE
REQUIRES TERMINATION OF THOSE
LEASES WITH FAIR COMPENSATION
PROVIDED TO THE LEASEHOLDERS
THIS BILL IS A REAL OPPORTUNITY
TO PHASE OUT OFFSHORE DRILLING
IN STATE WATERS AND ENERGY
C. AS THE COLD REPORT I'VE
ALSO BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE CENTER AND THE CLEAN
FEES LOBBYING COALITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
-- NOW WE WILL TURN TO OUR
LINES -- FOR GENERAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT -- SO FOR
LET ME SEE YOUR SHORT WE'RE
GONNA TAKE FIFTEEN MINUTES PER
SIDE FOR ALL BILL'S GOING
FORWARD IN THIS HEARING
SO -- LET'S START HERE
WITH ANY GENERAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WELCOME
NICHOLAS SACKETT SOCIAL
COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
MELISSA ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIANS
ARE MENTAL VOTERS SUPPORTING THE
BILLING CONCEPT THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS HARD WORK AND STUFF ON
THIS BILL URGED THE COMMITTEE TO
VOTE YES THANK YOU MANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT SEEING THAT WILL
TURN THE LINES A MODERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL ANY GENERAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL THIS WEEK
IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME IT WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE TWENTY GO AT
GOOD MORNING GETTING A PRODUCT
THEY HAVE THEIR CLUB CALIFORNIA
WE CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BALLOT SHARED
A LETTER BUT I'M CONCERNED WE
HAVE A DOCTOR IN THE COMMITTEE
BUT WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE OUT
THERE WORKING WITH THAT AND WE
HELP THE BILL WILL MOVE FORWARD
TODAY WE CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
OTHER GENERAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT LINE FORTY EIGHT
THE MORNING THIS IS
BEN GRANDY SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AND TRUNK
FOR THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT
LINE SIXTY FIVE
HI THIS IS JUDY MAN COUSTEAU
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY
COMMITTEE AND LAGUNA BEACH AND
CANDIDATE ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SEVENTY TWO I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
NEXT LINE SEVENTY FIVE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBER
IS RELATIVELY QUIET AND YOUR
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
LINE TWENTY FOUR
ERIN GILBERT BUT THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO
IN SUPPORT THANKS NEXT
LINE THIRTY SIX
THIS IS SAID DR JIM STEWART
FROM LONG BEACH CLOSE THESE
WELLS DOWN THANK YOU NEXT
LINE TWENTY FIVE
GOOD MORNING VALERIE
COUNTRY HARDLY THREE FIFTY
BAY AREA ACTION STRONGLY
SUPPORTING THANK YOU
NEXT LINE SEVENTY THREE
SHERRI WE'RE THREE FIFTEEN SOUTH
PLAN LEGISLATIVE ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
LINE SIXTY TWO
GOOD MORNING LITTLE BY LITTLE
GOING THROUGH THE BOILERMAKERS
LOCAL FIVE FORTY NINE OPPOSED
SB NINE FIFTY THREE OKAY
WILL NOT YOU IN OPPOSITION
BUT RIGHT NOW WE'RE JUST DOING
GENERAL SUPPORT -- SO NEXT
LINE TWENTY FIVE
BY TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
MOVING ON TO LINE FORTY SIX
JACKETS FRIEDMAN -- NILA CLIMATE
SELECTIVE AND I MEAN IT'S AN
ACTION LOS ANGELES ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU I WILL NOW TURN
TO THE GENERAL WITNESSES
IT ACTUALLY WHEN THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION OF THE LEAD WITNESSES
SO WHAT THREE MINUTES ANDERSON
WE'VE TO LEAD OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY -- AS WELL IN TIME TO
MISTER NERO -- YOU WANT TO
SHARE YOUR MEMBERS ON ONE TIME
FOR THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
INDEPENDENT OIL AND NATURAL GAS
PRODUCER SERVICES AND SUPPLY
COMPANIES AND ROYALTY OWNERS
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR MEN AND HIS STAFF AND
A BILL FOR WORKING WITH US
DURING THE PROCESS WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE IT -- WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL IN THIS INITIAL FORM --
AT THIS TIME HOWEVER WE DO NOT
OPPOSE THE AMORTIZATION STUDY
BUT WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE
CLAUSE IN THE BILL THAT SAYS
AND I'LL PARAPHRASE SECTION
TWO OF THE BILL SUB SECTION
FIVE SUBSECTION SEE IF THE
COMMISSION IS UNABLE TO REACH
AN AGREEMENT WITH THE LESSEES
THAT RESULTS IN VOLUNTARY
RELINQUISHMENT OF THE LEASES BY
TWENTY TWENTY FOR THE COMMISSION
SHALL TERMINATE THE LEASES
AND PROVIDE FAIR COMPENSATION
AS DETERMINED THROUGH THE
AMORTIZATION STUDY TO THE
LASSIES OF THIS CLAUSE WOULD
ONLY BE INVOKED IF THE OPERATORS
BELIEVE THE OFFER PRICE IS IN
DISPUTE MEANING IT'S TOO LOW
IF THE OFFER PRICES IN DISPUTE
THE ENTIRE TRANSACTION WOULD END
UP IN COURT WITH THE OPERATORS
FILING A TAKINGS CLAIM THAT
COULD COST THE STATE AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY AND THE GOAL
OF THIS BILL WOULD BE DELAYED
FOR YEARS OR PERHAPS NEVER
ACHIEVED AT ALL -- THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO ACHIEVE THE
GOAL OF THIS BILL WOULD BE TO
ARRIVE AT THE FAIR MARKET VALUE
OF THE ASSET TO MAKE AN OFFER
TO THE OFFSHORE PRODUCERS THAT
WOULD MAKE THEM WHOLE -- BE
MINDFUL ALSO THAT REDUCING IN
STATE CLIMATE COMPLIANT CRUDE
PRODUCTION MEANS REPLACING IT
WITH TANKARD CRUDE FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES AND TANKERS ARE
OFFSHORE OIL TANKER SPILL
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
CATASTROPHIC TANKERS ARE TICKING
TIME BOMBS AND CAUSED THE ORANGE
COUNTY OIL SPILL LAST YEAR
CIPR RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NO
VOTE THANK YOU NEXT
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CALDEIRA
REPRESENTING THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
-- WITH THE CHAIRS APPROVAL
I'D LIKE TO HAVE CHRISTIANITY
PRESENT ON MY BEHALF OKAY
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRIS HANNAN I'M AN EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY OF THE LOS ANGELES
ORANGE COUNTY'S BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND HARD WORKING
SKILLED MEN AND WOMEN WE
REPRESENT WE SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB NINE FIFTY THREE
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING
TO CURVE THE DEMAND
OF LOCAL ENERGY
INCLUDING OIL GASOLINE
-- THIS BILL DOES
NOT MITIGATE RISK --
OIL COMING FROM ANOTHER PART OF
THE WORLD ANOTHER PART OF THE
COUNTRY DELIVERED TO CALIFORNIA
IN SHIPS TRAVELING HALFWAY
AROUND THE WORLD DOES NOT
MITIGATE RISK THE PORTS IN
THIS COUNTRY INCLUDING THE PARTS
OF LONG BEACH AND LOS ANGELES
ARE BACKED UP THERE IS
AN EXTREME AMOUNT OF TRAFFIC IN
THERE AND INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF SHIPS COMING IN THERE FOR
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN PRODUCE
SAFER QUITE FRANKLY THAN ANY
OTHER PLACE IN THE WORLD DOES
NOT MITIGATE ANY RISK THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS MORNING
AND WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE NINE
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY PRECIADO IT WILL NOT
TURN TO GENERAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION A MODERATE EARTHQUAKE
TURNED ACTUALLY SORRY IN THE
HEARING ROOM FIRST STURDIER
A MISTER KAREN MEMBERS POLLED
YOU'RE A REPRESENTING WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION VERY GOOD THANKS
ANY OTHERS SEEING NONE
WILL TURN THE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR GENERAL IN THOSE IN
OPPOSITION THE BOSTON OPPOSITION
COULD PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY THREE GO AHEAD
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
YEAH THIS IS MANAGED CARE
ON THAT THE MODERATE FACTORS
COUNTY BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL WHEN STRONG
OPPOSITION S. B. NINE FIVE
THREE WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TREATY CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
ONE THIRTY TWO
YES GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
THIS IS COREY VAN RIGHT VALLEY
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL STANDING WITH THE STATE
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION TO NINE
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE FIFTY SEVEN
THANK YOU FOR THE MORNING
THE FEDERAL LEFT WE'RE
BELIEBERS DISTRICTS DON'T
BELIEVE DONNA CALIFORNIA AND
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NINE THIRTY NINE
THE DRUG FROM OUR WITH THE
CEMENT MASONS LOCAL FOUR
HUNDRED -- WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES -- IN
A POSITION OF SB NINE FIFTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
NINE THIRTY THREE
HI MY NAME IS DANNY BERNARDINI
REPRESENTING THE NAPA SOLANO
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL AYE STERN
STATE BUILDING TRADES TO
OPPOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU
ONE SIXTY NINE
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS PAUL
MARINO WITH IRON WORKERS LOCAL
FOUR THIRTY THREE LOS ANGELES
AND -- WE ARE OPPOSING FC NINE
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU
BY SIXTY ONE
MY NAME IS DANNY BURKE WITH
LOCAL THREE FORTY THREE
HUNDRED THE STAMPEDERS WE'RE
JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT LINE SEVENTY SEVEN
THIS IS DAVID BEANIE
REPRESENTING THE THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE SANTA
CLARA AND SAN BENITO COUNTY
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY
WITH THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. NINE
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU NEXT
NINE SEVENTY TWO
MORNING THIS IS ANTHONY
BROOKS YOU SOLVED AS MUCH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM LOCAL
SIXTEEN HEAT AND FROST
INSULATORS AND I STAND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION THE S. B. NINE
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
RIGHT EIGHTY FIVE
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
JOHN HUNTER LOCK WITH THE
HUMBOLDT DEL NORD BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES AND
THE OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
THREE WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE FIFTY THREE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. OKAY --
ALL TESTIMONY BEING EXHAUSTED
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE DIS
HERE MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA STEPS A
QUORUM BEFORE WE BEGIN THE
DISCUSSION HERE SO SHE CAN SO
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
STERN HERE STERN HERE JONES
ALLEN EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE
GROVE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HERE
HUESO LAYERED HERE LEARNED HERE
LONG LIMóN HERE WE HAVE A CORE
OF VERY GOOD -- WELL
WE HAVE THE QUORUM SHOULD
WE TAKE A QUICK MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR I WOULD MOVE
ITEM SIX SEVEN EIGHT AND NINE
WHICH ARE THE CONSENT AGENDA
LET TO MOTIONS CENTER LAYERED
FASCISTS BUT YOU NEED
TO DISPOSE OF THIS BILL
BEFORE WE CAN CONSENT
OKAY WELL BY THE PRESS WE
WILL HOLD THAT IN ADVANCE THAT
MOTION BE SET ASIDE --
DISCUSSION DEBATE QUESTIONS
MEMBERS I'M NOT CAN I JUST SAY
AT THE OUTSET I APPRECIATE THE
THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR ON THIS
MEASURE -- YEAH
I WAS OUT THERE WHEN THE SPILL
HAPPENED SHORTLY AFTER IT AND
-- UNDER WHICH THIS THIS WE'RE
TALKING YEAH WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE BILL BEFORE US RIGHT NOW
-- NO IT'S OKAY I DO WHAT WITH
SO I WOULD JUST SAY THE OUTSET
YOU KNOW THE DEVASTATION WE SAW
ON OUR SHORES STRETCHING ALL
THE WAY DOWN TO SAN DIEGO AND IS
FOR UP AND IN THE L. A. COUNTY
WE CAN TALK ABOUT CAUSES --
AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW
WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED THAT
FATEFUL DAY OR MANY DAYS MAY
HAVE BEEN MULTIPLE INCIDENCES
THAT LED UP TO IT BUT WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S A DUTY OF THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION AND FOR US
AS LEGISLATORS TO LOOK AFTER
THE PUBLIC TRUST HERE AND THAT
THERE IS A LOT OF VALUE THAT IS
CURRENTLY NOT ASSESSED IN THE
THIS FORMULA WE USE WE USE FOR
DETERMINING THE THE USEFULNESS
OF MANY OF THESE ASSETS -- AND
I APPRECIATE YOU TRYING TO TO
WALK THE LINE ON THIS QUESTION
OF AMORTIZATION THE VALUE OF
THE ASSETS I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
CONCERNS RAISED BY SOME OF
THE FOLKS ON THE FENCE -- WHO
ARE NECESSARILY IN OPPOSITION
BUT WITH CONCERNS ABOUT --
JUST JUMPING THE GUN ON THE
AMORTIZATION PROCESS AND AND
LEADING STRAIGHT STRAIGHT
INTO A TAKINGS ISSUE AND
AS WELL AS THE THE NEED TO
ACCOUNT FOR ALL THE COSTS AND
AND BENEFITS WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
AT FAIR MARKET VALUE AS THE BILL
NOTES -- IT IT DOESN'T REALLY
GET INTO ALL THOSE DETAILS --
IN TERMS OF WHAT ARE THE WHAT
ARE THOSE COSTS -- EVERYTHING
FROM RISK OF FUTURE SPILLS --
COSTS BRING THE PLATFORMS AN
ASSOCIATE IN INFRASTRUCTURE
UP TO CURRENT STANDARDS ACOSTA
SAYS YOU WITH ABANDONMENT
REMOVAL AND REMEDIATION WE
KNOW SOME OF THOSE ISSUES ARE
OUTSTANDING AND THAT -- AND
THAT OTHER OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL HAVE HAVE FURTHER CONCERNS
ABOUT JUST THE THE APPROACH
I HAD TO GO THROUGH THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION IN THE FIRST
PLACE HERE BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'RE MOVING FORWARD AND
THAT YOU HAVE WE HAVE TO KEEP
THIS LEGISLATION MOVING -- AND
THIS CONVERSATION GOING SO YOU
KNOW THE WORK YOU'VE DONE WITH
STAKEHOLDERS UP TO THIS POINT
I THINK IS EVIDENCE OF YOUR
YOUR WORK ETHIC BUT ALSO THE
COMPLEXITY OF THIS ISSUE AND
I APPRECIATE YOU NAVIGATING --
-- THOSE CONCERNS ESPECIALLY
FROM THE YOU KNOW THE THOSE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY WHO
ARE WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POLLUTER PAYS PRINCIPLE AND THAT
WE DON'T WANT TO BE SUBSIDIZING
-- CLEAN UP ACTIVITY THAT
IS REALLY THE RESPONSIBILITY
INDUSTRY THAT'S PROFITED IN THE
BILLIONS THAT'S JUST OFFSHORE
BUT ON SHORE AS WELL SO FOR
THIS COMMITTEE IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PRINCIPLE THAT HERE TOO AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR RECOGNITION
OF THAT TODAY AND GOING FORWARD
AND WHAT WE DON'T HAVE TOTAL
RESOLUTION ON THAT I'M GONNA
BE SUPPORTING THE MEASURE
TO TO GIVE YOU SOME SPACE
TO TO KEEP WORKING -- THANKS
ED HERTZBERG HAS A QUESTION
COMMENT I DO HAVE A STRONG CUP
SOME QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
THE FIRST QUESTION IS WHAT IS
THE PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE THEM WHAT'S THE PROBLEM
WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE AND
SECONDLY WHAT ARE THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN TERMS OF FIXING
THOSE SOLUTIONS CHAU NGUYEN
FIRST OF ALL THIS TWENTY SEVEN
OFFSHORE WELLS IN CALIFORNIA
INTO WATERS IN IRAN CALIFORNIA
TWENTY FOUR OF THEM ARE FEDERAL
AND THREE OR STATES ARE CORRECT
THERE'S TWENTY EIGHT WITH A
FOR HIS PART PLATFORM HOLLY
SO OKAY THE PLATFORM HOLLYWOOD
WHICH IS SHUT DOWN THE PRESS
RIGHT AT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS BECAUSE I DID A BILL
ON THAT THAT WAS EXACTLY THE
PROBLEM YOU'RE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH HERE DON'T TALK ABOUT
SO NOW YOU WILL REALLY THE
FOCUS OF THIS BILL IS THREE
THREE OPTIONAL AS WELL AS WELL
IF I MIGHT INTERJECT CENTER SURE
WE WE ARE WE OBVIOUSLY CANNOT
IMPACTED DIRECTLY OR I BELIEVE
INDIRECTLY THAT RAKES IN FEDERAL
WATERS CORRECT BUT WE ARE IN
DISCUSSIONS OF COURSE WITH OUR
CONGRESSIONAL COUNTERPARTS AND
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IN FACT THAT
WELL WE KNOW THEY'RE LOOKING AT
THIS BILL AND WHETHER SUCCESSFUL
AS AS POTENTIALLY A MODEL FOR
FEDERAL LEGISLATION SO WE I'VE
TALKED WITH KATIE PORTER MIKE
LEVIN AND OTHER -- CONGRESSIONAL
REPRESENTATIVES REPRESENTING
DIFFERENT PARTS THE ARE COUNTY
COASTLINE KICK BUT THE REALITY
IS IF IF THE RISK THAT WE'RE
FACING BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY WHAT YOU'RE REALLY
TRYING TO DO IS TO GET OFF
OIL BUT IF IN FACT WE ARE JUST
LOOKING AT THE AT THE FINANCIAL
ARCHITECTURE OF THIS BECAUSE I'M
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN TERMS OF COST
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE TRYING TO GET
OFF OIL WHICH BUT WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IS YOU'RE SAYING THERE'S
A SECONDARY REST THE CHAIRMAN
TALKED ABOUT IN TERMS OF THE
BEACHES WHICH YOU ALLUDED TO
WITH RESPECT TO YOUR FATHER
WALKING ON THE BEACH THAT IT
HURTS THIS EXTRAORDINARY ASSETS
SO IF YOU'VE GOT OIL AND YOU
WANT TO GET OFF OIL NOW WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IS YOU REALLY ARE
UNLESS YOU INCREASE PRODUCTION
ON SHORE SO YOU'RE NOT AFFECTING
THE SHORELINE RIGHT YOU
ARE DEALING WITH TANKERS YOU'VE
GOT THIS THIRTY PERCENT OF THE
PARTICULAR MATTER IN THE HARBOR
THAT WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT WITH
ASTHMA AND ALL THESE OTHER KIDS
AND ALL THE IMPACTS ARE COMING
ON THOSE TANKERS RIGHT IS THAT
A FAIR STATEMENT I'M NOT ABOUT
RIGHT WHEN WAS I'M SORRY OKAY
WE DID POINT IS IS THAT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS YOU'RE REPLACING
ONE RISK WITH ANOTHER RISK IN
TERMS OF IF YOU'RE IN FACT GOING
TO IMPORT OIL OFF OF TANKERS
THEN YOU'RE SAYING OKAY WE'RE
TO MOVING THE BEACH RISK BUT
WE'RE ADDING AIR POLLUTION RISK
AS A CONSEQUENCE YOU FORGET
IMPORTANT LIST WILL BE INCREASED
DRILLING HERE NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO WHICH CONCERNS ME IN
THE DISCUSSION I'VE HAD WITH YOU
ALREADY AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
EARNESTNESS WITH RESPECT TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A LONG TIME FOR THIS --
STRUCTURE YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY
DEALING WITH THIS BILL WHICH
CAUSED BY A TANKER NOT BY THE
WAY WAS IT WAS IT A TANKER THAT
DRAG DRAG THE THE AND THE AND
THEN THE ALARMS DIDN'T GO OFF
OR THEY MAY HAVE GONE OFF BUT
DIDN'T ALERT THEM BECAUSE THEY
PROBABLY WEREN'T UPDATED WHAT
IS THE STATE WE'RE WE'RE HERE
WOOD WORRIES ME AND I DEALT WITH
THIS IN REGARDS TO REEFS RIGHT
I KNOW THERE WAS SOME ISSUE
ABOUT THAT WE PASS OF THE SENATE
THREE TIMES WHERE WE SET UP
ANIL WE ALIGNED INTERESTS IN A
WAY AND I THINK THIS IS SENATOR
-- LATER GET WITH THIS YEARS AGO
HIMSELF WE'RE INNOCENT AND THOSE
SPEAKER PEREZ DID THE SAME THING
WE'RE TRYING TO ALIGN INTERESTS
TO BE ABLE TO INCENTIVIZE
THESE FOLKS TO ELIMINATE THESE
OFFSHORE RIGS AND I KNOW THESE
ARE AND SHALLOWER WATERS IN
TERMS OF RIGS TO REEFS BUT
RIGHT NOW YOU'RE EXPOSED TO THIS
EXTRAORDINARY TAXPAYER EXPENSE
AND MONEY'S NOT PRINTED ON TREES
SO YOU'RE SAYING WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THIS MONEY OUT OF FOSTER
CARE -- WE'RE GOING TO TAKE IT
OUT OF MONEY THAT WE NEED TO
BUILD HOUSING FOR HOMELESS WE IN
GOVERNMENT HAVE AN OBLIGATION AS
WE SPEND TAX DOLLARS TO BALANCE
IT'S EASY JUST TO SAY YES TO
EVERYBODY ALL THE TIME AND NOT
BE RESPONSIBLE IN GOVERNMENT
WHICH IS OUR JOB WHERE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT IS GOING TO COST WE
KNOW THAT IF IF WE TAKE THESE
THEY'RE CLEARLY IN THE LAW THIS
IS A TAKING AND THE QUESTION IS
I LOOK AT THIS AND QUITE FRANKLY
AND AS I ANALYZED AFTER TALKING
TO YOU AND TRYING TO GIVE YOU
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT AND
BEATING THE ANALYSIS IS TO SAY
OKAY WHY DON'T WE JUST DO ONE
OFF EACH ONE OF THESE WHY CAN'T
WE DO TRADE OFFS IN TERMS OF
NEGOTIATING EACH ONE YOU SET UP
THIS WHOLE PROCESS WITHIN THE
BUREAUCRACY OF GOVERNMENT THEN
TIES YOU TO THIS FRAMEWORK
WHERE YOU COULD BASICALLY DOES
THIS ONE OF THESE COMPANIES WHAT
AMY ESTHER ME WHATEVER THE THREE
PLATFORMS ARE CALLED DO YOU HAVE
SOMETHING TO NEGOTIATE WHERE
WHERE ONE OF THESE COMPANIES
I DON'T HOLD THESE THINGS HAVE
NO CLUE BUT OFTEN THE GO SHAKE
SOMETHING WITH THEM TO REDUCE
THE RISK ON THE GENERAL FUND
THAT AFFECTS PEOPLE I I THINK
THAT YOU PROBABLY COULD BUT NOW
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS YOU'VE SET
UP THIS PROCESS AND I UNDERSTAND
SO WORK IN PROGRESS AND I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT I'VE
BEEN THROUGH THIS MANY TIMES
BUT WHEN I LOOK AT THE BASIC
FRAMEWORK YOU'RE SAYING TO ME
IN THAT TO ASKING FOR FOR ME TO
SUPPORT THIS THAT YOU KNOW YES
OKAY FINE WE WANT TO DO ALL THIS
GREAT WE WANT TO GET THIS DONE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AGREE AGREE
AGREE NO QUESTION BUT YOU'RE
NOT BALANCING IT AGAINST ONE OF
THE OTHER RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH
ALL THE OTHER COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH GOVERNMENT AND THEN YOU'RE
SETTING UP THIS FRAMEWORK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LANDS COMMISSION
I WORKED WITH MANY MANY YEARS
ON A NUMBER OF THINGS AND IT IT
IS QUITE PROBLEMATIC AND SO I
I JUST I GOTTA TELL YOU FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE DO YOU KNOW UNLESS
YOU'RE BASICALLY SPENDING ALL
THIS MONEY TO BEG ELIMINATE OIL
COMPLETELY YOU'RE NOT REALLY
SOLVING THE PROBLEM IN YOUR
CREATING A WHOLE HOST OF NEW
PROBLEMS I'D LIKE TO GET SOME
OF INSIGHT YOU HAVE A BRIGHT
FELLA ON SOME OF THE STUFF
BUT I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
IT BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S THE
SAME THING HAPPENS IN THIS JOB
ALL THE TIME PEOPLE COME IN ON
ONE SIDE TO THE OTHER SIDE AND
THEY WANT TO YOU KNOW HAVE SOME
POLITICAL THING THAT HAPPENED
THEIR COMMUNITY AND THEY WANT
TO MAKE A STATEMENT BUT WE HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY TO DEAL WITH
THIS IN A REALLY INTELLIGENT
WAY AND THAT MEANS SPENDING
ARE THE TAXPAYERS DOLLARS IN
THE WAY MOST EXPEDITIOUSLY
AND IF YOU'RE OUT HERE TO STAY
YOU'RE GOING TO ELIMINATE OIL
WHAT ARE YOU REALLY DOING THAT
HAVE YOU DONE ANYTHING ELSE IN
TERMS THAT CONSEQUENCE RIGHT
AND WHAT PRICE TO PAY AND
ARE YOU PUTTING YOURSELF IN
A FRAMEWORK THAT IS SO RIGID
THAT YOU'RE BASICALLY SETTING
A TONE THAT PUTS US IN A VERY
DIFFICULT POSITION TO NEGOTIATE
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU MENTIONED THE
BIG STORY THING WHERE THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES TO LOOK AT THIS
THING IN A DIFFERENT WAY BUT
I I'D LIKE TO GET SOME OF YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THIS BECAUSE I'M
HAVING TROUBLE IT IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOUR OBJECTIVE IS YEAH WITHOUT
SEEING ALL OF THE HORRIBLE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND
NOT REALLY GETTING TO THE ROOT
OF SOLVING THE PROBLEM YOU'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE THANK YOU CENTER
AT THANK YOU OF COURSE PLEASE
-- SO I THINK THERE MIGHT BE
SOME MISUNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL AND MAYBE
THAT IS I WASN'T COMMUNICATING
CLEARLY I THINK YOU ARE NOT
HERE IN FORCING FOR MY OPENING
STATEMENT OKAY BUT THE POINT
IS BILLS NOT TO GET RID OIL
WHAT'S NOT TO LIKE GET THE
STATE OFF WHERE THAT THAT'S
A SECONDARY RIGHT THAT'S THE
SUBJECT OF A WHOLE DIFFERENT
DEBATE THIS THIS IS A NARROWER
GOAL WHICH IS IS ABOUT BALANCING
AS YOU SAID BALANCING THE RISKS
OF OFFSHORE OIL SPILLS THAT
JEOPARDIZE OUR COASTLINE AND
R. FORTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
ECONOMY IT AND THAT'S A REAL
RISK AND WE'VE SEEN IT TIME
AFTER TIME AND YES SOME OF
THAT RISK IS AGGREGATED IN THE
TANKERS A LOT OF IT THOUGH COMES
FROM THE PLATFORMS AND IN THIS
CASE IT WAS OIL FROM PLATFORM
IT WAS A SHIP I I BELIEVE IT
WAS IN THE TANKER WAS A CARGO
SHIP IT MAY HAVE BEEN A TANKER
BUT EITHER WAY IT WAS ABOUT AN
EXPOSE PIPELINE IT WAS ABOUT AN
ALARM THAT ALLEGEDLY WENT OFF
BUT NOBODY ANSWERED IT AND AND
THAT SEEMS LIKELY TO HAVE BEEN
A CASE OF NON INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS ALL TOO
COMMON WITH THESE THINGS AND I
THINK IN TALKING TO THE SENATE
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THE RIG THREE FINAL YOU
KNOW A LOT ABOUT THIS ISSUE --
BUT YOU ALSO KNOW THEN THAT A
LOT OF THIS INFRASTRUCTURE IS
OLD IF THERE'S NO MEANINGFUL
INCENTIVES FOR THE EXISTING
OPERATORS WHO ARE YOU KNOW --
TWO OR THREE GENERATIONS DOWN
OTHER THE MAJORS ARE ALL OUT
-- THE THEIR THINLY CAPITALIZED
THEY DON'T HAVE THE INCENTIVES
TO INVEST IN INFRASTRUCTURE
-- IN SO THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
INCENTIVES IS ABOUT RISKS AND
BALANCING THOSE RISKS I THINK
THIS FRAMEWORK DOES COME TO THAT
BUT THIS IS NOT ABOUT TRYING
TO GET RID OF OIL IT'S ABOUT
BALANCING THE RISKS OF SPILLS
FROM THESE WHAT I THINK ARE
TICKING TIME BOMBS AND I THINK
PEOPLE STUDY THIS AGREE WITH
THAT -- AND AND THE REST
SAY POSTCARDS ARE SHORT IN
OUR OUR BEACHES AND I REALLY
DO THINK THAT UNLESS WE STOP
THE DRILLING WE WILL END UP
INEVITABLY HAVING ANOTHER MAJOR
MAJOR OIL SPILL WHETHER IT'S IN
A YEAR TEN YEARS TWENTY YEARS
WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO SEE THAT
HAPPEN -- UNSERE IS
NUMBER APPOINT SOMEONE TO GO
THROUGH THEM -- THE COSTS -- AND
I SHOULD ALSO SAY THIS IS NOT
ON FOR DRILLING OIL PRODUCTION
THIS BILL IS LIMITED TO THE
THREE PLATFORMS WITH THE HOPE OF
PROVIDING EXAMPLE FOR THE OTHER
TWENTY FOUR PLATFORMS IN FEDERAL
WATERS THEN AGAIN I KNOW THAT
OUR CONGRESSIONAL COUNTERPARTS
ARE BIT CLICK VERY CLOSELY
FOLLOWING WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW WITH THIS BILL -- THEY MAY
USE THIS IS A MODEL THEY MAY
NOT BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT DEPENDS
ON WHAT HAPPENS WITH THIS BILL
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND GOING
FORWARD -- YOU KNOW THE COST
OF THIS BILL WE THINK WILL BE
CONSTRAINED IN AGAIN I EMPHASIZE
THE POINT THAT THIS THIS
FRAMEWORK ACTUALLY INCORPORATES
THE UP UP FRONT THE COST OF
DECOMMISSIONING IN A WAY THAT
I THINK IS A BETTER DEAL TO
TAXPAYERS THAN THE ALTERNATIVE
WE SAW THIS WITH PLATFORM HOLLY
UNFORTUNATELY WHERE THE COST
OF DECOMMISSIONING SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PAID FOR BY THE OPERATOR
I THEY DECLARE BANKRUPTCY AND
LEFT US HOLDING BACK AND I THINK
UNFORTUNATELY THE THE MOST THE
COMPANIES HOLDING THESE AYE
SO DITE DE CORPORATE DIE CORP
WHICH I BELIEVE IS HOUSTON
BASED COMPANY ALSO LEASES
AND OPERATES TO THE PLATFORMS
OF THE THREE WERE TALKING AT
THE OTHERS OPERATED BY C. R. C.
AND -- YOU KNOW MY BELIEF IS
THAT IF WE HAVE ANOTHER MAJOR
OIL SPILL OR WE HAVE ANOTHER
MAJOR A SET OF DECOMMISSIONING
COSTS WE WE MAY FACE THAT SAME
DILEMMA OF A COMPANY WALKING
WAY DECLARING BANKRUPTCY AND
LEAVING TAXPAYERS HOLDING THE
BAG SO AT LEAST THIS APPROACH --
INCORPORATES UP FRONT THE COST
OF DECOMMISSIONING IT GETS RID
OF THE RISKS OF OFFSHORE SPILLS
FROM THESE RIGS AGAIN I KNOW
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS IN WHICH
OFFERS BILLS CAN HAPPEN BUT IT
DOES REMOVE THAT RISK AND WE
THINK THAT IT DOESN'T LINE IN
SENTENCE IN THAT IT PROVIDES THE
POWER AND TOOLS FOR PLANTS TO BE
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE A SETTLEMENT
THAT'S WITH THE GOAL OF THIS
FRAMEWORK YOU CAN'T NEGOTIATE
A SETTLEMENT WITHOUT KNOWING
WHAT THE FAIR MARKET VALUES
I'M NOT GOING TO GO IN AND DID
ON YOU KNOW SOMETHING ON EBAY
WITHOUT HAVING SOME SENSE OF
THE CONDITION OF THAT WHAT IT'S
WORTH I WOULD THAT'S WHAT REALLY
AUTHORIZING LANDS COMMISSION
TO DO WE DO ANTICIPATE THERE
WILL BE AN APPROPRIATION FOR
THIS AND TRYING TO COME TO A
FAIR DEAL AND AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT THERE'S BEEN
SOME DISCUSSION WITH STEP UP
ABOUT WHETHER IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO HAVE A TERMINATION CLAUSE
WE FEEL LIKE THEY NEED THAT
NEGOTIATING POWER TO BE ABLE
TO NEGOTIATE A FAIR DEAL BUT
IT'S SOMETHING WE'LL CONTINUE
TO DISCUSS WITH CHIP -- WISPA
I AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS SHOULD
THIS BILL NEVADA COMMITTEE
TODAY IT WE WANT TO PROVIDE A
FRAMEWORK AND ROBUST SET OF
TOOLS FOR INDIGO SHOULD HAPPEN
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY IN EVERYONE'S
INTERESTS ARE BECAUSE THE
WRISTLET ADDITION ARE THERE
THE CONSULATE ADDITION COULD
BE HIGH AND WE LIKE TO TRY TO
AVOID THAT BUT WE DO THINK THE
COSTS WILL BE MORE MANAGEABLE
THAN SOME HAVE PREDICTED --
WE DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S NOT
MUCH OIL LEFT IN THESE THREE
PLATFORMS I HAVE BACK OF THE
ENVELOPE NUMBERS FROM ONE OF
THE PLATFORMS I'M HAPPY TO TALK
WITH YOU OFFLINE ABOUT THOSE --
BUT WE DO WE DON'T THINK THIS
IS GOING TO BE IN THE BILLIONS
WE THINK IT'S GOING TO BE --
YOU KNOW SOMETHING MUCH LESS
THAN AND I DON'T WANT TO THE
RIGHT NUMBERS BUT BUT WE THINK
IT'S MANAGEABLE AND IN THE
CONTEXT AGAIN -- FORTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL COASTAL
KANEMI WE THINK THAT THIS
BILL IS A PARTICULARLY FACTOR
IN DECOMMISSIONING COSTS IS
ACTUALLY GOOD DEAL FOR TAXPAYERS
AT A TIME WE HAVE A RECORD
SURPLUS IT'S NOT ABOUT MONEY
GROWING ON TREES IT'S ABOUT
MANAGING LONG TERM RISK AND AND
TRYING TO COME TO AN AGREEMENT
BECAUSE I I THINK WE ALL KNOW
OIL SPILLS ARE DEVASTATING IN MY
DISTRICT ALONG WITH SEVEN DAYS
OF SHUT DOWN BEACHES THE CONCERT
ANY PRETTY PRETTY HIGH FROM
THAT IF THEY HAD BEEN AS SEVERE
AS REFUGIO WHERE THE BEACHES
WERE SHUT DOWN FOR SIX MONTHS I
HAVEN'T SEEN A STUDY OF ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF THAT BUT SIX MONTHS
OF SHUT DOWN BEACHES AND PLACES
LIKE WE'RE GOING TO NEWPORT
AND HUNTINGTON I'M GONNA HAVE
MASSIVE COST AS YOU KNOW THE
HUNTING THE HUNTING BEACH OIL
SPILL SHUT DOWN THE SECOND DAY
OF THE AIR SHOW WE HAD A MILLION
A HALF THE TOURISTS IN TOWN
THEY WERE GONNA GO OUT TO BARS
GONNA GO OUT BE ON THE BEACH
ARE THEY ALL WENT HOME INSTEAD
AND SO I TALKED TO NUMEROUS
SHOP OWNERS WHO ESTIMATED THE
LOSS YOU KNOW A HUGE DAY OF
REVENUES BECAUSE THAT THEN THE
WEEK FOLLOWING -- WHEN THERE'S
NO REVENUE -- THEY THEY SUFFERED
AS WELL I ONE SHOP OWNER TOLD ME
SHE LOST ABOUT FORTY PERCENT OF
HER MONTHLY INCOME ON AGAIN IT
COULD'VE BEEN MUCH MUCH WORSE IF
IF THIS BILL HAD BEEN AS BAD AS
EXPECTED SO -- CONNECTIONS ONE
FOLLOW YEAH AND OKAY GOOD YEAH
I JUST AMEND LISTENING TO YOU
IF YOU'RE TELLING US THAT MAHOOD
PURPOSE SO CONCERNED IF YOUR
PURPOSE IS NOT TO GET RID OF
OIL IF THAT'S WHAT YOUR PURPOSE
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT YOU'VE SET
UP A STRUCTURE THAT BASICALLY
PUTS THE TAXPAYER INCH IN THE
JACKPOT OKAY AND HERE'S THE
REASON WHY IF I DON'T KNOW WHO
THESE COMPANIES ARE OF THE OF
ON SHORE OIL BUT BEFORE EITHER
GONNA STOP GETTING AWFUL FOR NOT
THEN WE'VE GOT TWO OPTIONS PUMP
MORE FROM CALIFORNIA I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT THE RIGHT THING
TO DO AND THAT'S GIVING YOU A
HYPOTHETICAL AGAINST PROFESSOR
AND THEN THE SECOND THING IS WE
CAN IMPORT THOSE ARE ONLY TWO
OPTIONS OKAY BRING IT FROM OVER
THERE AND ALL THE VARIOUS ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BUNKER FUEL
AND ALL THOSE PROBLEMS BUT THE
WHOLE YOU'RE THINKING OF IS
NOT TO GET RID OF OIL YOU'VE
LIMITED YOUR SKILL YOUR ABILITY
TO GET SOMETHING DONE BECAUSE
IF YOUR PURPOSE IS TO PROTECT
THE BEACH LEGIT LEGIT LEGIT OKAY
BUT YOU CAN GO AND WORK OUT WITH
THESE COMPANIES IS YOU'VE GOT TO
PAY BASIC RESEARCHER MISSING ONE
INSTEAD OF PUTTING THE TAXPAYERS
AND JUG JEOPARDY YOU CAN GO TO
THIS COMPANIES SAY YOU'RE MAKING
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
ON THIS PROJECT WE'LL GIVE YOU
A RESOURCE OVER HERE TO MAKE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
BUT YOU'RE LIMITING THAT THAT'S
NOT HAPPENING AS OF AS AN OPTION
SECOND THING YOU'RE DOING YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE IF THAT COMPANY
FILES B. K. WITH RESPECT TO THE
OPERATION OF THAT RIG YOU'RE
NOT PUTTING OURSELVES IN THE
SITUATION WITH PLATFORM HOLLY
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WHEN I INTRODUCED A BILL THAT
LOOKED TO TO TO CREATE A LARGER
BOND REQUIRED QUICK BECAUSE
THESE COMPANIES WERE BEING SOLD
OUT TO SMALLER COMPANIES WE
THOUGHT IT WAS GONNA BE LIKE
THIRTY MILLION FIFTY MILLION A
HUNDRED MILLION AND POPPED UP
TO FIFTY MILLION FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION EXCUSE ME SHE JUST
SAID WHAT'S IT GOING TO COST
TO TAXPAYERS SO NOW YOU HADN'T
TAXPAYERS ON THE RISK IT SEEMS
TO ME BY VIRTUE OF LIMITING
YOUR APPROACH -- ED AND WHAT
YOU HAVE TO PAY IN COMPENSATION
AND THEN SECONDLY YOU'RE STILL
EXPOSING THEM TO THE RISK OF
REMOVING THE RIG I I JUST YOU
KNOW I APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS
A WORK IN PROGRESS BUT I I GOTTA
TELL YA I YOU KNOW I THOUGHT
ABOUT THIS A LOT OF AND YOU KNOW
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS BOTH
HERE AND INTERNATIONALLY FOR
A LONG TIME AND I I JUST DON'T
SEE THE AVENUE YOU'RE COMING
DOWN BEYOND JUST THE NOTION OF
SAYING LET'S GET RID OF THESE
THINGS WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING
THE GLOCK LAVIN INTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND IN MY JUDGMENT
OFTEN ISSUE MISTER CHAIRMAN
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING ALL ON
THE BIGGER PICTURE OF WHAT YOUR
YOUR FOCUS ON SO WITH THAT I AND
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS TODAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FEEDBACK
-- THE COLLOQUY CENTER LAYERED
THANK YOU MR -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- I THINK THE DEBATE
HAS DONE A LOT OF THE WORK THAT
THAT I WANTED TO DO BECAUSE I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS
ABOUT GIVING A CHANCE TO WORK
BUT I APPRECIATE US SENATOR
HERTZBERG'S COMMENTS ABOUT
RAISING THE ISSUE FOR ME
THE THING I WAS GOING TO ASK
ABOUT THAT HE JUST REALLY
I WAS GONNA SAY DROP DOWN ON
THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT PHRASE HERE
-- WAS THE ISSUE OF LIABILITY
AND LIABILITY TO THE TAXPAYERS
AND THAT IS A CONCERN AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED CLEARLY IN THIS
BECAUSE HE HE I DID DEAL WITH
THE EXACT SAME THING HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT ABOUT ORSON WELLES
AND THE ESCALATING COSTS WE DID
OF THE BILL IN OUR LAST WEEK
ON THAT THAT I THINK WE
WHEN WE ACTED ON IN
DEFENSE OF OF WHAT WE SHOULD
BE DOING OTHER RIGS TO REEF
I WAS GONNA MENTION AND SENATOR
HERTZBERG REALLY HIT IT ON THE
FACT THAT THIS IS THESE ARE
IN SHALLOW WATERS THAT'S NOT
AN OPTION HERE AND THE RISK
IN THE IS SO OUR OUR
I AM INCLINED TO GIVE YOU THE
CHANCE TO WORK ON THESE ISSUES
AND MOVE ALONG THE THING THAT
I VOWED I WOULD START TO DO IS
THIS ANALYSIS SAYS THIS IS A
WORK IN PROGRESS AND WE HAVE
ANOTHER BILL LATER IN THAT
COMMITTEE HEARING IT SAYS IT'S
A WORK IN PROGRESS AND -- I
THOUGHT I'M GONNA START TO ASK
ABOUT ALL THE WORKS IN PROGRESS
TO FIND OUT HOW DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO GET TO THE END
THE L. ONE IS GOING TO STOP
BEING A WORK IN PROGRESS AND
WHAT ARE THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
WILL GET YOU THERE RENT AND WHO
WITH THAT AND WHERE DO YOU THINK
YOUR PATH IS IF IF YOU MOVE
THIS BILL OUT OF COMMITTEE SURE
AND I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
SENATOR FIRST OF ALL ON THE
LIABILITY TAXPAYERS WHICH IS
SOMETHING WE'D BE HAPPY TO
DISCUSS WITH YOU GOING FORWARD
AND AND TO THINK ABOUT SOME
OF THE MECHANISMS THAT SENATOR
HERTZBERG AYE HAS RAISED AS YOU
POINT OUT THESE ARE UNLIKELY
CANDIDATES FOR EXTRA REEF OUT
WE DO ANTICIPATE THAT LANDS
COMMISSION IN H. FOR THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD -- IN CONDUCTING
AMORTIZATION STUDY WOULD SS
AND EXPLORE ALL DIFFERENT
AVENUES FOR THE USE OF THESE
REEFS ERROR THESE USE --
PLATFORMS AND -- THAT IS
SOMETHING WE HOPE IS PART OF
THE NEGOTIATION PROCESS IS COULD
THIS BE USED FOR ALTERNATIVE
USES AND AND DOES THAT CHANGE
THE CALCULUS AS FAR AS THE
COST OF DECOMMISSIONING TO THE
TAXPAYER OR OTHERWISE -- AS FAR
AS OUR PATHWAY FORWARD OBVIOUSLY
WE ARE ENGAGED WITH BOTH
OUR SUPPORTERS IN OPPOSITION
WE FEEL LIKE THIS BILLS ALREADY
MOVED A LONG WAY WITH SOME OF
OUR DISCUSSIONS WITH OPPOSITION
AS YOU MAY HAVE HEARD OTHER
REPRESENTATIVE FROM SEEP UP
MENTION THAT AT THIS POINT
THEY'RE ONLY OPPOSED TO THE
TERMINATION CLAUSE THAT BEING
SAID EVEN IF WE GET TO A POINT
WHERE WE AN AGREEMENT WITH
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION THERE
THERE'S SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT YOU AND SENATOR HERTZBERG
HAVE RAISED ABOUT MAKING SURE
THIS IS THIS WE RESPONSIBLE FOR
TAXPAYERS I IS THAT SOMETHING
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAFF OF COMMITTEES MOVING
FORWARD THIS STAFF YOUR STAFF
IN YOURSELF IF YOU IF YOU TO
BE SO INCLINED LANDS COMMISSION
AND OTHER FOLKS INVOLVED WITH
THIS THEY'LL BE MINISTERING THIS
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THE BEST
PATHWAY FORWARD THAT PROTECTS
TAXPAYERS GETS TO OUR GOAL OF
ENDING THESE PLATFORMS IN A WAY
THAT IS FAIR TRANSPARENT AND --
MINIMIZES LITIGATION RISK THEN
-- AND MAKE A COMMENT I'D BE
HAPPY TO DO IT I WISH I STILL
HAD TO STAFF RESOURCES BECAUSE
THEY'D BE THE ONES THAT WOULD
BE BEST TO ENGAGE WITH YOU
UP ON THIS BUT THE ARE
-- IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
ME THAT YOU DO THE DRESSES
ISSUES IF THIS MOVES ALONG AN
ENDED AND I A I NOTED
THAT THE THAT THERE WAS SORT
OF A MOVE TO NEUTRALITY ON ONE
PART OF THE BILL OR AT LEAST
SOME MEASURE OF ACCEPTANCE
SAID AND THE THING THAT WE
HAVE OUTLINED IS THE REMAINING
THING WHERE THERE'S STILL
SOME CONCERN AND AND I THINK
ONE OF THE HARDEST ISSUES ARE
ALWAYS IT IS THE ISSUE OF
LIMITING MORAL PRODUCTION HERE
AND THE OPTIONS OF TANKERS OR
OIL TRAINS OR OTHER THINGS THAT
THAT ARE REALLY GOOD IT'S A
QUESTION OF WHICH WAY ARE WE
GOING TO TAKE ARE POISONED AND
SO ARE I AM INCLINED TO MOVE
THIS BILL ALONG AND GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO CONTINUE TO WORK BUT I
WOULD HOPE THAT YOU COULD FIGURE
OUT HOW TO GET TO THE END SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING AND I I DO I WILL SAY I
THINK WE HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IN RECENT DAYS AND
WEEKS -- AND AGAIN I I KNOW THAT
THE AMOUNT OF WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT IS IS I DON'T ASSIST
AMENDMENTS BUT IT'S A VERY
SMALL FRACTION OF CALIFORNIA
OIL PRODUCTION AND U. S. OIL
PRODUCTION WE TALK ABOUT THREE
PLATFORMS IT FAIRLY SHALLOW
WATERS ANY AND ALL OFFSHORE
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA OFF THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTS FOR
LESS THAN POINT THREE PERCENT
OF U. S. OIL PRODUCTION -- SO
I DON'T THINK WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WITH THESE THREE PLATFORMS
ARE SHIFTING TO LIKE A MASSIVE
CHANGE AND SUBSTITUTES OF
PRODUCTS YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT VERY SMALL DROP
OF WITH THEIR SMALL DROP IN THE
BUCKET BUT WE HAVE SEEN MISTER
CHAIR WITH YOUR INDULGENCE
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE -- --
IN THE PLATFORM THAT SENATOR
HERTZBERG A REFERENCE JUST
HOW ONE CAN GO TO FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN LIABILITY
YEAH AND WE IN OUR DISCUSSION
LAST WEEK ON THE BONDING VERSUS
OTHER ALTERNATIVES WE'VE SEEN
WHAT THE LIABILITY TO THE STATE
IS THAT IS REALLY BIG YEAH WITH
THE EXISTING WELLS BEFORE WE
EVEN MOVED TO SOMEWHERE ELSE
SO THESE ARE REAL ISSUES THAT
ARE GOING TO HAVE IF I MIGHT
REPLY JUST REAL QUICK PLEASE
-- WE IN TALKING WITH PLANS AND
YOU KNOW BUT YOU OBVIOUSLY HAVE
TO TAKE THESE THINGS THAT IT
MAYBE WITH A GRAIN OF SALT BUT
I DO BELIEVE THEY'VE LEARNED
A LOT FROM THE EXPERIENCE OF
THE COMMISSION HOLLY AND THEY
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE GOT
A BETTER GRASP ON THE COST OF
DECOMMISSIONING THE PROCESS AND
WE ACTUALLY SAW SIMILAR ANALOG
HERE WITH THE RESPONSE THAT WAS
BILLS -- THAT THAT THAT WHAT
WE SAW WITH OSCAR AND COMMAND
CENTER IN HUNTINGTON BEACH OIL
SPILL WAS WAS TRULY AMAZING I
THAT COORDINATE A RESPONSE I
THINK WAS THE RESULT OF LEARNED
EXPERIENCE OF REALLY BUILDING
ON THE LESSONS OF THE PAST AND
LANCE COMMISSION IT SURE'S US
THAT THEY HAVE LEARNED A LOT
THEY HAVE A BETTER HANDLE ON
HOW TO VALUE THIS AND ESTIMATED
FOR EXAMPLE THAT PLATFORM ANY
I BELIEVE IS IS GOING TO HAVE
A DECOMMISSIONING COSTS ALL IN
ABOUT NINETY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
-- SO THAT GIVES US SOME SENSE
OF THE BALLPARK FIGURES WERE
TALKING ABOUT NOW I'M NOT SAYING
THAT ALL THREE PLATFORMS OF THE
SAME BUT THEY CAN'T REALLY START
THAT DECOMMISSIONING PROCESS ON
ALL THREE PLATFORMS OR THE THE
SETTLEMENT WITHOUT SOME KIND OF
AUTHORIZATION WHICH IS WHAT OUR
BILL AIMS TO DO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WOULD MOST OF THEM OKAY
MOTION FOR CENTER LAYERED CENTER
EGGMAN THANK YOU -- I THINK
I'M ELEMENT SET UP WHO DOES NOT
REPRESENT A COASTAL COMMUNITY
SO THAT PUSHED ME TO A DIFFERENT
POSITIONS AND AND MORE DEPENDENT
UPON MY PEERS AND THEIR
EXPERIENCE AND SO I RESPECT
EVERYBODY BUT PEOPLE OF SAID --
THAT THIS INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED
ISSUE WITH A HUGE LIABILITY
POTENTIALLY TO THE TAXPAYERS --
AND A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
SHIFTING RISK FROM COASTLINES TO
INTERCITY PORTS WHICH YOU KNOW
WE KNOW WHO LIVES THERE AND THE
-- THE PUT THE PRESSURE ON ON
THOSE COMMUNITIES SO I I HAVE
I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE COST
I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE SHALL
DETERMINATION -- AND I HAVE
CONCERNS THAT THERE ARE THAT
THAT WE ARE WE ARE GIVING OVER
-- A BIG PROBLEM TO SOLVE TO A
BUREAUCRACY AND MY EXPERIENCES
BUREAUCRACIES DON'T SOLVE
OUR PROBLEMS WE GOT TO FIGURE
OUT THE STRUCTURE IN WHICH TO
DO THAT THAT'S MORE FLEXIBLE
AND PROVIDES FOR -- VARIATION
BETWEEN THOSE THREE WELLS
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT JUST ONE
ONE THING AND WE'RE WE'RE DOING
ONE BILL FOR THREE WELLS SO
I WILK SUPPORTED TODAY I BUT
I WILL NOT CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
IT IF WE DON'T RESOLVE THE
ISSUES THAT I THINK ARE VERY
REAL IN FRONT OF US THANKS
FOR THE COMMENT -- WE DO HAVE
A MOTION FROM CENTER LAYERED
A CEREMONY OF A COMMENT QUITE
WELL AND I'LL JUST COMMENT AND
INPUT FROM HOLLY HAS COME UP
MULTIPLE TIMES I THINK PEOPLE
KNOW THAT'S IN THE DISTRICT I
REPRESENT -- AND SURELY THIS
IS AN ONGOING DISCUSSION AND I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO SEE THESE DISCUSSIONS
COME UP IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
I I I DO THINK THAT THE
CONSTITUENCIES WILL REPRESENT
-- ARE VERY AWARE THAT THERE
IS A SHIFT IN HOW WE THINK
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHERE WE WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE ON THE RISKS AND
-- I YOU KNOW I CAN TELL YOU
THAT AND THAT THIS BILL IS IN
LINE WITH WHERE AT YOU KNOW
CONSTITUENTS FEEL IN MY DISTRICT
-- BUT IT'S NOT EASY AND SO I
THINK LOOKING AT THE ANALYSIS
WE YOU AND I HAD MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS AND
ABOUT THIS ISSUE OVER ALL -- BUT
IN MY FEELING IS IS THAT THIS
IS A BILL THAT'S IN THE FIRST
COMMITTEE IF YOU KNOW IF I HAD
TO GUESS I THINK IT'S GONNA
BE A WORK IN PROGRESS ALL THE
WAY THROUGH BECAUSE THESE ARE
VERY HARD ISSUES WE DON'T KNOW
WHERE WE LAND UNTIL THE END --
AND IT'S REALLY THE FEEDBACK
THE ANALYSIS AT THE BACK AND
FORTH OF LEGISLATIVE INPUT AND
INSIGHT AND OVERSIGHT AT THAT
KIND OF GETS PUT INTO THIS BILL
THAT WILL HELP US -- WHERE IS
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION WAS
-- A DECADE OR TWO AGO WITH
WHERE THEY'RE AT NOW IN TERMS
OF THEIR UNDERSTANDING ABOUT
THESE PLATFORMS -- AND THAT
WITH THE WELLS OVERALL IT IS A
THINK DIFFERENT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF WORK A LOT OF EVOLVEMENT
-- IN TERMS OF THE STAFF'S
EXPERTISE AT AND ABILITY TO COME
IN -- AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU
THAT I'M GRATEFUL BECAUSE AS
I SPEAK RIGHT THERE COME INTO
THE DISTRICT TO DO A TOUR WITH
CONSTITUENTS WITH THE PUBLIC
ABOUT ONE OF THE WEALTHY AND
YOU'RE SMILING BECAUSE WE KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS RIGHT IT'S
AN UNDERSTANDING OF TRYING TO
TALK TO THE YOU KNOW PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA OF WHAT THIS
WHAT THE TRADE OFFS ARE AND
ALSO HAVE THEM SEE -- FIRST
HAND -- WHERE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES ARE SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS -- AND ALSO
I'M GRATEFUL FOR FOR COLLEAGUES
TO ALLOW THE CONVERSATION TO
KEEP GOING THIS IS GOING TO KEEP
COMING UP AND UNLESS YOU KNOW
MY FEAR IS IT WHAT'S STOPPING
THIS CONVERSATION SO EARLY WE
DON'T GET TO THE PROCESS OF A
LEGISLATIVE INSIGHT OVERSIGHT
THAT I THINK IS REALLY NEEDED
IT TO CRAFT AT THE END PRODUCTS
SO -- I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS IS
WELL AND LOOK FORWARD TO AND I
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS AND HAVE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU CENTER
THANK YOU CEREMONY WE DO HAVE
A MOTION BEFORE US ALLOW YOU
TO CLOSE AFTER VERY ROBUST
DISCUSSION APPRECIATE ALL THE
THE -- DIRECTIVES
AND WATCHFULNESS THIS COMMITTEE
AND I'LL I'LL JUST REITERATE
AGAIN IT THE HARD
WORK BUT AS YOU GO FORWARD
BEFORE THE FLOOR WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT ALL THE ISSUES RAISED
HERE -- THE TRUE COSTS
OF THESE PLATFORMS AND
OF THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING COST THE PUBLIC --
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHATEVER THE
MARKET VALUE OR THE FAIR MARKET
VALUE OF THESE ASSETS ARE IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T
HIDE THOSE COSTS THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE IMPOSED ON ON
THE PUBLIC ON OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES I KNOW YOU'LL BE
WATCHFUL THAT GOING FORWARD SO
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
-- AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE YOU
TO CLOSE YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU TO THE COMMENTERS
FOR A VERY ROBUST CONVERSATION
I I DO APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK
AND AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK AND I THINK IF YOU SAW
THE VERY FIRST ITERATION THIS
BILL YOU SEEN IT'S IT'S MOVED A
LOT SINCE THEN I WILL CONTINUE
TO TRY TO MODIFY THIS BILL
AND AND BE FLEXIBLE ON IT SO
THAT IT ADDRESSES THE CONCERNS
RAISED TODAY ABOUT RISKS ABOUT
LIABILITY AND SOME OF THE OTHER
COMMENTS -- REYES SO -- YOU
HAVE MY COMMITMENT THAT WILL
KEEP WORKING WE'LL KEEP WORKING
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS --
AND SEE WHAT WE CAN COME UP
WITH AN AND -- I CAN'T PROMISE
YOU THIS BILL WILL GET ALL
THE WAY FOR WILL BUT WE'LL TRY
OUR BEST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS THAT I
CAN HOPEFULLY EARN YOUR SUPPORT
I TODAY AND ALSO GOING FORWARD
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AND AND THANK YOU ALL
FOR THE CONVERSATION OKAY
VERY GOOD SO -- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST RE REFER
TO COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
THAT YOU CAN SOME PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FILE ITEM ONE S. B.
NINE FIFTY THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
STERN STERN ALL RIGHT JONES
ALLEN ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN
EGGMAN HI HERTZBERG HUESO
LAYERED HI LEARN ALL RIGHT LIMóN
LIMóN HI OKAY
THAT MEASURE HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT
ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
-- CENTER LIMóN YOUR CONNECTS
WITH ITEM TOO BUT BEFORE YOU
DO I WILL TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT UNDER MOVE ITEM SIX
SEVEN EIGHT AND NINE THE CONSENT
AGENDA FOR THE COMING FROM
SENATOR LAYERED MOTION IS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR -- SHE
CAN SOME PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FILE
ITEM SIX S. B. TEN FIFTY ONE
FILE ITEM SEVEN S. B. TWELVE
FIFTY THREE FILE ITEM EIGHT S.
B. TWELVE TWENTY FOUR AND FILE
ITEM NINE SB TWELVE FORTY FOUR
STERN STERN ALRIGHT JONES
ALLEN ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN
EGGMAN ON HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HIGHWAY SO LAYERED HI LEARN ALL
RIGHT LET ALONE HI MON ALL RIGHT
OKAY OKAY THAT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SIX VOTES WILL EVEN
ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WILL MOVE NOW TO SET A FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO -- S. B. THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN SENATE ALONE WELCOME
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU CARE AND
COLLEAGUES SB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
ENSURES THAT CARBON CAPTURE
UTILIZATION AND STORAGE C. C. U.
S. PROJECTS DO NOT BOOST OIL
PRODUCTION AND EMISSIONS THROUGH
ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY ENHANCE
OR RECOVERY REFERRED TO AS E.
O. R. IS A PROCESS THAT USES
THE PRESSURE FROM PUMPING
CARBON UNDERGROUND TO PRODUCE
ADDITIONAL OIL THAT WOULD NOT
BE RECOVERABLE OTHERWISE YOU ARE
IS ALREADY WIDELY USED IN THE
STATE USING DIFFERENT METHODS
SUCH AS STEAM IT IS ESTIMATED
THAT OVER EIGHTY PERCENT OF
GLOBAL CAPTURED CARBON IS BEING
USED TO INCREASE OIL PRODUCTION
RESULTING IN SIGNIFICANT
EMISSIONS IT RECENT ANALYSIS
FOUND THAT EXPANDING YOUR
COULD RESULT IN AN ADDITIONAL
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND BARRELS
OF OIL PRODUCTION DALY IN THE
NATION BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
AND WOULD LEAD DIRECTLY TO
OVER FIFTEEN MILLION METRIC
TONS OF NET CO TWO EMISSIONS
ANNUALLY IS THIS THE U. S. IS
A TOOL TO HELP MITIGATE THE
IMPACT OF OUR CLIMATE CRISIS
THEN WHY WOULD THE STATE
PERMITTED TO YOU BE USED TO
INCREASE EMISSIONS THROUGH
OIL PRODUCTION ALTERNATELY
THE USE OF CARBON DIOXIDE FOR
EOR SUPPORTS CONTINUED FOSSIL
FUEL PRODUCTION AND USE YOU
ARE PRESENT SERIOUS HEALTH
SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENTAL RISKS
PARTICULARLY FOR MARGINALIZED
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES FOR
EXAMPLE AN ER FIELD IN WYOMING
LEAK TEN SPEED CARBON INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE NEXT TO A PUBLIC
SCHOOL WITH AIR POLLUTION TO
SERVE THAT IT ALMOST IT TOOK
AN ENTIRE SCHOOL YEAR TO RETURN
TO THE PROMISED THAT WAS SAFE
ANOTHER STUDY FOUND A STRONG
CORRELATION BETWEEN EARTHQUAKES
AND YOUR THE INTERGOVERNMENTAL
PANEL ON CLIMATE CHANGE IPCC
HAS RE SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE RISK OF CO
TWO LEAKAGE FROM YOUR AND THE U.
S. EPA RECOGNIZES THAT EXISTING
OIL WELLS MAY NOT BE SUITABLE
FOR PERMANENT SEQUESTRATION AS
CONVERSATIONS CONTINUE AROUND
THE FUTURE OF C. C. U. S. IN
THE STATE WE MUST MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT INCREASING OR PRODUCTION
WILL NOT HELP SELECT THE STATE
IT'S CHEAPER CLIMATE GOALS TODAY
WE HAVE A STEVEN FIGHT WITH
THE CENTER OF US INTERNATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW AND MUDDY
KUSTRA METIS FROM CRP TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU M. WELCOME TO THE LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES TOTAL SO EVERYONE SPLIT
THAT UP AMONGST THE TWO OF YOU
MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU
OKAY -- YES
WE GOT YOU RIGHT GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY
MY NAME IS STEVEN SITE AND ON
THE TOURNEY AT THE CENTER FOR
INTERNATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
LAW AN ORGANIZATION THAT USES
THE POWER OF THE LAW TO PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT PROMOTE HUMAN
RIGHTS AND SHORT LEFT TEMPLE
ID'S TODAY I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
SB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND
DISCUSS WHAT'S YOUR TV ARDEN
CARBON CAPTURE PROJECTS SHOULD
BE PROHIBITED IN CALIFORNIA
NOW THE CARBON CAPTURED NORM
HANSELL RECOVERY OR NEW THOSE
HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR DECADES
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
CAPTURE CARBON DIOXIDE ISN'T
SIMPLY DANTE AIR HAS BEEN USED
IN ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY OTHER
USES OF UNDERGROUND STORAGE DO
NOT EVEN COME CLOSE MORE THAN
NINETY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
CARBON CAPTURE CAPACITY IN THE
UNITED STATES IS OR HAS BEEN
USED FOR EOR BUT THIS IS NOT A
COINCIDENCE IT'S A DELIBERATE
EFFORT BY THE OIL INDUSTRY TO
OPEN UP NEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR
OIL PRODUCTION THE PUSH FOR
CARBON CAPTURE THAT MUCH ABOUT
EXPANDING OIL PRODUCTION AS
IT IS ABOUT FORTY MINUTES I'M
A FRIENDLY VENEER ON YOU'LL
AND DON'T JUST TAKE MY WORD
FOR IT NATIONALEN HAVE TOTAL
RECOVERY INITIATIVE WHICH IS
NOW THE CARBON CAPTURE COALITION
ESTATE PLAINLY THAT QUOTE THE
MAIN BARRIER TO TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF CO TWO EOR HENSCHEL HAVE
BEEN INSUFFICIENT SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE C. WITH CUTE IT ALSO
NOTE THAT QUOTE THE INDUSTRY'S
FUTURE GROWTH DEPENDS ON
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE LARGE
AMOUNTS TO THAT RESULTS FROM
ELECTRICITY GENERATION AND
INDUSTRIAL PROCESS THE NOW
CARBON CAPTURE ITSELF IS THE
TECHNOLOGY WITH THE HISTORY
OF IT COSTS TOO MUCH DOES TOO
LITTLE AND HAS TOO MANY OTHER
NEGATIVE IMPACTS TO PLAY A MAJOR
PART IN SOLVING THE CRIME RIGHT
AT THE I. P. C. C. RECENTLY
LAID OUT IN THEIR REPORT ON
CLIMATE MITIGATION OVER THE
NEXT DECADE CARBON CAPTURE HAS
AMONG THE LEAST POTENTIAL AND
THE GREATEST COSTS OF EDUCATION
OPTIONS BUT TO THE DEGREE THAT
CARBON CAPTURE IS DEPLOYED ALL
IT MUST NOT BE USED TO CLAIM
CLIMATE ACTION ON THE ONE HAND
WHILE BOOSTING OIL PRODUCTION
ON THE OTHER THANK YOU
OKAY SO JUST TO A
LITTLE MORE THAN ONE MINUTE
FOR THE FOR THE NEXT WITNESS
THE NAME IS MICHAEL IS A
MEDICINE I'M A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER FOR THE CENTER ON
RACE POVERTY AND THE ENVIRONMENT
I LIVE IN KERN COUNTY WHERE
I WAS BORN AND RAISED KERN
IS ALSO HOME TO ABOUT SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT OF THE OIL AND
GAS EXTRACTION IN THE STATE AND
THE EXTRACTION TENDS TO HAPPEN
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND THIS PATTERN IS NO
COINCIDENCE IT IS THE RESULT
OF ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM I
HAVE SPENT MUCH TIME TALKING
TO CURRENT COMMUNITY MEMBERS
ABOUT THEIR CONCERNS WILL --
EXTRACTION AND THE CONCERNS
ARE ALWAYS THE SAME POLLUTED
AIR WATER AND LAND HAS BECAUSE
ASTHMA CANCER AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND NEIGHBORS AND THIS SHOULD
NOT BE HAPPENING PUBLIC HEALTH
STUDIES ALSO CONFIRMED HIS
CONCERNS AND THERE'S ALSO HIGH
RATES OF CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
AND ADVERSE BIRTH OUTCOMES
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ALSO WORRIED
ABOUT C. C. U. S. AND THIS
BILL DOESN'T DEAL DIRECTLY
WITH -- CARBON CAPTURE BUT IT
DOES STOP THE MOST TOXIC USE
OF CARBON WHICH IS ENHANCED OIL
RECOVERY AND THIS IS ESPECIALLY
DANGEROUS TYPE OF OIL EXTRACTION
SLIMMER THE FRACKING THE HARMS
OF ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY OF
ALL TYPES ARE WELL DOCUMENTED
BUT THERE ARE SPECIAL CONCERNS
WITH USING CARBON DIOXIDE WHICH
IS A DEADLY SUFFOCATING GAS
ALTHOUGH THIS TECHNOLOGY IS NOT
WIDELY DEPLOYED WE HAVE ALREADY
SEEN A SERIOUSLY WHICH CLOSE
THE SCHOOL WYOMING FOR NEARLY
AN ENTIRE YEAR AND ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS A
CONCERN KERN COUNTY RESIDENT
MYSELF I IMPLORE YOU TO NOT
STUMBLE INTO THIS THAT AND FOR
CLIMBING COMMUNITIES AND PLEASE
VOTE YES ON THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WILL TURN OUT TO GENERAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE -- TURNING FIRST TO
THOSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WELCOME GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ELAINE ORTIZ
ON BEHALF OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
ACTION FUND IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
MELISSA ROMERO IF CALIFORNIANS
ARE MENTAL VOTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MARK FENSTER
MAKER ON BEHALF OF EARTHJUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEING
NO OTHERS IN THE HEARING
ROOM LET'S TURN TO THE LINE'S
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
QUEUE THE PHONE LINES FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY SIX
-- JENNIFER CRAVEN NEELAKANTA
COLLECTIVE LA FOR FUN
IS ALL DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ENVIRONMENTAL POCKETS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT NINE EIGHTY THREE
I NEED THE THREE GO AHEAD PLEASE
RIGHT EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE
JACK PARKER AT THREE FIFTY
FELLOW VALIANT STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE ONE HUNDRED
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IGOR THE
FRECKLED HI DENSIFICATION PARK
ASSIST CHAIR UP THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ENVIRONMENTAL
CAUCUS BUT MAKING AN INDIVIDUAL
INSTRUCTS THE PARK THANK YOU
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
LINE NINETY ONE
HELLO MICHAEL RINCON
ALLIANCES POPPING MANCHESTER'S
DISTANCE PERCEPTION OF THE
LOS ANGELES AND WE SUPPORT
-- SB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
VERY GOOD THANK YOU NEXT
LINE ONE FIFTEEN
EGGMAN CARE MEMBERS AND
WHATNOT ON THE CENTER'S
FROM WORK THANK YOU
THIRTY NINE FIFTY SIX
DR JIM STEWART LONG
BEACH YES DO IT
THANK YOU NEXT BY TWENTY
FIVE GOOD MORNING VALERIE
PANTRY HUTTON THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT LINE FORTY NINE
NUMBER FOUR HAVE A TON OF
BOOKING ON THE HALF OF FOUR
HUNDRED THEIR SHIFT FOR HOME
FROM COLLEGE THANK YOU NEXT
LINE THIRTEEN GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ROSY AND WITH
WITH THE CAN THEY HOPE FIND THAT
COALITION WE URGE YOU TO VOTE
YES ON SB ONE THREE ONE FOUR
TO PROVIDE GLOBAL FUEL POLLUTION
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
LINE SEVENTY EIGHT
HI THIS IS TRAVIS LEE
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT
JOB -- IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
ONE FIFTY THREE
HI MY NAME'S GENEVIEVE AND FORMS
AFTER THE CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
IT'S OUR LITTLE JUSTICE NETWORK
GETTING IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
FINE FORTY EIGHT
HI THIS IS BEN GRANDY ON BEHALF
OF ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT HI
I'M DOCTOR ROBERT GOULD
PRESIDENT OF SAN FRANCISCO
BAY POSITIONS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
LINE SEVENTY THREE
THE MORNING SHERRY WE ON BEHALF
OF THREE TO THREE THOUSAND
LEGISLATIVE ALLIANCE AND THREE
FIFTY SOUTH BAY LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT NINE NINE
HELLO ROAD TO CENTRAL VALLEY
AIR QUALITY COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF PRESIDENT SUPPORT
FOR THREE FIFTY SOUTH LAND
LEGISLATIVE ALLIANCE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER
AND LEADERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH
ONE ONE SIXTEENTH
OUR GOOD MORNING CATHY
SEE FIRSTHAND FERNANDO
VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MICHELLE
FOR NEXT BIND
ONE THE SEVENTIES YEAH
I AM READY TO TAP CAN YOU
RESIDENTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
TWO PERCENT SIXTY PERCENT
DIFFERENT KIND OF
THAT'S ALL EXIST YEAH OKAY
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY
VERY GOOD -- NOW WILL TURN TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION -- I
THINK WE HAVE LET'S SEE HERE
HE JUST ONE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES THAT'S CORRECT MISTER
LEERY WELCOME YOU CAN PROCEED
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS CHAIR AND
SANDERS ACT LARRY ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION HERE -- REGRETTABLY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN THE TRUTH -- BANA
SCIENTIFICALLY PROVEN WAY TO
SEQUESTER CARBON -- NUMEROUS
EXPERTS ACROSS THE WORLD ARE
IDENTIFYING CCS IS A CRITICAL
POLICY THAT'S GOING TO BE
NEEDED TO ADDRESS THE CLIMATE
CRISIS HERE IN CALIFORNIA THIS
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
IS CURRENTLY GOING THROUGH THEIR
-- SCOPING PLAN PROCESS PLANNING
FOR THE STATE'S A CLIMATE GOALS
IDENTIFYING CCS IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT AS ONE OF THE TOOLS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO
BE ABLE TO REACH THOSE TARGETS
-- REGRETTABLY THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN ATTEMPTS TO STIFLE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF CCS IN CALIFORNIA
BY BANNING A SPECIFIC FORM
OF SEQUESTRATION AS THE
AUTHOR MENTIONS CO TWO EOR
-- CO TWO EOR HAS BEEN AROUND
SINCE THE EARLY SEVENTIES
IT'S THE MATURE COMMERCIAL
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S BEEN USED
HISTORICALLY WITH NATURAL
OCCURRING CARBON -- BUT
WITH THE ADVANCEMENT OF NOW
-- CAPTURE TECHNOLOGIES YOU
CAN TAKE THAT INDUSTRIAL CARBON
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE RELEASED
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE AND USE IT
FOR THIS PURPOSE UNFORTUNATELY
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN IS COUNTER
TO THE CARBS PROGRAM INTENDED
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM FUELS CONSUMED
IN CALIFORNIA THE LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD WHICH SET UP A
PROTOCOL THAT ALLOWS CO TWO
EOR AS A VIABLE FORM TO REDUCE
AND THE SEQUESTER CARBON --
THE SORRY
THE EVOLUTION TO A LOWER CARBON
ECONOMY -- SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ON AND REDUCING EMISSIONS
NOT TO SPENDING FORMS OF WAYS
TO REDUCE THOSE EMISSIONS WE
NEED TO YOU KNOW THE STATE'S
VERY AMBITIOUS ON ITS CLIMATE
TARGETS BUT IT APPEARS TO BE
TIMID ON THESE TOOLS THAT WERE
ACTUALLY GONNA NEED TO GET
THEIR OF THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
WILL TAKE -- CLIMATE SOLUTION
AND TO ALL OFF THE TABLE
REGRETTABLY I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A NO VOTE TODAY IN
COMMITTEE THANK YOU
-- GENERAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM SEEING TO
CHRIS HAD AN EXECUTIVE SECRETARY
OF THE LOS ANGELES ORANGE
COUNTY'S BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL OKAY VERY GOOD
THANKS NEXT THANK YOU VERGE
WELSH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CARBON CAPTURE COALITION ALSO
POSE FOR THE REASONS STATED
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT ANYONE LOOKING HERE AND
SEEING NONE LET'S TURN THE LINE
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE GIVE
EVERYONE IN GENERAL OPPOSITION
TO THIS MEASURE SPEAK TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE NINETY FOUR
YEAH HI CAN YOU HEAR ME
ON THE OTHER YEAH YES
ANY BUT THERE'LL MODERATE
THAT GOES COUNTY BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
ARE OPPOSED TO SB ONE THREE ONE
FOUR WHEN THANK EIGHT
BUILDING TRADES CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT LINE SEVENTY TWO
HI ANTHONY THIS YEAR'S SUMMIT
BUSINESS AGENT FOR LOCAL SIXTEEN
HEAT ACROSS INSULATORS AND WE
STAND WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT NINE FIFTY SEVEN
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S BENITO ROBLIN FONG WITH
THE LAKERS DISTRICT COUNCIL
AND -- WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
NEXT WHITE LINE SIXTY ONE
ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE
NINE SIXTY ONE GO AHEAD
THIS IS YOUR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME VERY GOOD THANK YOU --
WILL TURN TO THE DYESS SAID
EARLIER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ARM THIS BILL AND THE
NEXT BILLS ARE GENERALLY
ARE ON THE SAME SUBJECT AND
I THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT IS
IF YOU STAND BACK FOR ME THE ONE
FOR ME AS AN INDIVIDUAL R.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE US OUR WORK
ON THIS ISSUE AND FIGURE IT
OUT AND IT AND IT SEEMS THAT IF
WE'RE FACILITATING ADDITIONAL
OIL EXTRACTION AS PART OF THE
PROCESS THAT IS IN SOME WAYS
DEFEATING OF OUR CLIMATE GOALS
AND ONE OF THE WITNESSES SAID A
REDUCE EMISSIONS IS A GOAL BUT
IF THERE WAS ONE A LETTER
OR NOT I WAS LOOKING FOR HERE
THAT CAME IN THAT SAID WE NEED
THIS TO EXTRACT MORE OIL WHAT
THAT IS IS SORT OF UNCLEAR
ON THE CONCEPT IT IS SORT OF A
CLIMATE PROGRAM THAT LEADS TO
MORE FOSSIL FUELS AND I THINK
YET -- WE DO NEED TO WORK
ON CARBON CAPTURE WE DO NEED
TO WORK ON IT IN SOME WAY
BEING PART OF OUR A SUITE
OF ALTERNATIVES BUT THE QUESTION
IS IS THERE A WAY TO DO IT
THAT ADDRESSES SOME OF THESE
OTHER ISSUES AND I THINK I
MIGHT HAVE PROBLEMS OF MY OWN
WITH EITHER THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
OR ELEVEN OH ONE BUT WHAT'S
IMPORTANT I THINK HERE THAT I
AM GOING TO VOTE TO MOVE BOTH
BILLS ALONG BECAUSE I KNOW THEIR
CONVERSATIONS GOING ON TO TRY
TO GET TO A UNIFIED POSITION
THAT TAKES ACCOUNT INTO ACCOUNT
SOME OF THE CONCERNS I RAISED
AND SO AT THE APPROPRIATE
POINT I'M GOING TO MOVE THIS
BILL BECAUSE I THINK WE SHOULD
ALLOW THOSE DISCUSSIONS TO GO
AHEAD AND WE CAN SEE IF WE CAN
FIND A PLACE THAT WE CAN MOVE
AHEAD TOGETHER ON THIS THANK
YOU OKAY RECOGNIZE THAT IS
A MOTION FROM CENTER LAYERED
CENTER ALAN YEAH I MEAN MY MY
MY MY TEN CENSUS -- ALONG THE
LINES OF CENTER LATER OF COURSE
YOU KNOW WE WE PASSED THAT COVER
YOUR BILL OUT OF -- IF I'M A
QUALITY COMMITTEE LAST WEEK
AND -- I KNOW IT'S UP TODAY
I I KNOW THERE'S -- SAMANTHA
THE AS A WORK ON SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION FOR MR LERI PERHAPS IS
-- AND IF LIKE I I UNDERSTAND
YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL
TOTALLY GET IT -- ARE
YOU OF THE OPINION THAT YOU
RATHER HAVE IF YOUR CHOICE IS
BETWEEN BOTH THIS BILL MACABRE
YOU'RE A BILL OR NOTHING AT ALL
WHERE WHERE DO YOU FORTY FIVE
I THINK OUR GENERAL POSITION
IS CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
SUPPORTED CCS AND CO TWO EOR
THROUGH THE L. CFS PROTOCOL
THAT WAS DEVELOPED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I THINK HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME POLICY
CHANGES -- TO ALLOW PROJECTS
TO HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA MAINLY
WITH REGARDS TO THE CENTER
COVER HEROES BILL DEALING
WITH POOR SPACE ALSO PIPELINES
AND PERMITTING ARE SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES THAT WOULD HINDER
PROJECTS BEING DONE SO THAT'S
OUR GENERAL POSITION ON WHAT
WE THINK AND BELIEVE NEEDS
TO BE ACCOMPLISHED IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THESE PROJECTS BE A PART OF THE
CLIMATE SOLUTION GOING FORWARD
OKAY I'M THEY'RE GOING
TO DO THAT AND THEN I I
UNDERSTAND YOUR YOU ALSO GOT A
LOT OF FOLKS TO GO TO WORK WITH
SO -- OKAY SO I MEAN I I GUESS
MY I'M I'M IN I'M TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AND AND -- YOU KNOW
I I THIS IS OF COURSE PART OF
A BROAD THE IT'S GOING TO BE
HAPPENING AS WE GO ALONG AND
I KNOW YOU INC CENTER COMING
UP AND AT THE HEART OF THE
NEGOTIATION OF A CCS -- WITHIN
THE CLIMATE WORKING GROUP AS
WELL AND I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU FOR YOUR FOR THE MANY MANY
HOURS EVEN PUTTING IT ON THIS
VERY TOUGH ISSUE STILL TRYING
TO GET OUR HEADS AROUND SO I'M
I'M CERTAINLY GONNA OF A FOR THE
BILL OKAY THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN
AND -- I'LL JUST SAY BRIEFLY
THAT I YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE
THE THIS MEASURE IT'S ACTUALLY
PRETTY -- LIMITED AND
AND STRAIGHTFORWARD IN SCOPE
-- THERE ARE GOING TO BE OTHER
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE TO TACKLE
WHEN IT COMES TO URBAN CAPTURE
AND SEQUESTRATION -- THAT
IN TERMS OF PROTECTIONS BOTH
FOR FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES -- FOR
WORKER SAFETY AS WELL AS FOREST
CARBON CERTAINTY THAT REALLY
AREN'T CONTAINED IN THIS MEASURE
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
IN THIS ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY
SPACE WHICH -- WHICH
I THINK IS IS A SMART PLACE
TO START -- AND WE SHOULDN'T
BE RUSHING TO PRIORITIZE
-- -- A TECHNOLOGY APPLICATION
THAT THAT ESSENTIALLY SUBSIDIZES
EXISTING OIL INDUSTRY ACTIVITY
BUT I WILL SAY THAT I THINK
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY BUT
NOT SUFFICIENT I THINK WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO DO MORE I THINK
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT --
AIR QUALITY PROTECTIONS I THINK
YOU KNOW THERE'S A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS AND ISSUES WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH CENTER CABALLERO
AND HURT HER MEASURES WELL --
BUT YOU KNOW I I DO THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE A NECESSARY PIECE
OF THE PUZZLE SO I APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING IT FORWARD -- AND
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO TEST
TO STEP OUT AND TRY TO COME TO
SOME KIND OF SOLUTION HERE --
TO HELP EVERYBODY MOVE FORWARD
SO I'LL BE SUPPORT MEASURES
WELL AND ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE
UNLESS THERE'S ANY OTHER FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AN N.
A. A. THINK M. AS IT'S BEEN SAID
ONE OF THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT YOU KNOW THINKING ABOUT
CCS IS WHETHER CCS IS GOING
TO BE A CLIMATE STRATEGY OR AN
OIL EXTRACTION STRATEGY AND
I AM OF THE MIND THAT IT IS A
CLIMATE TRAGEDY AND I DO NOT
BELIEVE IT AND I DO NOT WANT
CCS TO BE THE NORTH NEW FORM OF
FRACKING FOR CALIFORNIA AND AS
SUCH I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
DO THIS BUT I ALSO THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO CLARIFY
THIS BILL DOES NOT STOP CCS FROM
HAPPENING CCS PROJECTS CANCEL
HAPPENED THIS IS VERY SPECIFIC
TO ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY AT
BEING USED WITH CCS AND I THINK
THAT THAT IS SIGNIFICANT IT'S
NOT LOST ON THIS BODY THAT
SENATE RECOVER YET ON I HAVE
SPENT AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
HOURS DISCUSSING THIS -- AND
WE SHARE MULTIPLE PERSPECTIVES
ABOUT HOW TO GET TO THE FINAL
LINE UNTIL FINAL FINISH LINE
-- BUT CERTAINLY THIS IS PART
OF A GREATER CONVERSATION --
WITH THIS BODY -- A BUT ALSO
AGREED OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
OUR STAKEHOLDERS SO WE ARE AT
YOU KNOW AND AND I GUESS I AM
COMMITTED AND IN IT IS MY GUESS
THAT YOU WILL ALSO HEAR THAT'S
HER COVER LETTER WAS SAY THAT
SHE'S COMMITTED TO THE ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS AT TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE WE AT MAINLAND ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE AND SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- SO THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SO WITH THAT CHIEF CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE ITEM
TO S. B. THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
MOTIONS DO PASSED THE FIRST
BE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS STERN HI
STERN ALL RIGHT JONES ALLEN
HI ELLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
HUESO LAYERED HI LEARN ALL RIGHT
LIMóN HI THE MOON HI VERY
GOOD THAT MEASURES FIVE VOTES
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS -- NEXT WE HAVE
FILE ITEM THREE S. B. ELEVEN OH
ONE CENTER CABALLERO WELCOME
IT THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS UP FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT S. B. ELEVEN OH
ONE WHICH SEEKS TO FURTHER
CALIFORNIA'S POLICY GOALS
TO REACH ECONOMY WIDE CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
I SUPPORTING CARBON CAPTURE
SEQUESTRATION AND UTILIZATION
PROJECTS WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK ON THE BILL I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF I'M AS WELL
AS THE CLIMATE CHANGE WORKING
GROUP AS WE CONTINUE OUR WORK TO
DEVELOP CONCEPTS AND SOLUTIONS
ON ISSUES SUCH AS CARBON THAT TO
INCLUDE CARBON CAPTURE CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE AND NET NEGATIVE EMISSIONS
THEREAFTER WILL REQUIRE A
MULTITUDE OF CLIMATE CHANGE
INITIATIVES ONE THAT IS VITAL
TO OUR STATE SUCCESS IS CARBON
CAT CAPTURE UTILIZATION AND
SEQUESTRATION OR C. C. U. S.
THIS IS A SENTIMENT SHARED WITH
OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS IN ORDER
TO ACHIEVE PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
AMBITIOUS DOMESTIC CLIMATE GOAL
OF NET ZERO EMISSIONS ECONOMY
WIDE BY TWENTY FIFTY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION PROJECTS THE
NEED TO CAPTURE TRANSPORT
AND PERMANENTLY SEQUESTER
SIGNIFICANT QUANTITIES OF CARBON
DIOXIDE THERE IS A REAL TIME
BENEFIT TO SEE COS THAT
PROVIDES IT ENVIRONMENTALLY THE
PROCESS CAPTURE CAPTURES CARBON
DIOXIDE EMISSIONS STRAIGHT FROM
THE SOURCE TO AVOID RELEASED
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE IN FACT
CARBON CAPTURE METHOD SEQUESTER
MORE THAN NINETY PERCENT OF CO
TWO EMISSIONS FROM POWER POWER
PLANTS AND INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES
NINETY PERCENT OF WHAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE RELEASED THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TOOL AND A
PRACTICAL METHOD ESTIMATES ALSO
INDICATE APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN
PERCENT OF THE STATE'S TOTAL CO
TWO EMISSIONS CAN BE CAPTURED
AND STORED WITH C. C. U.
S. C. C. U. S. HAS BENEFITS
ENVIRONMENTALLY BUT ALSO FOR OUR
WORK FORCE AND OVERALL ECONOMY
THE USE OF C. C. U. S. WOULD
ENABLE DIFFICULT TO DECARBONISE
INDUSTRIES TO STAY IN BUSINESS
AND CONTINUE TO MAKE LARGE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY WHILE DRAMATICALLY
REDUCING THEIR GHG EMISSIONS C.
C. U. S. ACTIVITIES WOULD ALSO
PROVIDE GOOD PAYING JOBS FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH SKILL SETS
THAT WE NEED TO SUPPORT AS WE
MAKE IT CLEAN ENERGY TRANSITION
ALSO CONSIDER THAT MANY
ORGANIZATIONS AND COMMERCIALIZE
SECTORS ARE READILY ABLE TO
SUPPLY C. C. U. S. TECHNOLOGIES
TO THEIR OPERATIONS WHAT IS
NEEDED IS STATE SUPPORT IN THE
FORM OF A REGULATORY FRAMEWORK
S. B. ELEVEN OH ONE PURSUES
THIS GOAL BY ESTABLISHING A
CARBON CAPTURE UTILIZATION AND
SEQUESTRATION PROGRAM UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD THE PRIMARY OBJECTIVE
OF WHICH IS TO ASSIST THE
DEPLOYMENT OF PROJECTS THAT
WILL ACCELERATE THE DEVELOPMENT
DEPLOYMENT AND COMMERCIALIZATION
OF ADVANCED NEW TECHNOLOGIES
TO CAPTURE AND SEQUESTER
CARBON DIOXIDE EMISSIONS IN
INDUSTRIAL AND COMMERCIAL
FACILITIES THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD HAS ALREADY
RECOGNIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF
C. C. U. S. TO HELP THE STATE
MEET ITS GOAL RELATED TO GHG
REDUCTIONS BY INCLUDING IT IN
ITS SCOPING PLAN AS AN IMPORTANT
CLIMATE CHANGE SOLUTION
SOLUTION ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL WILL ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
UNDERGROUND POOR SPACE FOR THE
SEQUESTRATION IN MOST STATES
OWNERSHIP OF THE SUBSURFACE
PORE SPACE PROPERTY RIGHTS
GENERALLY BELONG TO THE OWNER
AT THE SURFACE PROPERTY RIGHT
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
LACKS A CLEAR AND DEFINED
LEGAL FRAMEWORK FOR POOR SPACE
OWNERSHIP FOR CARBON DIOXIDE
SEQUESTRATION CLARIFICATION A
POOR SPACE OWNERSHIP WILL ALLOW
CARBON CAPTURE PROJECTS TO
QUALIFY UNDER THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE CALIFORNIA'S LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD SO COMPANIES CAN
APPLY THE REDUCTION OF CARBON
TO THE TARGET SET BY CARB UNDER
THIS STANDARD AND ALIGNING ONE
STANDARD WITH THE FEDERAL C. C.
U. S. REGULATIONS WILL ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA IS WORKING
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS TO
MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS IN AN
EFFICIENT AND LOGICAL FASHION
WE ALSO DISCUSSED THE --
LIABILITY ISSUES AS WELL AS
THE NEED FOR THERE TO BE --
LIABILITY -- INDEFINITELY INTO
THE FUTURE AND THAT OBVIOUSLY
-- IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT WHEN
WE START TALKING ABOUT POOR
SPACE CALIFORNIA COULD BECOME
A GLOBAL LEADER IN C. C. U.
S. DEVELOPMENT AND DEPLOYMENT
TO ACHIEVE ITS CLIMATE GOALS
AS IT HAS IN OTHER CLEAN
ENERGY TECHNOLOGIES BUT TO
DO SO IT NEEDS TO ACT AND ACT
COMPREHENSIVELY BY SUPPORTING
MEASURES THAT ENDEAVOR TO
UTILIZE C. C. U. S. TO THE
STATE'S BENEFIT WE CAN CREATE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHILE WE WORK TO
ATTAIN OUR STATES CLIMATE CHANGE
GOALS TESTER MY TESTIFYING
REMOTELY IN SUPPORT IS DR
SARAH SALTER MANAGING DIRECTOR
AT STANFORD CENTER FOR CARBON
STORAGE AND IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IS CHRIS HANNON WITH THAT
LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHEN I FIRST TURNED TO THE LINE
AND THEN TO THE WITNESS IN THE
HEARING ROOM EARLY WITNESSES
SAID OKAY WE'LL TURN THE PHONE
LINES FIRST CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES YOU'RE WITH US OKAY
OKAY MY NAME IS DONE UP THERE
AND I'M THE MANAGING DIRECTOR
OF THE STANFORD CENTER FOR
CARBON STORAGE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR INVITING ME TO BE HERE
TODAY AT STANFORD WE RECENTLY
COMPLETED A STUDY ON PCS AND IF
I COULD SHARE WITH YOU A COUPLE
KEY FINDINGS AND THEN ADDRESS
HAVE PLENTIFUL ELEVEN OF ONE
COULD HELP ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES FIFTY CS IN THE STATE
THE OPPORTUNITY THE INDUSTRIAL
ELECTRICITY FACTORS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FROM UP TO FORTY
PERCENT CALIFORNIA'S EMISSIONS
IN OUR STUDY WE IDENTIFIED
SEVENTY SIX IDEAL CANDIDATES FOR
CARBON CAPTURE RETRO CALIFORNIA
HAS ALSO ONE OF THE LARGEST
GEOLOGIC STORAGE POTENTIALS
IN THE US WITH THE CAPACITY
TO STORE OVER SEVENTY GIGATONS
OF CO TWO THE OPPORTUNITY
PROCEED YES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HUGE BUT SO ARE THE
CHALLENGES IN CALIFORNIA THERE
IS UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHO OWNS
THE UNDERGROUND OF COURSE SPACE
OR SPACE REFERS TO THE VOID
IN ROCK THAT ARE NOT OCCUPIED
BY SOLID MATTER WHICH COULD BE
USED FOR STORING CARBON DIOXIDE
CARBON CCS PROTOCOL REQUIRES
THAT A PROJECT OPERATOR MUST
SHOW PROOF OF EXCLUSIVE RIGHT
TO USE THE POOR SPACE IN ORDER
TO OBTAIN LCMS CREDITS WHICH
AS WE KNOW ARE CRITICAL FOR
THE FINANCIAL VIABILITY OF
MOSTLY YES PROJECTS IN ORDER
TO PROMOTE THE DEVELOPMENT YES
IN CALIFORNIA THERE IS A NEED
FOR CLEAR RESOLUTION TO THIS
PROPERTY LAW ISSUES IDEALLY
ALLOWING OPERATORS TO ESTABLISH
THE NEEDED RIGHTS AT MINIMUM
FINANCIAL AND TRANSACTIONAL
COSTS SENATE BILL ELEVEN A
ONE WOULD PROVIDE GREATER
PREDICTABILITY FOR CCS OPERATORS
AND ALLEVIATE A MAJOR ROADBLOCK
BLOCK TO INVESTMENT IN CCS
PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NO TURN TO
LEAD SUPPORTING HEARING ROOM
MISTER HAN AND WELCOME BACK
GOOD MORNING AGAIN COMMITTEE
CHAIR HONORABLE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRIS HAND
AND EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF THE
LOS ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY'S
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL AND TODAY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND HARD
WORKING SKILLED MEN AND WOMEN
IN THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF IT S.
B. ELEVEN OH ONE CARBON CAPTURE
AS A TOOL THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO MEET ITS CLIMATE GOALS OUR
CLIMATE GOALS ARE AMBITIOUS
OUR CLIMATE GOALS ARE JUST AND
CARBON CAPTURE IS ONE TOOL AND
HELPING US REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS I'M DIFFICULT TO
MITIGATE INDUSTRIES WE NEED
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA -- WE
CANNOT BE A STATE THAT JUSTICE
SUPPORTED ON TOURISM WE NEED
INDUSTRY WITHIN THE INDUSTRY
DOESN'T WORK OUR MEMBERS DON'T
WORK CALIFORNIA DOESN'T WORK
AND WHEN CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
WORK -- FAMILIES HAVE A
REAL HARD TIME PROVIDING FOR
THEMSELVES AND EACH OTHER --
WE'RE WORKING ON AMBITIOUS
PROJECTS RIGHT NOW INDUSTRIAL
SOLAR LARGE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT LOS
ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY'S AND
ALL AROUND THE STATE THESE
AMBITIOUS PROJECTS AND LOOKED
TO BE WORKING SOON ON OFFSHORE
WIND AND ONSHORE WIND --
THESE INDUSTRIES NEED LOCAL
SUPPLIES OF STEEL OF CONCRETE
PRODUCTION OF STEEL AND
CONCRETE EMITS GREENHOUSE GASES
CARBON CAPTURE MITIGATES THAT
CARBON CAPTURE ALSO MITIGATES
GREENHOUSE GASES FROM THE ENERGY
SECTOR WE NEED I DIVERSE
ENERGY SECTOR HERE WERE FACED
WITH A LOT WILD FIRES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN BASE
IN POWER GENERATION IS NEEDED
TO PROVIDE RELIABLE SOURCES
OF ENERGY FOR CALIFORNIANS
DURING DRAMATIC TIMES LIKE
WILD FIRES CARBON CAPTURE
HELPS MITIGATE THE HOUSE GASES
WE SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME FOR THE OPPORTUNISTIC
THANK YOU MR HANNAN OF NO
ATTORNEY GENERAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT THOSE IN THE HEARING ON
WHICH TESTIFY CAN PLEASE LINE UP
WELCOME MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THE -- PEYTO'S REPRESENTING
CALPINE IN STRONG SUPPORT VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAMBERS THAT RAN WITH THEIR OWN
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS
IN SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU
ZACH LARRY ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS M. VERGE WELSH WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CARBON CAPTURE
COALITION VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU JOHN ONE TIME
FROM THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANKS ANY OTHERS SEEING ON THE
HEARING ROOM AUTOMATICALLY TURN
THE LINES FOR GENERAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN A ONE
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME WELL FIRST IN LINE
BURKE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE WHAT
MY NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
AND MOVING ON WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
IT MAY YES WE HAVE YOU
OKAY ANYTHING NARAL MODERATE
FACTORS KIND OF BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADE WE
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN ALONG WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE BILLINGTREE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
MORNING PEOPLE FROM WITH
THE LABOR DISTRICT COUNCIL
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE LINE SEVENTY TWO
GOOD MORNING THAT'LL BE
HAPPENING THIS YEAR SO EVEN
IF IT LOCAL SIXTEEN FROST
INSULATORS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT -- S. B. ELEVEN
OH ONE THE BILL CONTRACT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
ONE THIRTY THREE ARE OPEN
MOVING ON WE HAVE LINED ONE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE CALL AT
MY NAME IS DANNY BURKE WITH
LOCAL THREE FORTY THREE THE
PROMISED INTEREST WE'RE DURING
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WE HAVE LINE ONE A
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR AVAILABLE
COMMITTEE WILL SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
ONCE AGAIN LINE SIXTY TWO EUROPA
NEARLY YES WE HAVE YOU
-- THIS OLD MODEL APPROACH
IT WITH THE BOILERMAKERS
LOCAL FIVE FORTY NINE WE'RE
SUPPORTING S. B. ELEVEN OH ONE
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WE HAVE LINE SIXTY SIX TWO FIVE
THE STUDY SHOWED WELL
THAT WILL POP FORTY NINE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK GREAT THANK YOU NEXT
WE HAVE LINE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
GOD WELL IT'S
ROCKET WILL MAKE A LOCAL NINETY
TO REPORT BUILT ELEVEN A ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
AND WE HAVE LINE EIGHTY
FIVE LET'S GO AHEAD
IN LIGHT EIGHTY
FIVE YOU ARE OPEN
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE HAVE YOU
-- YEAH JUMP ON A ROCK
WITH A HUMBLE BUILDING OR
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES WE STAND IN SUPPORT
WITH S. B. ELEVEN OH ONE WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
VERY GOOD THANK YOU NEXT
AND WE HAVE LINE ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE ONE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
YEAH MY NAME IS ERIN LEADER
AND I'M WITH BOILERMAKERS
LOCAL NINETY THROUGH IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ELEVEN OH
ONE THANK YOU NEXT
THERE ARE NO FOR THE
WIND TO QUEUE AT THIS
TIME PLEASE CONTINUE OKAY
VERY GOOD THAT THAT CONCLUDES
THEN ALL SUPPORT WITNESSES
FOR THE MEASURE -- LET'S
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION NOW
I THINK WE HAVE TO LEAD
OPPONENTS -- REGISTERED --
MISTER ARRESTS AND MISS ROMERO
-- HI EVERYONE PROCEED
IF THREE MINUTES TOTAL WHEN
HE WAS CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
WHAT IS THE ADDRESS NAME A STAFF
ATTORNEY AT THE SAN ANDREAS
POVERTY AND THE ENVIRONMENT
LET'S START WITH THE QUESTION
WHY WHY IS THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY FIGHTING SO HARD FOR
CLIMATE POLICY AFTER DECADES
OF LYING AND DELAYS THERE'S NO
EASY ANSWER THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
PROMOTING THEIR OWN PROFITS BY
PUSHING THE STATE INTO A CLAIM
IT DEAD AND WITH MORE LIES AND
MORE SACRIFICE OF FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES OVER EIGHTY PERCENT
OF CCS PROJECTS IN THE U. S.
OF SHUT DOWN PREMATURELY OR
NEVER OPERATED THOSE THAT OF
THOSE THAT REMAIN NONE HAVE
MET THEIR PROMISED REDUCTIONS
AND THE VAST MAJORITY HAVE
NET POSITIVE CARBON EMISSIONS
THESE PROJECTS ARE EXPENSIVE
AND INEFFICIENT RELYING ON
MASSIVE TAXPAYER SUBSIDIES
AND RESULTING IN TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY COSTS FOR THE STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS BERMAN
A JUSTICE ADVOCATE I PROBABLY
WOULDN'T BE HERE WARNING YOU
ABOUT THIS BOONDOGGLE BUT FOR
THE INCREDIBLE LOCAL HARMS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM ASSOCIATED
SEE COS DID CARBON CAPTURE
INCREASES LOCAL POLLUTION
BY DOUBLING DOWN ON EXISTING
POLLUTION INFRASTRUCTURE
WHICH IS USUALLY LOCATED IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR FURTHER CARBON DIOXIDE
PIPELINES ARE VERY DANGEROUS
TRANSPORTING A DEADLY SIX YET
THE CORRODES THE MATERIALS
THAT OUR PIPELINES ARE MADE UP
RISKING CATASTROPHIC RUPTURE
SO JESTER SIMILAR COMPOUNDED
BY INCREASED SEISMICITY THEN OF
COURSE THERE'S THE DEVASTATION
WROUGHT BY ENHANCED OIL
RECOVERY THE MOST COMMON AND
POINT FOR CAPTURED CARBON ID
BE IRRESPONSIBLE TO FASTRACK
CCS WITHOUT SOUND PROTECTIONS
IN PLACE TO DO SO WOULD CAUSE
IRREPARABLE HARM TO BOTH CLIMATE
AND COMMUNITIES AND THAT IS
PRECISELY WHAT SB ELEVEN A ONE
IS DESIGNED TO DO I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON THIS DISASTROUS
POLICY THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT MISS AMERICA
THANK YOU CHIANG THREE MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO OF CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS AND
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN NO ONE
WE HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE'S
FOCUS ON CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE IS A MAJOR CLIMATE
SOLUTION POLICY DISCUSSIONS
THIS YEAR AND WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO PLEASE CONSIDER
THE CLIMATE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY IMPLICATIONS OF ADVANCING
POLICY THAT ACCELERATES THE
STREAMLINED DEPLOYMENT CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE PARTICULARLY
AS IT RELATES TO FOSSIL FUEL
INFRASTRUCTURE CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE SHOULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED A CLIMATE SOLUTION
WHEN IT PROLONGS THE LIFETIME OF
FOSSIL FUEL INFRASTRUCTURE ARE
LOCKED IN A LONG TERM DEPENDENCE
ON OIL AND GAS THE ANALYSIS
CORRECTLY CONCLUDES THAT WHEN
LOOKING AT THE MAJORITY OF
CCS PROJECTS THAT EMISSIONS
ACTUALLY INCREASED BECAUSE
OF THE ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY
FACILITATED BY CCS TECHNOLOGY
THIS LEGISLATION WILL BE USED
TO INCREASE THE PRODUCTION OF
OIL AND GAS IN OUR STATE FURTHER
POLLUTE COMMUNITIES ALREADY
OVERBURDENED BY POLLUTION AND
ADVANCE A LEGAL FRAMEWORK THAT
WILL STREAMLINE THE BUILD OUT
OF CCS TECHNOLOGY TO BE USED BY
THE FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY WITHOUT
ADEQUATE SAFEGUARDS TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES IF THIS WERE ABOUT
INNOVATION AND DECARBONISING
HARD TO DECARBONISE INDUSTRY
INDUSTRY IS ONE HAS TO WONDER
WHY THE PROPONENTS BEHIND
THIS BILL BEING INTRODUCED ARE
LARGELY REPRESENT REPRESENTATIVE
OF FOSSIL FUEL INTERESTS
IF YOU AGREE THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN DO TO ACT ON CLIMATE
IS TO PHASE OUT RELIANCE ON
OIL AND GAS AND WE URGE THE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THIS COMMITTEE TO REJECT
POLICIES THAT WOULD PROLONG OUR
DEPENDENCE ON OIL AND GAS AND
INSTEAD URGED THE LEGISLATURE
TO PASS FAR MORE POLICIES
THAT ACCELERATE THE TRANSITION
AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS SAID
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS ROMERO
-- WILL NOT TURN TO GENERAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
IN THE HEARING ROOM SEEING
NINE MODERATE IF WE TURN
TO THE LINES THOSE WISHING
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION GENERAL
OPPOSITION S. B. ELEVEN A ONE
IF YOU DO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME WILL FIRST
GO TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THIS IS JANET
PROCTOR THREE FIFTY THOUGHT
VALLEY URGING YOU TO VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT AND NEXT WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
MY NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT
YOU ARE OPEN WAS GLAD
MOVING ALONG WE HAVE A
LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
YEAH YES
YES OKAY -- GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FINDING
THAT ERIC ROMAN I AM
CALLING IN TODAY TO OPPOSE AT
ELEVEN A ONE OF THE REASONS
OFFERED -- OF IT TOO --
-- THE TWO PEOPLE GIVING
TESTIMONY IN THE ROOM
REPRESENTING PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES -- SO BADLY INSTALLED
AND LOOK -- AND LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL PRODUCTION ABILITY IN
THE FAMILY CAN AND -- COACHELLA
OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
NEXT WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER
-- ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO AMBER HOW TO TRAIN HOPING
ON BEHALF OF THE PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES POSITION PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY FFA CONTENT
BASED POVERTY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT SCOPE LOS ANGELES
THE KIND OF TENER LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
RESPONSIBILITY AND BY MENTAL
HEALTH COALITION COMMON UNITED
METHODIST CHURCH AND COMPLETES
PROSPECT A PEN AND PAD IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT
AND NEXT WE HAVE LINE ONE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI ALL ONLY IN FROM BAKERSFIELD
AND KERN COUNTY RESIDENTS
SPEAKING AN OP -- UP
VERSION OF THE BILL THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE FIFTEEN THE BILL AT
ONE ONE FIFTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LET'S MOVE ON
AND WITH THAT -- NO FOR THE
WIND Q. OKAY VERY GOOD --
WILL BRING BACK TO THE DICE
-- I JUST SEE AT THE OUTSET
MEMBERS -- YOU'LL NOTE IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THERE
ARE -- -- A NUMBER OF ISSUES
RAISED AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON ON THIS BILL --
RANGING EVERYWHERE FROM
ADOPTING THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY COMMITTEE
WHICH IS THE ON PAGE THIRTEEN --
TRYING TO GET CONSISTENCY ON
OWNERSHIP ISSUES THE BETWEEN L.
CFS EPA RULES AND AND THIS
FRAMEWORK RUN OWNERSHIP --
ONE OF THE PRIMARY CENTRAL
CONCERNS THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM OPPOSITION CERTAINLY --
BARRING -- THIS PROGRAM FROM
CONNECTING OR BOARD -- UTILIZING
PROJECTS THAT THAT HAVE ENHANCED
OIL RECOVERY OR FOSSIL FUEL
PRODUCTION AND IN THEIR --
IN THEIR CONCEPTION AND IN
THEIR PRODUCTION ELEMENTS --
A LIABILITY FRAMEWORK THAT WE
HOPE AT LEAST FLAGS THE ISSUE
-- TO FOCUS ON PERMANENCE
-- -- THE FIFTH AMENDMENT
BEING FOCUSED ON -- SIR
WHAT THAT PERMANENCE COULD MEAN
INCLUDING CAPITALIZATION PLAN
I'M LOOKING AT A HUNDRED YOUR
SCENARIO FOR AT LEAST AN UP
FRONT CAPITALIZATION PLAN FOR
MAINTENANCE MONITORING PROJECT
REPAIRS THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT
ARE SUPPOSED TO LAST FOREVER
AND THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT ARIAN LAW FOR US TO
IRON OUT IT AND THEN ADDING
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE ALSO FROM
THE U. S. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY SO THAT
EVEN THOUGH A RB IS SORT OF
IDENTIFIED AS A LEAD AGENCY --
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
INDEPENDENT EXPERTISE IN
REGULATORY GUIDANCE COMING FROM
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY AND THEN I'M
TALKING ABOUT AN APPLICATION
WINDOW SO THAT WE'VE NOT
IDENTIFIED TO DATE CERTAIN
BUT SOME APPLICATION WINDOW TO
ALLOW TIME FOR APPLICANTS
TO COME FOR TO PUT PROJECTS OUT
THERE BUT ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE -- AND SORT OF RE
EVALUATE THE PROGRAM BEFORE
-- MOVING FORWARD IN PERPETUITY
-- SO THAT'S YOUR NUMBER
DIFFERENT MEASURES -- I KNOW
IN CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR
-- THAT I THINK WE'RE THERE ON
ALL BUT ONE ISSUE AT THIS POINT
-- AND THAT'S THE THAT'S WHAT
IS NOTED MEMBERS IS AMENDMENT
NUMBER THREE -- SO I I JUST
WANNA GET SOME CLARIFICATION
FROM THE AUTHOR JUST SO YOU
YOU'LL KNOW WHAT YOU'RE ASKING
QUESTIONS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
BUT I THINK MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT THAT
ALL OTHER AMENDMENTS OTHER THAN
THE AMENDMENT NUMBER THREE WHICH
DEALS SPECIFICALLY WITH THIS
EO OUR QUESTION -- THAT WE
JUST OUT WITHIN THE LIMóN BILL
ARE GOING TO BE ADOPTED HERE
BUT THAT -- BUT THAT OUTSTANDING
ISSUE OF OF WHAT
KINDS OF PROJECTS ARE ALLOWED
-- AND HOW THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN
ELEVEN NO ONE IN THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN WOULD WORK -- IN TERMS
OF ALLOWANCES OF OF ENHANCE YOUR
RECOVERY OR OTHER FOSSIL FUEL
PRODUCTION -- THAT WE ARE GOING
TO TRY TO RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES
NOT TODAY -- BUT GOING FORWARD
-- AND I'D LIKE TO SEE THEM
RESULT BEFORE THE FLOOR AND AND
WOULD WOULD SAY THAT YOU KNOW
I'M I'VE BEEN OFF OF ALL THE
BILLS THAT ALLOW THAT KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY TO BE UTILIZED --
ON A NUMBER OF OTHER MEASURES
BEFORE SO I DON'T WANT TO BE
INCONSISTENT IN MY TREATMENT
OF THESE BILLS BUT I WILL SAY
-- BASED ON THE COMMITMENT
OF THE AUTHOR AND HER VERY
CREDIBLE AND HARD WORK ON THIS
I'M AS WELL AS THE ON GOING
CONVERSATIONS I THINK CENTER
LATER REFERRED TO IN HIS REMARKS
ON CEREMONIES LEGISLATION
WILLING TO KEEP WORKING THROUGH
AMENDMENTS THREE AND TRY TO
TRY TO DETERMINE THE RIGHT
WAY TO PUT LIMITS ON FOSSIL
FUEL BASED PROJECTS HERE --
IF WE CAN'T SOLVE THAT BEFORE
THE FLOOR WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING
THIS MEASURE BUT -- BUT FOR
FOR PURPOSES OF DISCUSSION
AND ONGOING CONVERSATION I
THINK THAT WE CAN WE CAN DO
SOME ADDITIONAL WORK THERE
AND I WILL JUST SAY THAT --
IN THE ENHANCE YOUR RECOVERY
AND FOSSIL FUEL PRODUCTION SPACE
-- THERE ARE THERE ARE CERTAIN
LIMITS THAT I THINK ARE GOING
TO BE IMPORTANT THE AIRPORTS
ALREADY INDICATE IN THEIR
TESTIMONY ON -- THE SCOPING
PLAN LAST WEEK TERMS OF
PRIORITIZATION -- I THINK HE
Q. ADMIN PORTMAN'S ON THAT
ON THAT PRIORITIZATION BUT I
THINK THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
SIDE OF THESE SO MANY INDUSTRIES
THAT ARE TOUGH TO DECARBONISE IS
THE WE SUPPORT NOTED AND I THINK
THAT'S THOSE ARE EXACTLY THE
RIGHT SECTORS TO BE FOCUSED ON
YOUR DOING THE HARD STUFF HERE
YOU'RE NOT LOOKING AT THE THE
EASY LOW HANGING FRUIT THIS IS
THESE ARE THE MOST HARDEST COULD
BE THE MOST EXPENSIVE BUT VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES TO WRESTLE WITH
-- WHETHER IT'S IN A BIOMASS
APPLICATION WHETHER IT'S IN A
HYDROGEN APPLICATION THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF OTHER OTHER OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE SECTOR THAT
WE THINK GO BEYOND JUST SORT
OF THIS NARROW FOCUS ON FOSSIL
FUELS AND ENHANCED -- RECOVERY
THAT I THINK ACTUALLY COULD
HOLD SOME PROMISE TO BE A PROPER
SAFEGUARDS BUT -- I JUST WANTED
TO LAY THAT OUT FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE UNDERSTAND --
WHAT WERE THE CONVERSATIONS
I'VE HAD WE'VE HAD BETWEEN THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE AND
JUST GET A LITTLE -- AFFIRMATION
FROM THE AUTHOR IF IF THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A A WORKABLE
PLAN GOING FOR YES IT DOES
MISTER CHAIR AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT RECITATION OF
THE DISCUSSIONS WE'VE HAD --
IT I THINK I'VE TRIED
TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR I'M NOT
INTERESTED IN E. O. R.
-- AS PART OF THAT --
PART OF THAT THE DISK
THE DISCUSSIONS BUT WHEN YOU'RE
NEGOTIATING AND YOU'RE IT'S
GOOD FAITH NEGOTIATING SOMEBODY
HAS TO GIVE UP SOMETHING AND
SOMEBODY HAS TO GET SOMETHING
WE'RE NOT THERE YET WE'RE
WORKING ON THE DETAILS -- WE'RE
WORKING WITH -- THE WORKING
GROUP THAT THEIR LEADERSHIP
HAS PUT TOGETHER -- WHICH IS
ABLY CHAIRED BY SENATOR LAYERED
HE'S DONE AT A TREMENDOUS JOB
AT KEEPING OUR NOSE TO THE
GRINDSTONE -- AND IT IS
MY ANTICIPATION AND --
CENTERING THEM YOUR MOM CAN --
CAN AGREE OR NOT I THINK WE BOTH
WANT THIS TO BE RESOLVED BY THE
TIME WE GET TO THE FLOOR ONE WAY
OR ANOTHER AND THAT WILL HAVE A
PACKAGE THAT WILL HAVE A WHOLE
BUNCH OF ELEMENTS IN IT THAT
WILL -- REALLY
PROVIDE US AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO
A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT WE THINK
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT BOTH IN
TERMS OF -- AT PRODUCING
ENERGY WHICH WHICH WHICH WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO DO WE NEED A
GRADE THAT IS RELIABLE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY IT STARTS TO --
MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS BECAUSE
WE DON'T DO CARBON CAPTURE EVERY
BUDDY SAYS WE CAN'T GET THERE
WE HAVE VERY AMBITIOUS GOALS
WE CAN'T GET THERE AND AS WE
START TO GET THERE I'D LIKE TO
THINK WE CAN ALSO CLEAN UP OUR
POLLUTED AIR A LOT OF IT WHICH
RESIDES IN MY DISTRICT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND SO SO IT IT
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
A WHOLE BUNCH OF GOALS HERE
AND -- IT'S IT'S A DELICATE
THREAD AND -- WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH YOU IS THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE AS WE --
NARROW NARROW THE BILL'S DOWN
TO REALLY FOCUS ON ON HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE SO
I YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO
TAKE ALL ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THAT
ONE AND WE'RE WORKING ON IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- EARLIER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
I DID SAY WHAT I WANT A
LOT OF WHAT I WANT TO SAY
ON THE PREVIOUS BILL THE
END DUE TO GO ON -- AND I
APPRECIATE THE EXCHANGE WITH
THE CHAIR AND AND THE AUTHOR
-- I THOUGHT I WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE
MR HANNAN'S COMMENTS -- --
FOR -- FOR ONE REASON AND
THAT IS IS THAT I APPRECIATED
HIM TALKING ABOUT COMMITMENTS
TO GOALS AND THE FACT THAT
HE'S COMMITTED I APPRECIATED
HIS MENTION OF OFFSHORE WIND
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS ANOTHER
PLACE THAT WE CAN FIND UNITY
I KNOW CENTER MCGUIRE AND I
HAVE THE TWO LARGE PROPOSALS
THAT ARE OFF OF OUR DISTRICTS
AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO MOVING
AHEAD AND WORKING OUT THAT
FIREMEN WISHES AND THE PLANNING
ISSUES AND AND TRYING TO DO
IT EXPEDITIOUSLY AND THAT IS
THE THEME THAT IS BEHIND THE
DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL AND
THE PREVIOUS ONE WHICH IS WE
ARE TRYING TO WORK THINGS OUT
SO WE CAN MOVE AHEAD AND
WHILE I MIGHT OF EXPRESSES IT IN
THE DISCUSSION OF THE PREVIOUS
BILL SOME PROBLEMS I MIGHT HAVE
PERSONALLY ON THIS ISSUE THAT
WERE REFLECTED BY SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION COMMENTS IT IS MORE
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW THAT WE TRY
TO MOVE AHEAD AND WORK THINGS
OUT AND AND THAT IS WHAT'S
GOING ON IN A VERY CONSTRUCTIVE
MANNER AND I THINK THAT IT MAY
BE BAFFLING TO SOME ADVOCATES
ARE SOME PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES
WHY WE WOULD MOVE OUT BOTH BILLS
BUT I THINK WE'RE MOVING IT
OUT IN THAT SPIRIT OF NOT BEING
WHERE WE WERE AT THE END OF THE
SESSION LAST YEAR BUT THE JUDGE
TRIED TO FIGURE OUT CONSTRUCTIVE
WAYS TO MOVE AHEAD BECAUSE THE
CLOCK IS TICKING IN A RATHER
HORRIFIC WAY ON CLIMATE AND WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO JUST GO TO OUR
CORNERS AND NOT TALK AND NOT
WORKING OUT AND NOT FIND A
COMMON GROUND I JUST WANT TO
KNOWLEDGE IN THE TESTIMONY OF
OF ONE OF THE KEY WITNESSES
SO IN THAT SPIRIT TO CONTINUE
ON WITH WHAT WE DID WITH THE
PREVIOUS BILL I WILL MOVE THIS
BILL SO THAT'S
A MOTION FROM CENTER LAYERED
AND -- COMING FROM CEREMONY
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU SENATOR
CONRAD I THINK WE'VE BEEN --
YOU KNOW VERY PUBLIC ABOUT HOW
MUCH WE'VE WORKED ON THIS ISSUE
AND YOU KNOW I KNOW THAT AT
THIS IS A ONE OF THOSE ISSUES
WERE YOU KNOW SOME STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE EXPRESSED A LOT OF CONCERN
-- AND YOU KNOW I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL IN THE
SPIRIT OF ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
AND THE FACT THAT WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE WE LAND -- AND
THAT IS NOT AND I WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR FOR THE RECORD IN
ANY WAY TO DISMISS -- OVERRIDE
OR NOT LISTEN TO THOSE
THAT HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERNS
I THINK THAT THOSE CONCERNS
-- THAT HAVE BEEN HEARD AND I
THINK THEY'RE SHARED BY MULTIPLE
FOLKS I MEAN INCLUDING YOURSELF
AND I I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT IN ORDER TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS A
CONVERSATION NEEDS TO CONTINUE
ON THIS TOPIC AND SO I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH YOU AND WITH YOU KNOW
REALLY SO MANY OTHER MEMBERS
WHO HAVE WEIGHED IN ON THIS
-- -- IN THIS CONVERSATION AND
WHO I KNOW WILL BE WEIGHING IN
-- ON WHATEVER ASPECTS OF THIS
CONVERSATION COMMA I SHARE YOUR
GOAL OF WANTING TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE WE GET UP BEFORE
WE RE FOR ANY OF THESE BILLS
POTENTIALLY REACH THE FOR
THANK YOU CEREMONY -- SEEING
NO OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS -- SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS IN OTHER
AB ONE IN THE ONE OF THE
AUDIENCE -- BUT
PRESHEAF THE HARD WORK
COMMITMENT FROM THE AUTHOR --
AND THAT AND REALLY THE HARD
WORK IT IS COMMITTEE I WANTED
THINK CATHERINE MORE PARTICULAR
WHO -- PUT IN OVERTIME --
TO TRY TO GET THIS RIGHT SO
-- I THINK WE'VE GOT A PRETTY
STRONG FRAMEWORK HERE WITH ONE
BIG OUTSTANDING ISSUE GOING
FORWARD -- THAT I KNOW WE'RE
ALL COMMITTED TO WORKING THROUGH
SO AND ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
I I I ALWAYS APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION THAT WE'VE
HAD AROUND THIS ISSUE -- IT
DEFINITELY IS NOT AT AN EASY
ISSUE TO GRAPPLE WITH AND I
WANT TO THANK MY MY COLLEAGUES
FOR ALL THE WORK ON THAT ON THE
CLIMATE -- THE SENATE CLIMATE
WORKING GROUP -- WE'VE
WE'VE WE'VE HAD MANY MANY
HOURS OF DISCUSSION IF I COULD
MISTER CHAIR THAT -- I JUST
WANNA MAKE A CLARIFICATION ON
AN AMENDMENT NUMBER TWO -- ARE
WHILE WE UNDERSTAND THE NEED
TO HAVE THE MINERAL RIGHTS --
ALSO ALIGN WITH THE POOR RIGHT
-- I THINK WHAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT WAS PIERCING BEING
ABLE TO PIERCE -- FROM ONE
ONE ONE I'M AT LEVEL
TO THE OTHER AND YOU DIDN'T
WANT TO HAVE THE MINERAL RIGHT
SEPARATED FROM THE PAR RATE
SO THAT THERE'S MORE WORK TO
BE DONE ON THAT THAT WAS --
DIRECTION THAT WE GOT FROM --
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WHICH
THIS BILL DOES NOT GO TO AND
I THINK WE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO WORK ON THAT CONTRACTUAL
OBLIGATIONS I JUST WANT TO KIND
OF POINT THAT OUT M. IT'S NOT AS
SIMPLE AS IT IS IS ARTICULATED
IN THIS PARTICULAR -- -- ONE
SENTENCE AND SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT THAT WE WERE GOING TO NEED
TO WORK ON IT IT IT'S IT'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE NUANCED SO WITH
THAT -- I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
YEP I'M SO SORRY I YOU KNOW
WE THIS IS THE PROBLEM WITH
OUR CRAZY SCHEDULING OVER
RUNNING BACK AND FORTH I JUST
HAD TO VOTE ON THE BILL BUT
-- I I I I MEAN TO VOTE FOR
THE BILL I WANT TO SEE MYSELF
WITH THE TEARS COMMENTS I I
CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL
THE WORK THEY'VE BEEN DOING
TO GET THIS INTO A GOOD PLACE
I'M AWARE OF THE FACT THIS IS
PART OF A BROADER NEGOTIATION
I'M CERTAINLY BY GOING TO
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WITH -- --
SOCI MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS
HAVE BEEN MADE BY THE CHAIR
ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE IN OUR
COMMITTEE TO AS THIS WHOLE
PROCESS MOVES FORWARD ABSOLUTELY
AND I APPRECIATE THAT WILL DO
OKAY SO WITH THAT
THE MOTION IS --
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND JUSTICE
FOR FOR THOSE OF YOU TRACKING
-- AND IT JUST CENTERS IT
SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
SETTING THE SECOND AMENDMENT
-- ONE TWO SHE'S ACCEPTING ONE
TWO FOUR FIVE SIX AND SEVEN IS
POTENTIALLY THREE IS OUTSTANDING
M. AS IN A MOMENT NOT BEING
ACCEPTED TODAY RIGHT AND THEN
SHE'S FLAG TO AN ISSUE THAT
SHE WAS TO WORK THROUGH ONE
ON I AM INTO BUT THAT'S BEING
ACCEPTED FOR FOR PURPOSES
OF OF TODAY SUCH A GREAT --
BUT YET THE THIRD THE THIRD
AMENDMENT IS WHAT'S STANDING
BETWEEN US AND AND -- THE
FLOOR -- AND SOME GREATER
RESOLUTION BUT I THINK WE'LL
GET THERE THANK YOU FOR THE
CLOSE -- SO THAT'S THE MOTION
ONE TWO FOUR FIVE SIX AND SEVEN
IT'S TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
HE CAN SOME PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FILE ITEM THREE S. B.
ELEVEN ZERO ONE THE MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
STERN STERN ALL RIGHT
JONES ALLEN ALLEN ALL RIGHT
EGGMAN HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
ALL RIGHT HUESO LAYERED
LAYERED ARE YOU LIMóN MON HI
OKAY THAT MEASURE HAS FIVE
VOTES WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
BACK WITH YOU FILE IN FOR YES
KEEP GOING FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX AND COMMITTEE TODAY FIRST
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY STATING I
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED
ON PAGE FOUR OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THIS BILL WILL ENHANCE
THE PENALTY OF AN OPERATOR OF
AN ILLEGAL CANNABIS GROW SITE
IF IF THEY FOUND -- TO HAVE
STOLEN WATER TEMPERED WITH
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE DOUG
AND AND PERMITTED WELL UP
TO BE PUNISHABLE I THERE IS
A MISDEMEANOR OR AS A FELONY
IN OTHER WORDS AS A WOBBLER
CALIFORNIA'S ARID CLIMATE MEANS
THAT EVERY YEAR REGARDLESS
OF THE YEARS RAIN OUTPUT OUR
WATER RESOURCES ARE STRETCHED
THIN EVEN DURING SEASONS OF
AVERAGE RAINFALL AND SNOW
CALIFORNIA WATER RESOURCES ARE
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND THERE IS
NOT ENOUGH WATER IN OUR SYSTEM
TO MEET ALL OF OUR THE NEEDS
OF ALL OF OUR RESIDENTS THIS
YEAR CALIFORNIA IS PROJECTED
TO BE HEADED TOWARDS A HISTORIC
ONE THOUSAND YEAR DROUGHT AS
ONE OF THE CONSISTENT LEAD
DRIVE A PROLONGED PERIODS IN
RECORDED HISTORY ACCORDING TO
MEASUREMENTS COLLECTED FROM
THIS YEAR ALONE CALIFORNIA'S
SNOWPACK IS THAT THIRTY NINE
PERCENT OF ITS AVERAGE LEVEL
WHICH IS TWENTY THREE PERCENT
LOWER THAN THIS TIME LAST YEAR
LET LOW SNOW PACK MEANS THAT
OUR WATER SUPPLY FROM SNOW
MELT WILL NOT MEET DEMANDS IN
THE SUMMER AND THE FALL THE
AGRICULTURAL ALLOCATION FROM THE
FEDERAL AND STATE WATER PROJECT
WILL BE TO ZERO THIS YEAR AS OF
MARCH THIRTY FIRST ALMOST ALL
OF THE STATE IS UNDER A SEVERE
DROUGHT CONDITIONS I SHARE
THIS DATA WITH YOU TODAY BECAUSE
IN LARGE PART THE MOTIVATION
BEHIND THE BILL THAT IS BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE ILLICIT CANNABIS
CULTIVATORS IN CALIFORNIA --
THREATENING BOTH BOTH ABOVE
AND BELOW GROUND WATER SUPPLIES
SUPPLIES THAT ARE LIFELINES
FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
URBAN CENTERS ALIKE ACCORDING
TO A RECENT CALMATTERS REPORT
EXAMPLES OF WATER THEFT BY
ILLICIT CANNABIS CANNABIS
GROWS IN THE STATE ARE PROLIFIC
STATEWIDE IN THE HIGH DESERT OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WATER THEFT
RESULTED IN WATER SHUT OFFS
TO OVER THREE HUNDRED HOMES IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY THE RUSSIAN
RIVER IS BECOMING DEPLETED
BECAUSE RIVERS AND STREAMS
THAT FEED INTO IT ARE BEING
DIVERTED THE BROOKINGS INSTITUTE
REPORTED RECENTLY THAT THIS
ACTIVITY HAS LED OVER TWENTY
FOUR STREAMS IN THE REGION GOING
DRY A DEVASTATING OUTCOME FOR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES LAST YEAR AND
SISKIYOU COUNTY ILLEGAL CANNABIS
CULTIVATORS STOLE AS MUCH AS
TWO MILLION GALLONS OF WATER
PER DAY ENOUGH WATER TO SUPPLY
UP TO THREE QUARTERS OF ITS
POPULATION IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
BROOKINGS INSTITUTE ESTIMATED
THAT UP UPWARDS OF NINE POINT
FIVE MILLION GALLONS OF WATER
WAS DIVERTED BY ILLEGAL CANNABIS
ACTIVITIES THAT'S DRINKING
WATER FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
WATER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HABITAT
THAT SUPPORT FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND WATER TO HELP COMBAT
FOREST FIRES CURRENT LAW DOES
NOT PROVIDE A DETERRENCE OR
RESOURCES TO TRACK AND STOP THE
ILLICIT ACTIVITIES OF A MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR CRIMINAL INDUSTRY
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO FIND ILLEGAL CANNABIS
OPERATIONS UP TO A THOUSAND
DOLLARS A DAY FIRST STEALING
WATER BUT FOR THIS LEVEL OF
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY FINE JUST
ISN'T ENOUGH IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
STATE OFFICIAL CHARGED OVER
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN FINES TO
OVER ONE THOUSAND WATER RIGHTS
VIOLATORS YET WE CONTINUE TO SEE
A GROWING PROBLEM FOR ALL THESE
REASONS I BELIEVE THAT PUNISHING
THIS ACTIVITY AS A CRIMINAL
OFFENSE IS NOT ONLY WARRANTED
BUT ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO
PROTECT OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
AND VOTE DURABLE COMMUNITIES
WERE DEPENDENT ON DWINDLING
WATER SUPPLIES AND DELIBERATE TO
SAY NOTHING OF THE FACT THAT WE
NEED TO STOP THE L. ECO ILLICIT
GROWS A CANNABIS IN ORDER FOR
OUR LEGAL INDUSTRY TO FLOURISH
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
FACILITATE QUESTIONS AS SARAH
DOCKET WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
SHE'S ON THE PHONE AND NICOLE
NICOLE WARDMAN LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH PRECISION ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THE SCENT OF
SAMBIT SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
AND SHE'S HERE IN PERSON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL GO
FIRST TO IN PERSON OR TO THE
LINE SENATOR WHAT DO YOU --
SIR YEAH COME ON UP MISTER K.
THIRTY CAD ON BEHALF OF THE
REAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX REDUCING
ILLICIT CANNABIS CULTIVATION
IS A PRIORITY FOR OUR SECURITY
MEMBER COUNTIES AS REAL COUNTIES
ARE FREQUENTLY THE TARGETS OF
LARGE SCALE ILLEGAL CANNABIS
GROWS MANY COUNTIES PLAY WITH
ILLICIT CANNABIS CULTIVATION ARE
ALSO IN THE MIDST OF A DROUGHT
EMERGENCY REINFORCING THE NEED
TO PROTECT THIS FINITE RESOURCE
FOR EXAMPLE MENDOCINO COUNTY
ONE OF FIRST COUNTIES TO DECLARE
DROUGHT LAST YEAR CONTINUALLY
DEALS WITH WATER THEFT A
RECENT EXAMPLES REDWOOD VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT WHICH IS IN A
MORATORIUM AND HAS A DECLARED
EMERGENCY WATER SHORTAGE HAS
BEEN HARD HIT HARD WITH SEVERAL
ILLEGAL STAFFS RELATED TO
CANNABIS SIMILAR STORIES FROM
WATER DISTRICTS IRRIGATION
DISTRICTS MUNICIPALITIES AND
PRIVATE RESIDENTS ARE A REGULAR
OCCURRENCE FROM THE NORTH
COAST THIS YEAR AND ABOUT IT
DOWN TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CURRENT PENALTIES ARE NOT
STRONG ENOUGH TO DETER CRIMINALS
FROM ENGAGING IN WIDESPREAD
ILLEGAL CANNABIS FARMING DO
NOT RECOGNIZE THE DANGER OF
ILLEGAL GROWS SUPPOSED TO WATER
SUPPLYING GROUND WATER POLLUTION
THE PRESENCE OF THIS ACTIVITY
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY MAKES
PERMITTING CANNABIS PROJECTS
MORE CONTROVERSIAL TO THE PUBLIC
AND FURTHER HINDERS THE LEGAL
INDUSTRY ADDITIONAL TOOLS ARE
NEEDED TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC'S
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND FURTHER
DISCOURAGE ILLICIT CANNABIS
OPERATORS WHILE STRENGTHENING
THE MARKET FOR THOSE WHO OPERATE
LEGALLY FOR THESE REASON RC
RC URGES YOU'RE EITHER TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- NEXT I THINK WE'LL
TURN TO THE TO THE LINE FOR
THIS NEXT LEAVES FOR WOMEN'S
GOOD MORNING STERN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NICOLE WATERMAN ON
BEHALF OF SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SPONSOR OF SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX ILLEGAL CANNABIS FARMS --
VARIOUS GROWING THREAT ACROSS
RURAL AREAS OF CALIFORNIA
ILLICIT CANNABIS CULTIVATORS
FREQUENTLY ENGAGE AND WATER
FAST AND ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION
AS PART OF THEIR OPERATIONS
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
THAT THE POLITICAL STATION
OPERATIONS HAVE RUN RAMPANT IN
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY SEPARATE
HAS SOME CORPORATION FIGHTS
GO UNDETECTED FOR YEARS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE COULD LAST
GENERATIONS CALIFORNIA STATE
LAW PENALTIES ARE NOT CURRENTLY
STRONG ENOUGH TO DETER CRIMINALS
FROM ENGAGING IN WIDESPREAD
ILLEGAL CANNABIS FARMING WE'RE
ASKING THE COMMITTEE TO DATE
COULD PLEASE PASS SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX TO ASSIST RURAL AREAS
ACROSS THE STATE IN COMBATING
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE DONE
BY ILLICIT CULTIVATION THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- WILL TURN OUT TO GENERAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANY IN
THE HEARING ROOM SEEING TO
GOOD MORNING WELCOME GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS --
OUTSIDE OF COURT THIS CAPELLO
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
MR CHEN MEMBERS THAT RAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTED THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTIST IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK
YOU I'VE SEEN ORDERS IN THE
HEARING ROOM COULD TURN TO
THE LINES -- MODERATOR FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE ONE TWENTY NINE
WELL AT GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN CENTERS WHERE
THEY ACROSS -- ELLIOT CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER COALITION SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
ONE ONE TWENTY EIGHT
GOOD MORNING DELFINO
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT LINE ONE FORTY
GOOD MORNING KAREN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ANDREA AVERAGE
ALL WITH CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES PRESERVATION AND
RESEARCH OR AT THE FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
LINE ONE TENTH
TWENTY MISTER MEMBERS DR
MILAN CAMPBELL HALL OF THE
ENVIRONMENT MINISTRY DIS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
LINE FORTY FOUR
GOOD MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS
ON TURNER WITH NEW ENGLAND
BAPTIST IN IT THAT IT ON
BEHALF OF EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT IN THE PORT
OF SB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS IS YOUR WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. OKAY
WILL MOVE NOW TO ANYONE
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ANY LEAD SUPPORT -- INSERTED
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES HERE
LIST IN THE ANALYSIS BUT ANYONE
WISHING TESTIFYING OPPOSITION
INCOME FORD IN THE HEARING ROOM
NOW SEEING NONE WILL TURN TO
THE LINES MODERATE YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP THE LINE FOR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
KNOWING QUEUING UP OKAY
GOOD WILL BRING BACK TO THE
MEMBERS -- QUESTIONS SENATORS
SENATOR ALAN SENATOR LAYERED
DIFFERENCE AMAZING
THANK YOU -- THE THE
-- I THINK THE CENTRAL ISSUE
FOR ME IS IS THAT THE PURPOSE
OF THIS BILL IS AN INCREDIBLY
LAUDABLE IT PARTICULARLY
HE WON I WAS IN MY PRIOR
POSITION OUR ILLEGAL
CANNABIS GROWS DIVERTED OUR
WATER USE PESTICIDES THAT
WERE REALLY DIFFICULT TO BAN
FREQUENTLY THERE WERE GUNS
INVOLVED THROUGH ALL THESE
THINGS THAT WERE NOT GOOD AND
I THINK THIS BILL RECOGNIZES
THAT TRIES TO GET IT THAT
HOWEVER IT REFERS TO THE THEFT
OF GROUNDWATER I DON'T THINK THE
THEFT OF GROUNDWATER SOMETHING
THAT EXISTS IN THE CODE IT'S
SO THE THE QUESTION IS IS HOW
COULD WE TAKE THE GOALS THAT IS
SET OUT HERE AND BETTER ALIGN
IT TO THE ACTION THAT IS IN THE
BILL IN HAND BECAUSE I
WHOLLY AGREE WITH WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO HERE AND
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A THING
ABOUT MOVING TO A NEW LEGAL
MARK DRILLING OF WELLS OR
SOMETHING THAT IS MORE ALIGNED
WITH WHAT THE REALITY OF THE
LAW FOR THE SITUATION IS ON THE
GROUND AND AND SO IF IF THE
AUTHOR IS IS WILLING TO WORK ON
THOSE ISSUES AND TRY TO ALIGN
THE BILL BETTER TO WHAT THE
PRACTICALITIES AND THE CODE ON
ONE TO GIVE HER THE CHANCE TO
WORK ON IT BUT IT -- THAT WAS
JUST MY CONCERN I LOVE THE WHOLE
NOTION OF THEFT OF GROUNDWATER
BUT I THINK WE WILL BE THROWING
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN JAIL
YOU'RE A GENERAL AND AND THERE
MIGHT EVEN BE SOME IN YOUR
DISTRICT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT I REALLY LIKE THE THAT
STAFF TO GROW BUT -- THERE IS
A SUGGESTED AMENDMENT WHICH
I WILL TAKE WITH IT WHICH
-- RESTATED AS AN AUTHORIZED
TAPPING INTO WATER CONVEYANCE
OR STORAGE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
IF THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE
DONE ON IT MORE HAPPY TO DO
IT I JUST LIKE THE IDEA THAT
THE WORD THEFT AND SO
WELL AND IN THE
ARMY JUST EXPLORE THAT FOR
SECOND WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
IF YOU IF YOU SWITCH TO THAT
AMENDMENT WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
WHAT ON THE GROUND WHAT HAPPENED
FOR WHAT WOULD YOU HAVE DONE
A FIRE HOW WOULD SOMEBODY BE
PENALIZED FOR DOING WHAT BOTH
OF US DON'T WANT THEM TO DO
RIGHT WELL I THE THE GROSSES
AS I UNDERSTAND -- BASICALLY
JUST -- DIVERT WATER FROM FROM
RIVERS AND STREAMS -- AND THEY
TAP INTO SOMEONE ELSE'S SYSTEM
IN IT AND -- AND THEY DO THAT
BY PUTTING IN HOSES AND DRIP
AND WHATEVER THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO CONVEY
THE WATER OVER TO TO WHERE
THEY'RE GROWING AND SO THAT'S
WHY THEY'RE ACTUALLY TWO ONE IS
DIGGING ARE EXTRACTING GROUND
WATER FROM IT AND PERMITTED
WHILE I'M IN THE OTHER ONE
WHICH IS AN AUTHORIZED TAPPING
INTO OUR WATER CONVEYANCE OR
STORAGE INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH
WHICH IS AN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
ALREADY EXISTS BUT IT'S NOT
THERE FOR THEM -- NOW IF THERE'S
MORE WORD SMITHING WE NEED TO
DO WE SHOULD DO IT BUT I LIKED
THE THEFT AND SO -- AND I WAS
RIGHTLY CORRECTED THAT THAT'S
PROBABLY NOT THE MOST PRO ONCE
AGAIN RIGHT NOT SUPPOSED TO
FALL IN LOVE WITH YOUR BILL
YEAH I KNOW THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT I LIKE TO COOK BUT IT'S
AN INDIVIDUAL IMAGE RIGHT --
BORING TO SAY YOU KNOW TAPPING
AND MARK WELL THE THING ABOUT
IT IS IS I STILL WONDER
HOW SOME OF THIS WORKS BUT
HAVING SAID THAT IT'S LIKE I'M
GLAD THAT YOU RECOGNIZED IT
OR TAKING THE AMENDMENT I WILL
HAPPILY MAKE THE MOTION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND AND VOTE
TO MOVE THE BILL ALONG AND IF
THERE ARE ANY CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
THAT WORKS I'M SURE THEY'LL GET
REPRESENTED IN THE PROCESS OKAY
THANK YOU SAID EARLIER TEHRAN
WELL I MEAN I'M I KNOW YOU'RE
NOT FALLING IN LOVE WITH THE
BILL -- YOU B. I AM WELL I KNOW
YOU HAVEN'T FALLEN IN LOVE WITH
OF I AM FALLING IN LOVE WITH THE
BILL I I THINK YOU'RE ADDRESSING
AN ISSUE THAT IS ENORMOUSLY
IMPORTANT I I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
A FEW THINGS YOU HAVE TO WORK
OUT AYE AYE AYE THIS IS AN ISSUE
I'VE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT FOR
QUITE SOME TIME I'M GLAD YOU
STEPPED UP TO TAKE -- TAKE
TO TO PLAY A ROLE HERE SO I
WITH YOUR PERMISSION I'D LOVE
TO COST THE BILL -- BECAUSE I
TRUST YOU ON THIS AND I TRUST
YOUR YOU THAT YOU KNOW I I'VE
DONE SO MUCH WORK WITH YOU KNOW
NO YOU'RE GONNA YOU'RE GONNA
-- BIRD DOG THIS AND AND AND
AND GET THESE ISSUES ADDRESSED
BUT BY THE END OF THE DAY
YOU'RE TRYING TO YOU'RE TRYING
TO DRAW SOMETHING IT'S REALLY
BECOME AN ENORMOUS PROBLEM I
THINK I'M A PRETTY CALM FOR FOR
LEGIT FARMERS HAS BECOME A BIG
PROBLEM FOR OUR WATER AGENCIES
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND FOR
A LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ESPECIALLY
GIVEN SOME OF THE WILD
WEST NATURE OF OF SOME OF THE
ILLEGAL GROWS THAT ARE OUT THERE
-- IT'S BECOME A PROBLEM FOR
STATE PARK SYSTEM IN A RANGERS
-- AND SO I'D LIKE TO COPE
WITH THE COST OF THE BILL IN
CONSERVING THE TO MOVE IT IF IF
AND WHEN APPROPRIATE ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU M. AND I'LL JUST
SAY JUST TO FURTHER CLARIFY
THAT THE AMENDMENT REALLY
HINGES ON THE THE WELLS
OR OR DIVERSIONS THAT ARE UN
PERMITTED SO THE IDEA HOPEFULLY
IS THAT WE'RE USING THEIR
RIGORS IN OUR IN OUR GROUNDWATER
REGULATION FRAMEWORK TO GET LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED AND SOME BASIS THAT THEY'RE
GONNA NEED TO TO GO AFTER THESE
GROWS WE KNOW THAT THEIR ALSO
CARTELS OPERATING OUT THERE
AND THAT THE FEDS ARE INVOLVED
WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS ISSUES ON
FAMILY FARM -- WITH
NOT JUST DIVERSION OF WATER BUT
ALL SO -- YOU KNOW THE RAMPANT
USE OF ILLEGAL PESTICIDES --
HAD LOST PET -- TO SOME
ILLEGAL PESTICIDES -- AND
YOU KNOW SEEN THIS THIS SORT
OF RAMPANT ABUSE HAPPENING ALL
OVER THE PLACE SO I'LL I'LL JOIN
ON WITH SENATOR ALAN SIGN ON TO
YOUR BILL HERE AND AND WISH YOU
WELL ON IT AND -- I KNOW YOU
YOU ACCEPTED BOTH THE AMENDMENTS
AND WE HAVE A PROMOTION FROM
CENTER LAYERED BUT I WOULD ALLOW
YOU TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE
YOUR OFFER TO CO AUTHOR AND I'M
HONORED TO HAVE THAT -- THIS
THERE'S JUST NO QUESTION THAT
THIS IS A REALLY SERIOUS ISSUE
AND IT'S NOT JUST THE THEFT OF
WATER IT IS THESE -- ILLEGAL
PESTICIDES AND RODENTICIDES
ARE ON THERE IF THEY'RE NOT
ILLEGAL THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
AUTHORIZED AND SO -- IT IS
HAVING A TERRIBLE IMPACT ON
ON OUR ENVIRONMENT AND SO WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THE MOTION IS
DUE TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHIEF CONSULTANTS CALL THE
ROLL FILE ITEM FOR SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS STERN HI STERN
I'D JONES ALLEN HI ALLEN
ALL RIGHT EGGMAN HERTZBERG HUESO
LAYERED LAYERED I LIVE ALONE
OKAY WE'LL LEAVE THE MEASURE
BECAUSE THREE VOTES THANK YOU
SO MUCH YOU'RE VERY MUCH OKAY
-- TO ANOTHER AUTHOR
YOU DO YOURS YES THEY
WANT AMERICA'S WHICH OVER
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE
RIGHT THE SECOND WITNESS
SOME OF OURS OKAY SO
I WILL BE HERE I
WILL PRESENT MY BILL
OR OKAY SO WHO WHO CAN I HAND
THIS GAVEL TO MOMENTARILY
WELL I PERCENT ANOTHER HUNTER
ALLEN -- CENTER ALLEN GETS
THAT GETS THE THE GAVEL HERE
FOR A MOMENT I'M I'M HAVING
THOMAS FROM LAST WEEK --
ALL RIGHT OKAY SO --
SENATOR YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
PRESENTING YOUR BILL -- TWELVE
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU AND --
LET ME -- PLEASE WITH
INTO HASTE WITH ALL
DELIBERATE SPEED SO NO
NO NO THAT'S THIS YEAR
ALTHOUGH ONE SECOND I'M JUST
GET MY STUFF IN FRONT OF ME
HERE MOST WANTED OAKS FIRST
LIKE YOU DID LAST TIME SO --
WE'LL WE'LL DIVE RIGHT INTO
SB TWELVE SIXTY ONE OF THAT'S
ALL RIGHT AND BEFORE I BEGIN
I WANT TO ACCEPT THE EXCELLENT
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LISTED
ON PAGE SIX OF THE ANALYSIS
YES I'M COMPLIMENTING MY OWN
COMMITTEE AND I WILL SAY
THAT THE THE THE ANNOUNCEMENT
OF THAT OF NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS RELATED TO BUILDINGS
-- WILL BE IMPORTANT SO I THINK
THAT'S IT THAT'S IT STRENGTHENS
THE BILL AND AND FURTHER EXPANDS
THE APERTURE TECHNOLOGIES AND
AND SOLUTIONS THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO DEAL WITH THE EXTREME
HEAT AS WE'VE LEARNED ALL TOO
QUICKLY THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND EMERGE THIS EMERGENCY
-- HAPPENING RIGHT BEFORE OUR
EYES BUT TO IN MY VIEW AND
IN THE STATE IS PREPARING THIS
OUT MORE AND MORE THE MORE WE
LEARN -- HE IS THE GREAT KILLER
I WE'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
WILDFIRES FLOODS SEA LEVEL RISE
BUT THE SILENT KILLER OR THOSE
HOT DAYS AND THOSE HOT NIGHTS
THAT DON'T ALLOW PEOPLE TO
RECOVER FROM THESE EXTREME HEAT
EVENTS CREATE UNSAFE CONDITIONS
FOR THE ELDERLY FOR INFANTS
FOR CHILDREN FOR EXPECTANT
MOTHERS AND WITH HEAT ON THE
RISE ACCORDING THE GOVERNOR'S
TRAFFIC STREAM HEAT REPORT
WE'RE GONNA SEE DAILY AVERAGE
MAXIMUM TEMPERATURES -- ANYWHERE
FROM FOUR TO SIX DEGREES --
OVER THE COMING DECADES AS AN
INCREASE FOR SOMEONE WHO'S HAD
THE HOTTEST DAY EVER RECORDED
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY FOR
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION
WITH A HUNDRED TWENTY DEGREES --
CANOGA PARK IN WOODLAND HILLS --
I KNOW ALL TOO WELL THE DANGERS
HERE WE KNOW WE'RE ATTACKING
THIS ISSUE WITH URBAN FORESTRY
SOLUTIONS WITH RESILIENCE
HUBS -- BUT
THE THE THE PREMISES BILLS THAT
WE REALLY ALSO NEED TO LOOK
AT OUR BUILDING STOCK AND OUR
HOUSING IN PARTICULAR AND HOW
TO KEEP PEOPLE NOT JUST IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY HAVE TO GO
TO COOLING CENTERS ON A VERY HOT
DAY OR HAVE TO LEAVE THEIR HOME
BUT HOW THEY CAN BE SHELTERING
IN PLACE I'M IN THE SAFETY
OF A COOL AND HABITABLE HOME
-- LAST YEAR'S STATE BUDGET AND
THE GOVERNOR PUT FORWARD
A SERIES OF PROPOSALS AND THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET DOES THE SAME --
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT EVERYTHING
FROM DIRECT INSTALL PROGRAMS
TO LOW IN FOR LOW INCOME
BUILDINGS AND RETROFITS LOOKING
AT ELECTRIC ELECTRIFICATION
INSULATION ENERGY EFFICIENCY
AS WELL AS CONSUMER REBATES
FOR UPGRADES TO OLD CLUNKY
FURNACES AND AIR CONDITIONERS
THAT CAN BE REPLACED WITH NEW
OFFICIAL AFTER KEEP PUMPS --
AND ACCELERATING THE ADOPTION
OF PHASING OUT CERTAIN ULTRALOW
-- THAT HIGH HIGH GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL REFRIGERANTS WITH
NEW LOW GLOBAL WARMING FRAZIER
IN TECHNOLOGY -- SO THIS BILL
REALLY LOOKS IT PROVED PUTTING
FORWARD AN APPLICATION TO LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS WERE THE MOST
EXTREME EXTREMELY VULNERABLE
-- THE GRANT PROGRAM -- THE
MAXIMIZE THE REACH THE REACH
OF EASY EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
THEN -- PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT TO
REALLY MEET PEOPLE WHERE THEY
ARE AND GET TESTIMONY FROM THE
COMMUNITY I THINK MOST PEOPLE
OUT THERE MAY NOT REALIZE THAT
IF THEY HAVE THAT SWAMP COOLER
THAT BUSTED AIR CONDITIONER --
OR THAT -- INSULATION THAT'S
NOT WORKING THAT THEY ACTUALLY
ARE NOW GOING TO HAVE SOME
KIND OF RECOURSE FOR THEMSELVES
-- TO MAKE THEIR LIVES MORE
HABITABLE AND TO TO DEAL
WITH THE EXTREME HEAT THAT'S
GOING TO BE -- CONTINUING
TO BE A FATAL INFLUENCE ON
CALIFORNIA FOR YEARS TO COME
AND WITH ME TODAY TESTIFYING
REMOTELY IS MERION BOARDS AND
WITH AN RTC YOU MAY PROCEED
GREAT GOOD MORNING BURNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- I THINK
VERY IMPORTANT AND I'M A
SENIOR SCIENTIST AT THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL I
KNOW THAT MANY OF THE OTHERS
COMMITTEE ARE LIKE SENATORS
VERY DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF INCREASINGLY
EXTREME HEAT ON OUR COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA AND OR TO MAKE
A FINAL OPTIONS INCLUDING FOR
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS THE
BURDEN OF EXTREME HEAT --
AND I KNOW THAT YOU ALSO KNOW
THAT WE NEED TO GO TO CONTINUE
TO FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE AND
TO PREPARE FOR THE IMPACT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WE'RE ALREADY
EXPERIENCING I WOULD ARGUE
THIS BILL WILL BE BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS -- AS WELL AS ADDRESS
INCOMING HOUSING DISPARITY FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING EXTREME HEAT
THE TOTAL PROPOSED A PROGRAM
THAT COMBINES MEASURES THAT
WOULD REDUCE H. EMISSIONS SUCH
A THROUGH ENERGY EFFICIENCY
WHETHER THEY SEND ALONG WITH
-- PROVIDING EFFICIENT COOLING
AND OTHER MEASURES TO IMPROVE
THE COMFORT OF HOME ENERGY THE
-- LOOKS FORWARD TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE CENTERS AROUND
THE FELLOW -- AND TO ENSURE
THIS PROGRAM COMPLEMENT THE
OTHER THING STATE PROGRAMS SO
I ENCOURAGE AYE VOTE ON THE
BILL TODAY AND APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON SENATOR STERN --
PARTLY IN THE SCORING THANK YOU
OKAY OUR FOLKS
WHO ONE OF TESTIFIED FOR THE
BILL ON THE PHONE LINES ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR
ONCE OF ONE OF TESTAMENT'S
AFFORDED SB TWELVE SIXTY ONE
WE CAN SUPPORT BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCHTONE PHONE AT THIS TIME
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE ONE TEN
MEMBERS THIS IS JUST MOLANA
BEHALF OF THE U. S. GREEN
BUILDING COUNCIL IN LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED BY YOUR COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THANK YOU THANK YOU --
I SHOULDN'T SAY THANK YOU AND
WE'RE GONNA PASSED THE GAVEL
UNFORTUNATELY SUCH AS THE CALLED
FOR ME TO GO OVER THE US ON A
PATH TO DOUBLE OVER TO OUR --
ARE TEMPORARY CHAIR EMERITUS
OF THE LAST ARE THERE ARE CHAIR
DESIGNATE EMERITUS JOHN MILLER
BUT I WILL BUT I WILL GO DOWN
TO LINE ONE TWENTY ALL MOVES
THE ITEM WHEN APPROPRIATE
THANK YOU MODERATOR NEXT
BEAKER LINE ONE TWENTY
RIGHT WHAT WHAT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
-- NO OTHER LINES IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU OUR MODERATOR WILL BE
BACK TO YOU IN A MOMENT -- THIS
WOULD BE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANYBODY TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL -- AND
-- SENATE BILL TWELVE SIXTY ONE
WILL GO FIRST TO PEOPLE IN THE
HEARING ROOM SIR HI AND ON AND
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A LIST
OF -- A SPEAKER SO JUST YOUR
NAME AND YOUR I'M SANTIAGO
RODRIGUEZ WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT
I'M DID
I MISS THE SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
OKAY WHAT WILL TAKE THAT
AS SUPPORT -- -- BUT
WILL CONTINUE TO ASK IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
I'M NOT HEARING TO SEEING
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM MODERATOR
WILL GO TO YOU A IF YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP TO ANYBODY FOR A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL TWELVE SIXTY ONE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY
LINE ONE TWENTY HAS TAKEN
THEMSELVES OUT OF YOU AGAIN WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE TO DO IT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MODERATOR OR
WILL BRING IT BACK TO ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND UP
I WOULD RECOGNIZE MYSELF I THINK
THIS IS A GREAT BILL PRECIADO
EVERYBODY THAT TESTIFIED THAT
WOULD MOVE THE BILL WE HAVE A
MOTION ARE THERE ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS ON ON THIS BILL
SEEING NON I WILL ALLOW THE
AUTHOR TO CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR FOR
THE RIGOROUS CONVERSATION AND
DESPITE THE LACK OF DEBATE
-- THIS IS GOING TO BE A HUGE
ISSUE FOR YEARS TO COME SO
APPRECIATE ALL THE SUPPORT
AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
-- CONSULTANT IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE READ THE MOTION AND CALL
THE ROLL FILE ITEM ELEVEN S.
B. TWELVE SIXTY ONE THE MOTIONS
DO PASSES AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
STERN STERN ALRIGHT JONES
ALAN EGGMAN HERTZBERG
HUESO LEARNED HI THERE ALL RIGHT
LET ALONE THAT BILL HAS TWO
VOTES WILL PUT IT ON CALL AND
-- NOW BEFORE ANYONE COMES
BACK I DON'T HAVE ANY
BILLS -- -- -- -- I COULD MAKE
SOME UP BUT IT BUT IT'S LIKE
-- WE WILL MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE WHICH IS A SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN OH FOUR BY SENATOR
STERN AND LET ME JUST SAY ARM
TO SENATORS DAUGHTER CORTESE
YOUR THE TWO AUTHORS THAT
ARE LEFT WHEN WE'RE DONE WITH
THIS BILL WILL WANT TO MOVE
TO YOU AND -- AND I'M SURE
THE CHAIR WILL EXHORT ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO SHOW UP
FOR THE CALLS OF PROVIDING WE
CAN ACTUALLY GET THROUGH THESE
NEXT THREE BILLS ARE RECOGNIZED
OF THE CHAIR FOR TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN OH FOUR
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BEFORE BEGIN PRESENTATION I WANT
TO JUST INFORM THE COMMITTEE
THAT LAST WEEK WE ACCEPTED
AMENDMENT AN ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE I DO TO TIMING
ISSUES WE HAVE TO ADOPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS HERE AND SENATE
NATURAL RESOURCES SO IN ADDITION
TO THE AMENDMENT THAT
I'M ACCEPT BEING ON PAGE SEVENTY
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES WILL ALSO BE
ADOPTING THE E. Q. AMENDMENTS --
AND I ALSO WANT TO STATE AT
THE OUTSET -- THE STAKEHOLDERS
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
SPECIFICALLY THOSE -- IN
OPPOSITION WHO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BREADTH OF IN SCOPE
OF THE BILL -- SHOULD NOT
CONSIDER THESE AMENDMENTS TO
BE OUR OUR FINAL -- EFFORT AT
TAILORING THIS LEGISLATION I'M
IN FACT WE'VE BEEN HAVING MORE
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS AS OF
LATE AND THE COMMITTEE ITSELF
HAS BEEN DOING SOME DEEPER
RESEARCH WITH SOME OF YOUR --
WITH SOME OF YOUR INPUT ABOUT
WAYS TO TO LOOK AT AREAS
THAT WOULD BE INCLUDED -- RIGHT
NOW IT DID THE LANGUAGES THAT
THE BILL WOULD ONLY APPLY IN
AREAS MAP BY STATE OR LOCAL
AGENCIES AS AREAS CRITICAL TO
HABITAT LINKAGE AND NATURAL
RESOURCE PROTECTION OR OTHERWISE
RELATED ABOUT DIVERSITY AND
CONSERVATION BUT I DO WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THAT THAT
LANGUAGE MAY BE OVERLY BROAD SO
WE WANT TO GET VERY SPECIFIC --
HERE IN TERMS OF EXACTLY WHAT
KIND OF MAPS WERE TALKING ABOUT
THERE SO THAT -- SHOULD THIS
BILL MOVE FORWARD THAT PEOPLE
WILL KNOW EXACTLY WHAT AREAS
MAY BE IN OR OUT -- AND WHAT
THE PROCESS WOULD BE -- BUT
I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION ACRES OF OAK
WOODLANDS IN ABOUT FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION ACRES OF OAK FOREST
COMPRISING ABOUT ONE EIGHTH OF
THE STATE -- THAT'S BLUE OAK
VALLEY OAK OREGON WHITE OAK
COASTAL LIVE OAK ANGLE MEADOW
OAK INTERIOR LIVE OAK AND SO ON
-- THESE OAK WOODLANDS PROVIDE
HABITAT FOR AT LEAST THREE
HUNDRED THIRTEEN SPECIES OF
BIRDS MORE TWO MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND PLANT SPECIES AN
ESTIMATED FIVE THOUSAND INSECT
SPECIES AND THERE ARE ALSO A
HUNDRED THIRTY KNOWN SENSITIVE
PLANT SPECIES THAT OCCUR IN OAK
WOODLANDS OAK WOODLANDS ALSO
PROVIDE CARBON SEQUESTRATION
BENEFITS IMPROVE WATER QUALITY
-- AND FROM A FIRE PERSPECTIVES
-- ARE INCREASINGLY VIEWED AS A
CRITICAL NATURE BASED SOLUTION
TO PROVIDING -- FIRE BUFFERS
FOR NEARBY COMMUNITIES NOW
AMONG THOSE THOUSANDS OF ACRES
THERE'S CERTAIN ACRES THAT
MATTER MORE THAN OTHERS AND
THE PROBLEM WITH CURRENT LAWS
THAT THE COUNTY IS RESPONSIBLE
AND STATES AND CITIES AND
MUNICIPALITIES RESPONSIBLE FOR
JURISDICTION OVER CONVERSION
OF AN OAK WOODLAND OR THE THE
DESTRUCTION OF -- OAK WOODLAND
OFTEN RESULT IN ADOPTING A
ONE TO ONE OAK TREE MITIGATION
POLICY THAT DOES NOT ADEQUATELY
ACCOUNT FOR THEIR VALUE WHETHER
YOU'RE REPLACING A HUNDRED YEAR
OAK WITH A A SAPLING OR WHETHER
YOU'RE FAILING TO RECOGNIZE
THAT CERTAIN STANDS OF OAK
WOODLANDS -- WHILE THEY MAY
BE ON PRIVATE PROPERTY OR IN
A SORT OF MORE URBAN FACING
-- AREA IF THEY'RE CONNECTED
TO THAT WILD LAND THEY ARE
STILL PART OF THAT HABITAT AND
THEREFORE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
EFFECT ON THE ENVIRONMENT SO
THAT'S THE THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL IS TO GET TO ALL THOSE OAK
WOODLANDS -- THAT ARE CURRENTLY
NOT BEING ADEQUATELY MITIGATED
FOR AND HOPEFULLY FIND SOME WAY
TO MEET THE GOALS OF OF OUR
HOUSING AND INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILD OUT -- WITHOUT DECIMATING
OUR ECOSYSTEMS I THINK
WE CAN DO BOTH ESPECIALLY
WITH THE INCREASED FOCUS ON
INFILL AND URBAN GREENING AND
AND AND -- URBAN DEVELOPMENT
I THINK THAT WE CAN WE CAN
FIND A WAY TO TO NOT DESTROY
THAT URBAN WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE BUT STILL -- BUT
STILL MEET OUR HOUSING AND OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE GOALS LEAD AGENCY
WE STILL ALSO HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO AVOID IMPACTS UNDER SEEK WHAT
NONE OF THOSE MITIGATION ISSUES
CEASE AND THIS WOULDN'T BE AN
ALL OUT BAR AND ANY OF THAT
DEVELOPMENT IT JUST REQUIRES
MORE RIGOROUS MITIGATION IN
CERTAIN SENSITIVE AREAS -- SO
WE ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE TESTIMONY FROM LEAD SUPPORT
AS WELL AS THE OPPOSITION
HERE BUT I'M HAPPY TO GET
INTO A LITTLE MORE DETAIL
TO FLESH OUT OUR THINKING
-- AS THE DEBATE GOES ON
THANK YOU IN A
MICHAEL I KEEP WANTING TO
CALL YOU MISTER CHAIR UP
DO YOU HAVE LEAD -- WITNESSES
I DON'T HAVE WEST DID YOU
YEAH -- I BELIEVE ON THE LINE
WE HAVE -- DAN SILVER FROM
ENDANGERED HABITATS LEAGUE
THE INJURED HABITATS LEAGUE WE
MAY ALSO HAVE -- JIMMY
HALL ON HAND AS A TECHNICAL
EXPERT AS WELL AS THOSE CHAU
THERE'S NICK JENSEN OKAY AND
NICK JENSEN'S ON ARTS WE'VE
TO SUPPORT WITNESSES MISTER
SILVER MISTER JENSEN THEN LET'S
GO TO MR SILVER ARE YOU THERE
GOOD MORNING OUR CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AM DAMN SILVER REPRESENTING
A DANGER HABITATS LEAGUE IN
SUPPORT OAKS ARE A KEYSTONE
SPECIES MEANING THAT MANY
OTHER SPECIES DEPEND ON THEM
YES THEY ARE STILL BEING LOST
SB FOURTEEN OH FOUR WOULD SET
A THRESHOLD PRITCHETT CRISTINA
BEGIN IMPACT AND ENSURE THE
MITIGATION OCCURS WITH THE
FLEXIBLE ARRAY OF OPTIONS
THREE MATURE OAKS THAT ARE
PART OF A WOODLAND IS INDEED
SIGNIFICANT ABSENT A RELATIVELY
LOW THRESHOLD THERE IS NO
INCENTIVE NO INCENTIVE TO
REDESIGN A PROJECT TO AVOID
OUT AND THE OAKS ARE
IMPARTIAL OAKS ARE UNAVOIDABLE
LITIGATION AT A REASONABLE COST
IS A GOOD THING NOT A BAD THING
IF THERE'S NO MITIGATION FOR THE
NATURAL WORLD THE NATURAL WORLD
WORLD BECOMES WHAT ECONOMISTS
CALL AN EXTERNALITY MEETING
SOMETHING WHICH IS NOT VALUE
VALUED ECONOMICALLY AND THAT'S
THE CASE WE WILL HAVE DEATH
BY A THOUSAND CUTS THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THE VALUE APPROACH
AND PROVIDES AN ESSENTIAL
BASIS FOR THEIR CONSERVATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE ALSO HAVE --
LISTED NICK JENSEN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
ARE YOU ON THE LINE AS WELL
YES GOOD MORNING GREAT
WELCOME TO THE GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS NICK DENTON AND I
AM THE CONSERVATION PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PLANT SOCIETY OR SEEN YEAH
CAN'T GET TO THE STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WITH
MORE THAN ELEVEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND THIRTY FIVE CHAPTERS
ACROSS THE STATE DEDICATED
TO THE STUDY APPRECIATION
CONSERVATION OF OUR STATE LARA
IN LINE WITH OUR MISSION WE
ARE PLEASED THE WHOLE WHOLE
HEARTEDLY SUPPORT AND THEY'RE
STARING AT EACH PORTANTINO FOR
WITHOUT HYPERBOLE OUR NAY ABOUT
ARE AMONG CALIFORNIA'S MOST
IMPORTANT PLANT LIKE TO THINK
OF OAK THAT'S NATURE SUPERMARKET
IN THAT A SINGLE OAK TREE CAN
PROVIDE HABITAT AND FOOD FOR
HUNDREDS OF ANIMAL SPECIES
INCLUDING BIRDS AND COUNTLESS
INTACT ADDITIONALLY OCHRE
CLIMATE CHANGE CHAMPIONS THEIR
LONG LIVES AND THEY'RE DOWN
WOOD STORES MORE CARBON THAN
MOST OTHER TREAT UNFORTUNATELY
MANY OF OUR ICONIC OAK SPECIES
ARE AT RISK OUR LARGEST OAK
VALLEY OUT HADLOCK FOR THE
NINETY PERCENT OF ITS ORIGINAL
HABITAT THE AGRICULTURAL
CONVERSION AND DEVELOP LIKEWISE
NEARLY HALF OF ALL CALIFORNIA
OAK SPECIES ARE CONSIDERED
THREATENED IN THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION FOR THE CONSERVATION OF
NATURE SPREAD BUT OF YOU
KNOW AND THE CONSERVATION OF OUR
NATIVE OAK IS A GLOBAL IMPORT
WE SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN OH FOUR
BECAUSE IT WILL ENSURE OAKS ARE
GIVEN THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
ANALYSIS ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REPORT AND ALTHOUGH WE HOPE
TO COMPARE THE REMAINING OUT
THIS LEGISLATION WILL SECURE
COMP COMPREHENSIVE MITIGATION
FORTY O'CLOCK GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR VOTING
YES ON THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
-- NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
-- JUST INDIVIDUALS AND
SUPPORT NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION WILL START WITH THE
HEARING ROOM SIR ANYBODY THAT
WISHES TO OFFER A POSITION IN
SUPPORT OF THE HEARING ROOM
SAYING NO ONE WILL GO TO
THE MODERATOR MODERATOR FEW
COULD QUEUE UP ANYONE WISHES
TO OFFER POSITION IN SUPPORT
AND JUST NAME ORGANIZATION
AND THE FACT THAT YOU SUPPORT
THE BILL MODERATOR TO SPEAK
THANK YOU JUST BECAUSE SUPPORT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME WE WILL GO OUT FOR
FIRST LINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT
GOOD MORNING I CAN TELL YOU
KNOW REPRESENTING THE DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND THEN THE FOURTEEN OH
FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER
LINE TWENTY NINE
HELLO SENATORS DIANNE OF
THOSE GRAND BOARD MEMBER
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES
AUDUBON SOCIETY WE HAVE OVER
THREE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS IN LA
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT
YOU WENT PASS JUST TO SUPPORT
YOU STARTED INTO THE BOAT
SO THIS WAS JUST TO OFFER
YOUR POSITIONS SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT
CALL LINE EIGHTY FOUR
ONE EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
I KNOW PRETTY DARK
WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ANGELA
MASCO I'M WITH CALIFORNIA
OAKS PROGRAM OF CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE FOUNDATION WE STAND
WITH SENATOR STERN IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOURTEEN OH FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU IT HAPPENS TO BE
SEATED RIGHT NOW BUT WE'RE GLAD
YOU STAND WITH HIM SO ARE WILL
MOVE ON MODERATOR TO THE NEXT
CALL WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I HAVE
NO -- NO WITNESSES LISTED
AS LEAD OPPOSITION BUT LET ME
GO TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SILVIO FOR
OUR AND WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
-- WERE OPPOSED AND CONSISTENT
WITH COMMENTS WE MADE AN
SENATE YOU LAST WEEK YOU KNOW
OUR OUR CONCERNS BOIL DOWN I
THINK RELATED TO SPECIFIC AREAS
FIRST IS IS THE BILL'S EFFORT
TO STATUTORILY DETERMINE A
THRESHOLD OF SIGNIFICANCE
THAT BEING THREE TREES FOR
PERSONS OF THE BILL -- THAT
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
GIVEN THE CLIMATIC THE GEOLOGIC
THE TOPOGRAPHIC THE DIVERSITY
OF OUR CALIFORNIA'S NATURE
WE DON'T THINK THAT MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE WE HAVE SIXTEEN CLIMATE
ZONES WHEN IT COMES TO ENERGY
EFFICIENCY WE HAVE FLOOD ZONES
WITH EARTHQUAKES AND WE HAVE A
HABITAT THAT IS VARIED THINGS
YOU GUYS ALL KNOW REALLY WELL
-- WE DO NOT THINK IT MAKES
SENSE TO STATUTORILY PUT THIS
INTO LAW WE ALSO HAVE EXAMPLES
FROM AGENCIES IN THE STATE
MOST NOTABLY PROBABLY -- -- PRD
OFF THE PLANET RESEARCH WHO HAS
BEEN PUSH BUT RESISTED DOING
A THRESHOLD OF SIGNIFICANCE
FOR V. M. T. BECAUSE THEY
RECOGNIZED THEIR NEEDS TO BE
A LEAD AGENCY WHICH IS VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED DRIED I LEFT
YOUR LET YOUR FIRST ACRONYM
GO BY THAT BUT I'M GONNA START
TO FIND YOU GOT IT ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU LIKE I WAS TRYING TO
ADD ON THE PREVIOUS BUT BUT I
COULDN'T FIGURE THAT ONE OUT
SO YES VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
-- AND I WOULD SAY LASTLY --
YOU KNOW LEADING AGENCIES ARE
THERE FOR A REASON THEY'RE THERE
LOCALLY THEY ARE THERE TO LOOK
AT PROJECTS AND FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MAKE IT WORK IN THE LOCATION
WHERE IT'S PROPOSED WE JUST
DON'T THINK WE CAN BE DOING AT
THE STATE LEVEL THANK YOU AND
LET YOU GO ON BECAUSE WE HAD
NO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS AND
I SUSPECT THE SECOND ONE COULD
BE AS WELL AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC
THE WORLD COUNTIES ON BEHALF OF
THIRTY NINE RURAL COUNTIES IN
THE STATE WE OPPOSE SB FORTINO
FOR TODAY WE DON'T DISPUTE THE
THE ECOSYSTEM BENEFITS OF OAKS
OR OAK WOODLANDS IN THE STATE
BUT WE THINK THIS IS THE WRONG
APPROACH FIRST ESTABLISHES
AN ARBITRARY ONE SIZE FITS
ALL STANDARD FOR DETERMINING
THE THRESHOLD OF SIGNIFICANCE
ACROSS THE STATE REGARDLESS
OF THE BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
AND REGIONAL DIVERSITY IN THE
STATE AND SECOND BECAUSE IT
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASES EQUAL
EDUCATION BY ELIMINATING A
SAFE HARBOR THAT EXIST IN
EXISTING LAW FOR PROJECTS
THAT HAVE INCLUDED MITIGATION
MEASURES IDENTIFIED BY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WE DON'T
THINK ARE AT SIGNIFICANT RISK
OF DEVELOPMENT OR CONVERSION
AND MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES
FOR OVER EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
FOLKS IN THE STATE AND YET THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES A THRESHOLD OF
THREE OAK TREES REGARDLESS OF
THE SIZE OF THE PROJECT TENTH
OF AN ACRE THOUSAND ACRES A
HUNDRED ACRES SO IF THE AUTHOR
WANTS TO TAKE A HARDER LOOK AT
WHAT SOME OF THOSE MITIGATION
MEASURES ARE AND HOW ADEQUATE
THEY ARE UNDER THE EXISTING
CONSTRUCT WE'RE HAPPY TO DO THAT
WERE LOOK AT AND SEE IF THOSE
EXISTING MITIGATION MEASURES
ARE WELL SUITED FOR SOME OF
THOSE TREES PIECES IDENTIFIED
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT HAVE
REPRODUCTION ISSUES HAPPEN TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS BUT
ESTABLISHING THE THRESHOLD AND
THEN ELIMINATING THE SAFE HARBOR
WE THINK IS A MISGUIDED APPROACH
WILL INCREASE THE THE COSTS
THE TIME FRAMES AND LITIGATION
RISK FOR PROJECTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE PUBLIC SAFETY PROJECTS
AND IF YOU COULD BEGIN TO WRAP
CERTAINLY -- LEVY MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS PARKS MAINTENANCE
PROJECT I KNOW YOUR FORMER
LEGISLATIVE STAFFER WHICH CHEN
GENERALLY THINKS THAT RIGHT SO
SO THANK YOU FOR INDULGING ME WE
OPPOSE FORTINO FOR HOPE THAT WE
CAN WORK OUT A BETTER SOLUTION
ON WAYS TO INCREASE MEDICATION
EFFECTIVENESS THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATED THE COMMENTS AND
NOW WE WILL MOVE TO JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION IN A STATEMENT OF
OPPOSITION MISTER MEMBERS THAT
RAN WITH THEIR IN RING ASSOCIATE
FOR PUTTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS PARDON MY TARDINESS
SAID TO RUN OVER TO JUDICIARY WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU -- YOU'RE IN SUPPORT YES
WE WILL NOTE THAT EVEN THOUGH
THIS IS OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WISHES TO COMMENT --
STATE IN OPPOSITION POSITION
SEEING NO ONE MODERATOR WILL
GO TO YOU PLEASE COULD QUEUE
UP ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION AND
THIS IS JUST A CHANCE TO DO
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
THE STATEMENT THAT YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME WELL
FIRST THE LINE ONE FIFTY TWO
APPLE CALIFORNIA YIMBY WE STAND
WITH OUR PARTNERS AT THE CIA IN
OPPOSITION AT THE WHAT YOU
KNOW POOR THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALL
LINE TWENTY NINE
DIANA'S -- GRANT AGAIN
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES
AUDUBON SOCIETY WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE OF AMENDMENT
TWO WHICH WOULD ADD TO THE
OR LINKAGE INTO THE SO YOU
DIDN'T USE THE WORD BUT BUT
YOU ARE STILL MAKING A RUN
ON SENTENCE SO JUST WE
APPRECIATE YOUR A STATEMENT IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR NEXT CALL
LINE ONE FIFTY THREE
GOOD MORNING THIS IS CONNOR
MEDINA WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY
THAT THE HELP WELL WE HAVE BOTH
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR NEXT CALL
NOPE REGARDING Q. WE APPRECIATE
THAT MODERATOR FOR HELP ON
THAT BILL WILL NOW BRING
THE MATTER BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS YOUR LIMóN AND AT
EACH YOU KNOW AT A HERE AS
THE OPPOSITION BUT THEY ALSO
WILL SAY THAT THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS AND A LITTLE
SPECIAL ANECDOTE IS THAT THERE
IS SOMEONE WHO IS A PART OF
THE TEAM WHO IS -- QUITE A
BIRD WATCHER AND HAS EXPRESSED
LOTS OF SUPPORT FOR THIS
PARTICULAR BILL SO I JUST WANTED
TO CALL THAT INTO THE AS AN
OUT YOU CAN GO BACK TO YOUR
OFFICE SAFELY NOW AND I WILL
MOVE THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE
I WILL TAKE THAT AS A MOTION
-- BUT LET ME -- THEN
RECOGNIZE MYSELF AND ASK --
ABOUT A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
OF THE THE FIRST ONE IS IS
ARM I KNOW JUST IN THE SEQUEL
PROCESS THAT IT PROVIDES
FOR CUMULATIVE ANALYSIS
-- THAT WOULD ADDRESS THE
CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF THE PROJECT
WHY NOT USE THAT PROCESS FOR
THIS WE WE
LOOK TO THE CUMULATIVE IMPACTS
-- FUNCTIONS IN CURRENT LAW
AND DO THE ISSUE IS THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE SAY ONE OR TWO --
S. STANDS OF OAKS THAT ARE
MAYBE SMALLER NATURE BUT THAT
YOU HAVE YOU SORT OF SEQUENCE
OUT THE PROJECT AND LOOK AT
IT SORT OF INDIVIDUALLY SAY
-- HOMEOWNERS WANTING TO TEAR
DOWN THEIR HOUSE AND BUILD THE
BIG NEWS STATE -- MAYBE
THEY'RE ONLY CUTTING DOWN THREE
OAKS IN THAT IN THAT REBUILD
CUMULATIVELY THAT EFFECT --
BECAUSE NOT PART OF A MUCH
LARGER PROJECT WOULDN'T TRIGGER
-- ANY ADDITIONAL MITIGATION
REQUIREMENTS IN WHICH SORT OF
DEFERRED THAT LOOPHOLE EARNED
NOT A LOOPHOLE BUT THE THE
SAFE HARBOR IF YOU WILL SO
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THERE'S
PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNERS A
BUDDING WILDLAND THAT HAVE
SORT OF WHAT MAY LOOK LIKE
A DE MINIMUS IMPACT BUT --
CUMULATIVELY IN A WAY THAT THE
CURRENT LAW DOESN'T RECOGNIZE
-- WILL BE SIGNIFICANT IN THEIR
IMPACT SO IT'S IT'S THAT THE
CURRENT LAWS AND CAPTURING --
THE INDIVIDUAL AFFECTS OF FOR
THOSE THOSE SORT OF PROJECT BY
PROJECT MITIGATION REQUIREMENTS
AND K. AS THE BILL MOVES ALONG
PROVIDING IT DOES I HOPE YOU
CONSIDER THAT IF THAT TURNS
OUT TO BE SOME TENSION TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF MY
OTHER QUESTION HAPPENS TO DO A
COMMENT THAT I MADE ON SENATOR
MANSFIELD BEGINNING BECAUSE THE
ANALYSIS REFERS TO THIS IS A
WORK IN PROGRESS AND I WAS GOING
TO SAY WHAT DOES THAT MEAN ARE
YOU ACTUALLY MEETING WITH PEOPLE
DO YOU HAVE A PATH TO GET TO THE
END ASSERT TIME THIS WILL STOP
BEING A WORK IN PROGRESS YES
I WANTED THAT TIME TO BE TODAY
BUT -- I WILL SAY THAT
-- IF THIS BILL IS FOR TO
APPROPRIATIONS I DON'T WANT
TO MOVE THIS BILL OFF THE
FLOOR WITHOUT NARROWING
THE SCOPE AND NOT HAVING A
SORT OF GENERAL DESCRIPTION
OF THE KINDS OF AREAS THAT ARE
BEING MAPPED THE THE CATCH
ALL RIGHT NOW IS WHEN THERE'S
LOCAL OR STATE ADOPTED MAPS
THAT ARE CRITICAL HABITAT
LINKAGE RESOURCE PROTECTION OR
OTHERWISE RELATED BIODIVERSITY
CONSERVATION RECOGNIZE THAT'S
OPEN ENDED THE REFINEMENT
THAT WE'RE INTERESTED IN IS
-- WE'RE LOOKING AT CDFW MAPS
IN SPECIFIC AREAS FOR --
FIRST SORT OF CRITICAL HABITAT
CORRIDORS WE'RE LOOKING AT SORT
OF CALLING OUT SPECIFIC MAPS
AND SORT OF NOTING SPECIFIC
AREAS AS OPPOSED TO SORT OF
LEAVING IT OPEN ENDED FOR A
JURISDICTION TO ADOPT ANYTHING
THERE IS A CERTAIN THERE IS
CURRENTLY AN OAK WOODLANDS
CONSERVATION ACT THAT ALLOWS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO ADOPT
SOME OF THESE -- THESE SORT
OF BROADER OAK WOODLAND
SAVANNA PROTECTIONS -- SO THAT
COULD BE AN AREA ALSO LOOK AT
THE HABITAT LINKAGE MAP THAT
-- IN THE LOS ANGELES AREA AT
LEAST THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY IS ADOPTED AND
WHETHER THERE'S ANY ANALOG SO WE
DON'T WANT TO JUST CALL OUT THAT
HABITAT LINKAGE MAP PER SE WANT
TO SEE IF THERE'S SOME ANALOG
AND A FEW OTHER JURISDICTIONS
BECAUSE WE WOULDN'T WANT TO JUST
LIMIT THE APPLICATION ONLY TO
TO LOS ANGELES JUST BECAUSE THE
CONSERVANCY ADOPTED THAT MAP
BUT THAT SEEMS LIKE A PRETTY
GOOD START FOR A FOUNDATION --
AND THEN YEAH MAYBE WE CAN
SORT OF MARY THAT TO WHERE
CDFW IS MAPSCO BETWEEN THE
COMBINATION OF THOSE TWO THEN
THE STAKEHOLDERS WELL ACTUALLY
NO OKAY DEEP OUT TO RURAL AREAS
IF YOU'RE BUILDING A STANDALONE
PROJECT THAT'S NOT CONNECTED
TO A GREATER OAK WOODLAND AND
YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO BUILD
SOME AFFORDABLE HOUSING OUT
THERE WE'RE NOT TOUCHING YOU AND
WE DON'T WE REALLY DON'T WANT
THIS TO BE ANY IMPEDIMENT --
TO THAT HOUSING GROWTH FRANKLY
JUST WANT ADEQUATE MITIGATION
AND WE HOPE THAT THE DEVELOPMENT
COMMUNITY IS UP FOR DOING THAT
MITIGATION AND NOT JUST -- YOU
KNOW HIDING THE SAFE HARBOR SO
-- THAT'S THE THAT'S
HOPEFULLY WHERE WILL LAND BY
APPROPRIATIONS AND --
BUT I'M I'M SORRY THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THAT FINAL LANGUAGE IRONED
OUT FOR TODAY WELL THEN LET
ME JUST SAY I APPRECIATE THAT
RESPONSE BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REFINE THE SAID
AND GET TO THE END AND SECONDLY
JUST BEFORE HOPEFULLY
MOVING TO THE CLOSE ARM
I WOULD SAY THERE WAS A COMMENT
MADE DURING THE TESTIMONY
THAT FOLKS ARE NOT AT RISK AND
IT'S I WOULD INVITE YOU TO SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTY WHERE THERE
WAS A RATHER HORRIFIC PROJECT
WHERE A FEW HUNDRED ACRES
WERE CLEAR CUT OF THE OAKS AND
CAUSED A FIRESTORM POLITICALLY
OF A FEW YEARS AGO IT WAS A
BIG ISSUE SO ARE THERE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS BEFORE WE
-- ALLOW FOR THE AUTHOR
TO CLOSE WE HAVE A MOTION
MISSING NINE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YET THANK YOU FOR THE
COLLOQUY AND -- THANK YOU FOR
THE INPUT FROM STAKEHOLDERS
AND FOR WHOEVER'S ON THE LINE
WHO HAD A BUT IN THERE COMMENT
I AM PLEASED TO FOLLOW UP
WE WANT TO DIG INTO WHATEVER
THAT CONCERN MAY BE BUT --
LOOK FORCING DOWN BEFORE
APPROPRIATIONS AND IRONING OUT
THE FINAL DETAILS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS BILL DOES WHAT IT SAYS
WHICH IS STOP THE DEATH BY A
THOUSAND CUTS ENSURE ADEQUATE
MITIGATION OF THIS CRITICAL
HABITAT -- BUT IN NO WAY IMPEDE
ANY SORT OF PUBLIC SAFETY --
PROJECTS -- ANY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OR HOUSING PROJECTS THAT
WILL BE IMPORTANT AND HOPEFULLY
MOVE BOTH ARE ENVIRONMENTAL
AND OUR HOUSING GOES FORWARD IN
UNISON WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR LAMONT WHAT
THE CONSULTANT PLEASE STATE THE
MOTION AND CALL THE ROLL FILE
ITEM TWELVE SP FORTINO FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
STERN STERN ALL RIGHT JONES
ALLEN ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN
EGGMAN ON A HERTZBERG HUESO
HUESO I LAYERED HI
LEARN I LOVE MON MON ARI
OKAY THAT MEASURE SIX VOTES
WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS I
SEE SENATOR CORTESE I'M
OKAY COME ON UP I DON'T SEE
SENATOR DODD HERE YET BUT I
WOULD GIVE A HE STILL CHAIRING
OKAY ALL RIGHT AND I THINK B.
AFTER CENTER CORTESE THAT'LL
BE IT'LL BE CENTER DOT AND
THEN THAT'S THAT'S IT SO
-- WERE ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN MEMBERS THIS IS SB
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN CORTESE
WELCOME MORNING -- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALMOST NOON
YES -- HAPPY ALMOST NOON
IN THE AND HELLO CLOTURE IS A
CENTERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA TAKES A LEADERSHIP
ROLE IN ADVANCING CLIMATE
RESTORATION BY TAKING STEPS TO
MINIMIZE EMBODIED CARBON AND
MAXIMIZE CARBON SEQUESTRATION
THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT CO
TWO CAN BE STORED IN OUR
BUILT ENVIRONMENTS INCLUDING
ROADS AND BUILDINGS THESE
STRATEGIES PROVIDE VALUABLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO STORE CARBON
ENORMOUS POTENTIAL TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
PRIORITIES SB TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN WILL REQUIRE THE
STATE TO DEVELOP A PLAN AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO MINIMIZE
EMBODIED CARBON AND MAXIMIZE
CARBON SEQUESTRATION AND
BUILDING MATERIALS NOTABLY
THIS WOULD GREATLY EXPAND THE
REACH OF OUR STATE'S CURRENT
EMBODIED CARBON REDUCTION GOALS
INCLUDE MATERIALS SUCH AS CEMENT
CONCRETE AGGREGATE LUMBER CROSS
LAMINATED TIMBER STEEL IN MORE
OUR BUILT ENVIRONMENT IS A
LARGE GHG EMITTER AS WE ALL
KNOW IN BODY CARBON WE'RE
GHG EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
PRODUCING AND USING BUILDING
MATERIALS ACCOUNTS FOR AT LEAST
ELEVEN PERCENT OF GLOBAL CARBON
EMISSIONS SB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN FOLLOWS AN ANNOUNCEMENT
AT THE RECENT TWENTY TWENTY ONE
UNITED NATIONS CLIMATE CHANGE
CONFERENCE IN GLASCO SCOTLAND
WE'RE I THINK THE SENATE WAS
WELL REPRESENTED A FROM THE
PACIFIC COAST COOPERATIVE
THAT PARTNERING JURISDICTIONS
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA WILL
WORK TO ACCELERATE INNOVATION
INVESTMENT AND MARKET
DEVELOPMENT FOR LOW CARBON
MATERIALS IT ALSO COMES
ON THE HEELS OF THE RECENT
ANNOUNCEMENT BY THE BY THE
MINISTRIES REGARDING NEW ACTIONS
TO ADVANCE PRODUCTION USE OF
LOW CARBON BUILDING MATERIALS
MADE IN AMERICA AND GUIDANCE
ON THE RESPONSIBLE DEPLOYMENT
OF CARBON CAPTURE UTILIZATION
AND SEQUESTRATION TO HELP
ACHIEVE A CARBON NEUTRAL CONNIE
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT FOR THIS
COMMITTEE THAT WE'VE ACCEPTED
THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENT PROPOSED
BY THE COMMITTEE NOTED ON PAGE
SEVEN OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
TO CLARIFY THE TIMELINE OF THIS
BILL WE'VE ALSO CROSSED SEVERAL
AUTHOR AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION TO ENSURE THE
BUILDING MATERIAL IS CAPABLE OF
BEING INSTALLED IN A SUCCESSFUL
MANNER WITHIN A REASONABLE
PERIOD OF TIME TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT
LEGAL SOCIAL AND TECHNOLOGICAL
FACTORS AND WE'RE CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS A WITH THE CBI IS
WILL BUT WITH US TODAY
IS -- TERRY Q. REPRESENTING
THE FOUNDATION FOR CLIMATE
RESTORATION TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AS WELL AS LAURA BERLIN SHEEN
REPRESENTING BLUE PLANET THANK
YOU IN -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE BOTH SO -- CENTER
FOR DISEASE I DON'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT THE BILL PRESENTATION
BUT I THINK THERE'S A
LEADERSHIP'S NOTIFY ME THAT
THERE'S THERE'S A A CONFLICTING
PRESENTATION OCCURRING ANOTHER
COMMITTEE IN THAT THEY WANT US
TO TO RECESS ON THIS ITEM BEFORE
WE FINISH FULL PRESENTATION
AND TAKE VOTES ON IT SO --
IF THAT'S ALRIGHT WITH YOU
-- CAN WE PUT PUT A PIN IN IT
RIGHT WHERE YOU WORK WHERE YOU
LEFT OFF AND I APOLOGIZE TO
THE LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES AS
WELL -- BUT WE'RE GONNA PUT
PUT A PIN IN THIS COMEBACK
AFTER RECESSING THERE'LL BE
ONE MORE ITEM AFTER THAT --
THE
ONE OF THE THIS ONE
HUNDRED I DON'T MEAN CAMPUS
ACTUALLY ONE I USED I WOULD
BUT
THIS IS A REFERENCE TO FORMER
ASSEMBLY WHAT WOULD NEVER
EXISTED I CAN HONESTLY OF THE
LEAD WITNESSES TO -- ABBREVIATE
THEIR COMMENTS OF THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL OR MAKE MAKE THEMSELVES
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO JUST KNOW THAT THEY WERE HERE
AND YET THEY'RE AVAILABLE FOR
OKAY SO SO IF THAT'S POSSIBLE
FOR LEASE PORT WITNESSES CAN
WE CAN WE JUST COUNT YOU AS
THE LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES
AND THEN OFFER YOU IS --
TECHNICAL SUPPORT FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS OF MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS HOPE THAT'S OKAY
ABSOLUTELY OKAY -- AND APOLOGIES
THANK YOU FOR ACCOMMODATING
-- AND I DON'T HAVE ANY --
-- LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES
BUT -- FOR PURPOSES OF
THE DISCUSSION DO WE HAVE ANY
ANY OTHERS WHO FEEL A BURNING
NEED TO TESTIFY IN GENERAL
SUPPORT IDEALLY WE CAN JUST
MOVE IT TO MEMBER DISCUSSION
BUT MODERATOR IF THERE'S ANYONE
ON THE LINE WHO DESPERATELY
NEEDS TO TESTIFYING GENERAL
SUPPORT -- YES THE -- PASCAL
FINDING SUPPORT YOU SURE DID
MODERATOR WE ARE ABOUT
LINE ONE THIRTY FOUR
YEAH MISTER MEMBERS
MICHAEL GUNNING A. B. I. A.
AT THE OFFICERS MENTIONED WE
ARE STILL OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
BUT HE HAS TAKEN AMENDMENTS
WERE APPRECIATE UP AND CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH HIM OKAY YOU
THANKS FOR THAT ANY OTHERS
NO FOR THE LINES INTO AT THIS
TIME OKAY VERY GOOD I'M JUST
TURNING TO THE GENERAL HEARING
ROOM ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM THAT WAS TO TESTIFY
SEEING NONE ANY OTHERS ON THE
LINE IT WAS TESTIFYING MODERATOR
CAN YOU GO BY IN OPPOSITION
THE TESTIFIED OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME BEFORE
OKAY SEEING NINE BRING BACK
TO THE ICE MEMBERS COMMENTS
OR EMOTION I MAKE A MOTION TO
MOVE THIS BILL OKAY SIR LIMóN
MAKES A MOTION SEEING NO FURTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS SECRETASE
VALUE TO CLOSE I THANK YOU THANK
YOU THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH SO WELL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU ON
THANK YOU FOR THAT TRUNCATED
PRESENTATION I DO APPRECIATE
THE WITNESSES TESTIMONY AND
AND BUT AUTHORS WORK HERE --
CHIEF CONSULTANT MOTION IS
WE GOT A YOU CAN READ
ABOUT IT FILE ITEM S. B.
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
STERN STERN I'D JONES ALLEN
ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN
EGGMAN ON A HERTZBERG HUESO
LAYERED LAYERED I LOAN LOAN
ONLINE THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES
OKAY THANKS -- WE'LL WE'LL
TAKE A RECESS FOR CAUCUS AND
WE BACK AFTERWARDS THANK YOU
WELCOME BACK -- ADVISE
ALL MEMBERS AND AFTER RESOURCE
COMMITTEE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR OUR LAST ITEM HERE ON THE
AGENDA TODAY -- SENATOR DODD IS
WITH US BUT WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AS WE AWAIT A FULL
QUORUM WELCOME
SENATOR DODD A YOU HAVE A
FILE ITEM FIVE S. B. EIGHT
FIVE TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBER
SB A FIFTY TWO WOULD AUTHORIZE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO FORM
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE FINANCING
DISTRICTS TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE AT THE LOCAL OR REGIONAL
LEVEL I AM ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AS SHOWN ON PAGE
EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS I THANK
THE CONSULTANT FOR HER WORK
ON THE BILL I ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WILL BE MEETING WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES TO ADDRESS
THEIR SUGGESTED AMENDMENT FOR
LAST SEVERAL YEARS THE STATE
HAS RESPONDED TO CLIMATE CHANGE
BY APPROPRIATING BILLIONS TO
FUND A VARIETY OF PROGRAMS THAT
SEEK TO PREVENT AND PROTECT OUR
STATE FROM CLIMATE CHANGE DANGER
THANK YOU KNOW I GOT ON THE
PHONE AND I TOOK EVERYTHING
OUT THEY TOOK EVERYTHING OUT
AMAZING IN
IN SOME AREAS SUCH AS THE
ONE I REPRESENT THE THREAT
OF WILDFIRES OF PARAMOUNT
IMPORTANCE IN SOME COMMUNITIES
THE MOST SERIOUS THREAT
RESULTS FROM SEA LEVEL RISE
IN YET ANOTHER COMMUNITIES
EXTREME HEAT EVENTS HEAT
EVENTS POSE THE GREATEST DANGER
SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO WILL PROVIDE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES WITH JUST YET
ANOTHER TOOL TO PUT IN THEIR
TOOL KITS TO HELP COPE IMPROVE
THAT CLIMATE RELATED DISASTERS
THAT ARE MOST CRITICAL TO THEM
VERY SIMPLY EIGHT FIFTY TWO
PERMITS CITIES AND COUNTIES
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS TO
WORK AS A JOINT ENDEAVOR TO
DEVELOP PLANS TO ADDRESS THEIR
HIGHEST LOCAL CLIMATE CHANGE
PRIORITIES AND GENERATE REVENUE
TO IMPLEMENT THOSE PLANTS
NOTHING IN THIS BILL MANDATES
FORMATION OF THE DISTRICT AND
NOTHING IN THIS BILL CHANGES
THE CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS
FOR VOTER APPROVAL AND PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION WE'RE VOTER
APPROVAL AND PARTICIPATION ARE
NOW REQUIRED WITH ME TODAY ARE
FORMER IS OR ARE FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROGER DICKINSON
WHO NOW SERVES THE PUBLIC POLICY
DIRECTOR OF CIVIC WELL AND
MIKE PEARSON DEPUTY INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER FOR CLIMATE AND
SUSTAINABILITY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS THANK YOU SIR DODD
WELCOME DECEMBER MEREDITH'S
-- GROWING OLDER BY THE MOMENT
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND AND MEMBER --
-- AS CENTER DODD MENTIONED
I'M ROGER DICKINSON THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR CIVIC WELL FORMERLY
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION
-- AND ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF
SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO -- CENTER
DOT HAS WELL DESCRIBED THE BILL
AND I WANT TO THANK HIM FOR HIS
HIS LEADERSHIP SB EIGHT FIFTY
TWO IS DESIGNED TO ACCOMPLISH
SEVERAL OBJECTIVES INCLUDING
THE FOLLOWING ONE PROVIDE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND REGIONS WITH THE
ABILITY ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS
TO PUT A SPOTLIGHT ON CLIMATE
ACTION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
REGIONS THE STRUCTURAL MEANS TO
WORK ON CLIMATE IN A SUSTAINED
CERTAIN AND PREDICTABLE MANNER
THREE PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
OPTIMIZE STATE LOCAL FEDERAL
AND PRIVATE RESOURCES TO
MEET CLIMATE CHALLENGES MOST
IMPORTANT TO THEIR COMMUNITY
FOUR GIVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FLEXIBILITY IN ADOPTING THE
RIGHT FINANCING APPROACH FOR
THEIR NEEDS AND COMMUNITY AND
FIVE GIVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND REGIONS THE FLEXIBILITY
TO PLAN AND IMPLEMENT THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY PROJECTS AND
PROGRAMS IN THEIR LOCALITY
WHILE THE STATE HAS ENACTED
PROGRAMS AND MADE INVESTMENTS
TO MEET THE INCREASING URGENCY
OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS TAKEN
RECENT STEPS TO ALSO DO SO
FAR LESS ATTENTION HAS BEEN
PAID TO DEVELOPING A COHESIVE
AND COORDINATED APPROACH AT
THE LOCAL AND REGIONAL LEVEL
AS THE GOVERNOR'S CLIMATE
ADAPTATION STRATEGY RECENTLY
RELEASED EMPHASIZED PARTNERSHIPS
COORDINATION AND COLLABORATION
IN OUR EFFORTS TO BUILD CLIMATE
RESILIENCE ARE ESSENTIAL
GIVEN THE DIVERSITY OF THREATS
CALIFORNIA FACES AND THE
VAST ARRAY OF ENTITIES THAT
ARE FOCUSED ON BUILDING OUR
RESILIENCE THROUGH THESE THREATS
ALL ENTITIES FROM INDIVIDUALS TO
TRIBAL LOCAL REGIONAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR HOLD A PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE AND MUST WORK TOGETHER TO
LEVERAGE EACH OTHER'S STRENGTHS
AND ACTIONS IN RESPONSE TO THE
CLIMATE CRISIS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
WE'LL NOW TURN TO OUR SECOND
SUPPORT WITNESS MISTER PETERSON
OKAY THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON SIR STERN BOETTCHER
JONES AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- THANK MICHAEL
PETERSON DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
AND CLIMATE WITHIN ABILITY
BEHALF OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE AT THE
BILL'S CO SPONSOR COMMISSION
LARA WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR DON TRANSLATOR SHIP IN
OFTEN IT'S IMPORTANT CLIMATE
RESILIENCE THE MEASURE IN JULY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE COMPANY
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE RELEASED
THE CRIME INSURANCE REPORT
TITLED PROTECTING COMMUNITIES
FOR THEIR IN NATURE AND BUILDING
RESILIENCE AS A WAY TO COMBAT
THE COSTS OF WILDFIRES EXTREME
HEAT AND FLOOD THE REPORT WITH
THE WORK OF THE CRIME INSURANCE
WORKING GROUP CONVENED BY
COMMISSIONER LARA AND TWENTY
NINETEEN AND COMPRISED OF
INTERNAL ADVOCATES RESEARCHERS
AND INSURANCE EXPERTS THE
PRESENTED FORTY RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR VARIOUS POLICIES TO REDUCE
THE COSTS FROM WILDFIRES EXTREME
HEAT AND FLOODING AMONG OTHER
CHALLENGES LIKE THE LEVEL RISE A
STRONG MESSAGE COMING OUT OF THE
CRIME INSURANCE REPORT WITH THAT
IN ORDER TO IMPROVE INSURANCE
AVAILABILITY RELIABILITY AND
AFFORDABILITY CALIFORNIA NEEDS
COMMUNITY MEDICATIONS IMPROVED
DRAMATICALLY THE WORKING GROUP
EMPATHIZE WITH THE IMPORTANCE
OF LOCALIZED CREATED AFTER
MITIGATION THAT FOCUSES ON
WETLAND COURSE MANAGEMENT AND
URBAN FOREST IN ORDER TO REDUCE
THE IMPACT OF THE SEVERE STORMS
FLOODING WILDFIRES YOU OF ALL
RIGHT AND EXTREME HEAT THAT
THEY RECOMMENDED THE CREATION
OF SPECIAL CHOIR IS GOING TO
DISTRICT FOCUSED ON THE CLIMATE
POLLUTION I AM HAPPY TO CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL BOUNDARIES
AND BECAUSE OF THAT THESE
HAZARDS ARE PASSED THE DRAFT
POLITICALLY AT THE REGIONAL
COMMUNITY AND LANDSCAPE
SCALE RATHER THAN KEEP MAIL
JURISDICTION BY JURISDICTION
SB EIGHT FIFTEEN TO WHATEVER
COUNTRY BEARS THE CLIMATE
ADAPTATION FIRST THE NEED FOR
FINANCING ENTERED INTO RUSSIA
USER IF YOU DON'T MIND JUST
WE'RE AT THE END OF OUR TIME
FUTURES WRAP UP DO APPRECIATE
ATTACHED MONEY THOUGH EARLY
AT THE POLITICALLY AT THAT
THEIR WORK AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON ITS
FEET IF YOU DO THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND PLEASE THANK INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AS WELL -- WE
ARE NOW TURNING GENERAL SUPPORT
ANY ANY HEARING ROOM WHICH
TESTIFIED IN GENERAL SUPPORT
FOR A FIFTY TWO WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON STEVE WALK ON BEHALF
THE NAPA VALLEY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT OKAY THANK
YOU OTHERS SEEING NONE TURN THE
LINES MODERATOR KILLED ANYONE
IS WISHING TESTIFYING GENERAL
SUPPORT FOR YOUR SB FIFTY TWO
THANK YOU OPEN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
-- CRYSTALLINE TWENTY
FIVE THE BILL HAS ALRP
ENTRY HADN'T BECAUSE AREA
ACTION WE FOR JUST EIGHT FIFTY
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
AND ONCE AGAIN THIS PRESS ONE
THE DURAL IN THE QUEUE UP IN
SUPPORT NO FOR
THE LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANKS I WILL TURN ANY
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM -- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY LISTED FOR LEAD
OPPOSITION SO SEEING NONE WILL
TURN OF THE LINE'S MODERATOR
TO HAVE ANYONE IN GENERAL
OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY TWO
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND THERE ARE CURRENTLY
NO LINE'S GOING UP OKAY
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
DICE MEMBERS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS IN AN CHEN MOTION
HE'S MOTION FROM CENTER
HERTZBERG APPRECIATE BRING
HIS MEASURE FORWARD --
THE DESIGN ON GREAT CO
AUTHOR THIS AND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO KNOW COMMITTEES
GET WORKS WE LOOK AT THINGS
LIKE HARDENING CAN JUST DO
IT HOME BY HOME HEALTH IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR STARTS
INVEST YOUR TOO SO I THINK
THIS WILL BE REALLY IMPORTANT
HE'S LEGISLATION APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING IT FORWARD --
WE
WHEN WE NEED ONE MORE TO GET
A QUORUM SO WILL ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE AND THEN WILL ESTABLISH
QUORUM AFTERWARDS AND TAKE A
VOTE WHICH IS LIKE THE LONG
CLOSE OR YEAH ONCE YOU EXTEND
YOUR CLOTHES -- WELL WE TRY
TO GET THE NEXT PERSON SHOWS
THAT WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I'VE THANK YOU FOR
I WILL PUT YOUR STAFF THROUGH
THE U. K. ALL RIGHT WILL
WILL WILL IN THAT A PRESENTATION
THERE AND WE'LL WAIT FOR MEMBERS
TO ESTABLISH CORPSMAN AND CLOSE
UP THE REST THANKS THANK YOU
THAT YEAH MAYBE LESS
THAT IS THE LAST
YOU KNOW FOR MORE
IT'S GOING TO BE LIKE A
CONSULTANT SAY THAT'S COVERED
UNDER I THINK IT'S COVERED
IT'S COVERED IT'S WHAT THE
WORLD YEAH THEY THEY ASK FOR A
SPECIFIC PROJECT STRONG
IN THEIR STRUCTURE THAT MAKES
FOR STRUCTURE FIRE AND WE'RE
TRYING TO SO YOU'RE NOT SEPARATE
I SEE RIGHT OKAY THEY CAN DO
IT VIDEO UNDER EXISTING LAWS
THAT USE THIS APPROACH
I THINK IF THEY WANTED
TO LOOK UNDER THE LINE OF
SERVICE WE JUST DIDN'T WANT MY
ROOMMATE GOT IT SEEMS MARC
OKAY COOL ALL THIS WAS A
IS ALL YEAH
THEY JUST THEY WEREN'T ON THE
ANNOUNCES THAT ARE SUPPORTING
YEAH OKAY
OKAY LET'S -- LET'S ESTABLISH
A QUORUM HERE -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OKAY STERN HERE
STERN HERE JONES JONES
HERE ALLEN ALLEN HERE EGGMAN
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HERE HUESO
LAWYERS -- HERE ALONE
HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM OKAY VERY
GOOD CORN BEING ESTABLISHED
LET'S FIRST CALL THE ROLL ON
THE BILL JUST PRESENTED FROM
SENATOR DODD THAT WAS ITEM
FIVE THAT'S SB FIVE SORRY
EIGHT FIVE TWO AND THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FILE ITEM FIVE SP EIGHT FIFTY
TO THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS STERN HI STERN
ALRIGHT JONES JONES NO ALLEN
ALLEN ALL RIGHT EGGMAN
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HIGHWAY
SO LAYERED LAYERED I LOAN
LIMóN ALL RIGHT OKAY
THE MEASURE HAS FIVE VOTES
WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND DON'T CONFUSE
AFTER THAT THE NEW
OVER PUBLIC SAFETY
IT'S JUST THAT
YEAH THANK YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY RIGHT ALL THE
WHAT WILL WILL WILL WILL OF
LOCAL YEAH WE'RE GONNA LIFT
THE CALLS ON ON THE ON THE
THE BILL STILL CURRENTLY
ON CALL YOU BOTH HAVE
NO WE HAD PRIOR WE HAD A QUORUM
SHARON BECAUSE WE WERE YES SO
-- AND MAYBE AS YOU ROLL THROUGH
YOU CAN JUST NOTE THE VOTE COUNT
CURRENTLY ON THE MEASURES --
LET'S START WITH ITEM ONE --
MEN SB NINE FIFTY THREE FILE
ITEM ONE S. B. NINE FIFTY THREE
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO
JONES JONES NO HUESO
THAT HAS STILL HAS FIVE
OKAY WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON
CALL SB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
THE MON FILE ITEM TO SB
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE ZERO JONES
JONES NO EGGMAN HUESO
OKAY ELLIE PUT THAT BACK ON CALL
ITEM THREE SB ELEVEN A ONE
COMING YEAR FILE ITEM THREE SB
ELEVEN OH ONE THE CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE ZERO JONES JONES
YEAH ALL RIGHT EGGMAN HUESO
IT HAS SIX NOW K. WILLIE PUT
THAT BACK ON CALL SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX ITEM FOR SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY FILE ITEM FOR SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX THE CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE ZERO JONES JONES
ALL RIGHT EGGMAN HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HIGHWAYS ALONE
LIMóN ALL RIGHT OKAY
SIX IS THAT IS THAT OUT IS
THAT WHEN VOTED ON THAT ONE NO
SENATORS AND SENATOR CHRIS OKAY
WE'LL PUT IT BACK ON CALL THEN
-- THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND
SINCE GOING THE CONCERN
HONORED COUNTER FINALIZES
SIX SEVEN EIGHT AND NINE
JONES JONES HI HUESO
SO IT THAT HAS SAID OKAY WE'LL
PUT IT BACK ON CALLED ITEM
TEN SB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN
FIVE EQUITIES A YES WE JUST
AT THE TOP THIS ONE YET YEAH
-- YES WHEN YOU VOTED ON YEAH
REQUIRED IN TEN SB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN RIGHT THE CURRENT VOTERS
FIVE ZERO JONES JONES
KNOWS HERTZBERG HERTZBERG RIGHT
HUESO WITH THAT ON CALL FILE
ITEM ELEVEN SB TWELVE SIXTY
ONE CURRENT MOOD IS TWO ZERO
-- JONES JON SNOW ALLEN
ALLEN I EGGMAN HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG ALRIGHT WE SO LONG
HI THERE HAS GLORIA OKAY
AND THEN -- PUT THAT
BACK ON CALL THEN FILE
AN TWELVE S. MARTINO FOR
CURRENT MOOD IS SIX ZERO TWO
JONES JONES NO HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG ARI THAT HAS
SEVEN AND THERE'S OUT
OKAY THAT MEASURES OUT
SO WE ARE WAITING FOR
I DON'T REMEMBER MEMBERS WITH
UNRECORDED VOTES ARE EGGMAN AND
HUESO YES SO WE'LL
WE'LL RUN THROUGH ONCE CENTER
WAYS AGAIN SETTLED WILL WILL IF
THE CALLS FOR HIM AND THEN WE'LL
WE'LL WAIT FOR SENATOR EGGMAN
HOWEVER I MAY NEED TO PASS THE
GAVEL BECAUSE I HAVE TO GO SO
LET'S LIVE THE CALLS ON FILE
ITEM ONE S. B. NINE FIFTY THREE
THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TO ONE
HUESO HUESO NO
THAT THAT IS FIVE TWO IS ON
MEASURES OUT FILE ITEM TO
SB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE TO ONE
EGGMAN HUESO HUESO
HI OKAY SIX THE MEASURE
THE OUT -- -- DID DID
-- SEGMENT IS NOT VOTE ON THIS
SHE'S NOT A FLUKE OKAY VERY
GOOD WILL EVEN CALL FILE ITEM
THREE S. B. ELEVEN OH ONE
THE CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ZERO
EGGMAN HUESO HUESO
ONLINE HAS SEVEN OKAY
NEXT FILE ITEM FOLLOWING FOR
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX THE
CURRENT GOAL IS SIX ZERO EGGMAN
HUESO HUESO ALL RIGHT SEVEN
FILE ITEM FIVE SB EIGHT FIFTY
TO THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ONE
EGGMAN HUESO HUESO ARI
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THE CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN
ZERO HUESO HUESO AYE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
FILE ITEM TEN TWELVE S.
B. TWELVE NINETY SEVEN THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
FIVE SIX SIX ONE HUESO
HUESO I'D THAT BILLS I DON'T
-- THIS IS FILE ITEM ELEVEN SB
TWELVE SIXTY ONE THE CURRENT
VOTERS FIVE ONE EGGMAN
WE SO WE SO ARI
FILE ITEM TWELVE SP FOURTEEN
-- FOR THE THAT -- THAT THAT
MEASURES OUT WE ARE WITH
OKAY SO PUT THOSE MEASURES
BACK ON CALL LEAVE IT FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBER -- AND THE GAVEL
WILL STAY WITH THE VICE CHAIR
THIS JUDICIAL -- PERSONALLY BUT
-- OVER THREE WHAT IS YOUR
LOTUS POSE OR YEAH I WAS JUST
TALKING HER FOR YEAH LASWELL'S
MORE TWO YEARS IF YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON
WE ARE GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS
ON THE REMAINING VOTES AND
I THINK WE ONLY HAVE A FEW
LEFT THAT'S RIGHT IN IT --
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO OPEN
THE ROLE AND CALL THE ROLL ON
THE REMAINING ITEMS OKAY FILE
ITEM TO SB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
THE CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ONE
EGGMAN EGGMAN ALL RIGHT THAT
IS SEVEN ONE IS OUT FILE
ITEM THREE S. B. ELEVEN OH ONE
THE CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO
EGGMAN EGGMAN ALL RIGHT THAT'S
EIGHT ZERO THAT ITEM IS OUT
FILE ITEM FOR SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX A CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO
EGGMAN EGGMAN ALL RIGHT THAT
IS EIGHT ZERO THAT ITEM IS OUT
FILE ITEM FIVE SB EIGHT FIFTY
TO THE CURRENT VOTE IS SIX
ONE EGGMAN EGGMAN ISLAND
SEVEN ONE THAT ITEM IS OUT
AND THERE'S ONE MORE FILE
ITEM ELEVEN S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
ONE THE CURRENT VOTE IS SIX ONE
EGGMAN EGGMAN ALL RIGHT THAT IS
SEVEN ONE THAT ITEM IS I DON'T
AND THAT COMPLETES OUR AGENDA
GIPSON ARE GOING ON CONTENT
YES HE WAS OPEN SO THAT --
COMPLETES THE BUSINESS FOR
THE NATURAL SOURCES A COMMITTEE
FOR TODAY WE ARE JOINED